learn the foundational elements of a
microservices architecture with net by
building a real microservices-based
application
julio is an excellent teacher and has
created many popular.net courses
welcome to
buildingmicroserviceswith.net the basics
my name is julio gasal and i'll be your
instructor through these first steps in
your mac services learning journey with
the.net platform
before we move on to learn about
microservices i'd like to walk you
through the fictional client application
that drives the requirements for the
backend system that you will build the
high level architecture of the system
and the technology stack that will be
used across this course
let's imagine a video game where the
player will need to acquire a series of
items to stay healthy become stronger
and survive the multiple changes that
await him in his adventures
there will be a series of stores that
will allow the player to purchase items
like potions antidotes and even source
and shields
these items have a price
to purchase them the player will need to
present the right amount of some sort of
currency that we will just call jill
once the player successfully purchases
an item it then goes into his inventory
back where it will be available for him
whenever he needs it
now the client side of this game
the app that runs in the player's device
is already being built by your company's
client team so you don't have to worry
about it and in fact this client app is
not part of this course
our team has been chartered with
building the backend services for this
game
which the client will heavily depend on
to be able to store the items catalog
the player's deal and inventory and to
enable the in-game purchase experience
let's now look at the high-level
architecture of the
system support the client applications
the following microservices-based
architecture has been designed
at the core we have identified four
microservices
catalog which owns the list of items
available for purchase
inventory which keeps track of the
quantity of items that a player owns
identity which manages the list of
players and also acts as an identity
provider
and trading which owns the purchase
process that can grant inventory items
in exchange for jill
each of these services have their own
database that has no relationship with
other databases and that are of
exclusive use by the owning service
for inter-service communication the
system makes use of a message broker
which allows the services to collaborate
by polishing and consuming messages
asynchronously
for the clients to interact with the
microservices this architecture has an
api gateway which provides a lot of
flexibility to make changes to the
services without impacting the clients
and lets the services focus on their
business while delegating multiple
cross-cutting concerns to the gateway
there is also a front-end portal that
enables the administration of the items
catalog the players and the inventory
and it also includes a store section
where players can purchase items
finally there are a few infrastructure
components like logging distributed
tracing and monitoring that all
microservices can interact with and that
can greatly help to troubleshoot issues
and make sure the whole system remains
healthy
now there are a lot of topics to cover
to implement this system so in this
course the basics we will focus on the
most fundamental parts related to
microservices collaboration
in that sense you will implement only
the catalog and inventory microservices
using.net and asp.net core
and you will use mongodb to host a
non-sql database for each service
you will initially explore how the
services can communicate synchronously
via res and http
but later you will stand up a rabbit
enqueue message broker that will allow
all services to communicate
asynchronously by publishing and
consuming messages via the mass transit
distributed application framework
that will give you a solid understanding
of how to get started with microservices
and net and how to tackle the multiple
challenges of getting the services to
collaborate in a resilient way
the frontend portal is placed on the
react ui framework
you won't be coding this portal but you
will get access to all this source code
so you can build and run it in your box
and use it to see how real and modern
client can take advantage of your
microservices
also you will run all infrastructure
services like mongodb and revit queue
via docker containers which is the best
way to get things up and running in your
box very quickly
at the end of this course i will point
you to the next steps so you can
continue your journey by implementing
the rest of the system
in the next lesson you will download and
install the first set of tools that you
will need in your development box for
the upcoming models
in this lesson you will set up the
development environment that will be
used across this course
here for the tools required for this
model
the net 5 software development kit or
sdk which includes everything needed to
build and run.net applications
docker desktop which has all the tools
needed to run the multiple
infrastructure services that we will use
across the course
and visual studio code the lightweight
but powerful source code editor that we
will use to write build and debug our
microservices code
a few of the future models will require
more tools but for now this is all that
is needed
let's go through the installation of
these tools and the overall setup of our
development environment
before getting started just keep in mind
that the pages that you will see for
downloading the tools will likely look a
bit different depending on your
operating system and the versions
available at the time that you're taking
this course
but regardless the result download and
installation process should be mostly
the same
so let's start by going to the download
page for the net sdk
so let's go to
net.microsoft.com
download
and this page is going to present you
the latest version of the net sdk which
in my case that will be net 6 and in
your case it could be different
but one thing to keep in mind is that
this course has been designed for net5
not for dotnet 6 or any other future
version
so even if you have net 6 or another
version installed in your machine you
have to make sure that you get the net 5
sdk in your box otherwise the project in
place that you will be using will
generate different code than the one
that you're going to see in this course
and you're also going to get a few
syntax errors
so to get the net 5 sdk what you want to
do is go to this link all the temp
versions
and then you want to go into the 5 link
over here
here at the top of this page you want to
look at this table here
which lists the links to install.net for
the different operating systems so you
have to choose the link that corresponds
to your operating system in my case i'm
running windows and my platform is x64
so i'm going to click in the x64 link
and that is going to start unload
so this unload could take a few seconds
depending on your download speed so
let's just give it a few seconds
okay so the installer has unloaded i'm
going to click on installer
i'll click on install
and installation starts
this could take a few seconds or a few
minutes depending on the speed of your
machine so again let's just give it a
moment
okay so the identified sdk has been
installed already and i'm going to just
close this window
and what i'd like to do now is to
quickly go ahead and verify the
installation just to make sure that it
has been installed properly so to do
that i'm going to go and open my start
menu
and then i'm going to look for my
terminal my windows terminal and of
course depending on your operating
system what you can do is just open
whichever terminal or shell is available
in your box
this should work in really any kind of
terminal or shell
and then all you want to do is just type
net
and then dash info
and this is going to present you with a
bunch of details regarding your version
of the sdk and your machine
like in my case it is showing that i
have version 5.0 that 404 of the sdk
and then there are many other details
here but in the end this shows that that
end has installed properly into my
machine
so that net is ready to go
now let's go ahead and load the page to
download docker desktop
let's go to docs.docker.com
getdocker
and in this page if you scroll down a
little bit you're going to see again
that you can pick your operating system
so again my operating system will be
windows so i click on docker desktop for
windows
and docker desktop for windows so i'll
click on that button and let's give it a
few seconds for the download to complete
okay so let's go ahead and open the
docker desktop installer
okay so here it goes
we'll just keep these two checks right
there
no need to change anything
i'll just click on ok
and that's going to get things started
again this may take a while so let's
give it a moment to complete
okay so installation succeeded i'll
click on close
another thing about docker is that
docker desktop will usually not
automatically start in your machine
after installation
so you do have to start it at least the
very first time that you install the
tool
so to start docker i'll just go to my
start menu i'll type docker
so here it is you're looking for docker
desktop i'll click on it
and you should see a new icon show up in
the right side
bottom right i guess which is starting
the docker process
okay so this screen shows up i'll click
accept all the terms accept
notice how docker desktop is starting
and then this screen shows up local
engine waiting double engine starting
give it a second
installation has completed it has
started
i'll click on skip tutorial here
and at this point docker is up and
running
and to verify that docker is up and
running properly what i'll do is also
type a quick command in the terminal
window
but i'll open a second terminal just
because we want to make sure that it has
gotten the chance to read the new
environment variable to locate docker
so i'm going to close this terminal here
close our windows
and i'll open a new terminal windows
terminal
and here what i'll do is just type
docker version
and if docker is installed it should
show up all the details about the
current version of docker
which in my case is version 20.10.11
for the docker client at least
and with that our docker installation is
complete
so now i'll go ahead and install visual
studio code
so i'll close this terminal and i'll go
into
i'll close this i'll go into the browser
let's go into aka rms slash bs code
and here's the style page for vs code
and as usual you're going to be offered
the version that corresponds to your
operating system
so i'm going to click on this big blue
button here download for windows stable
build and then download starts
and this should be pretty fast this is a
small starter
okay so i'll click on installer
accept agreement
and then i'll just click all the default
options here
click install and let's give it a moment
to complete
okay so then i'll just click on finish
and this code is opening up right away
i'll maximize this window
and as you can see vs code has open up
and that completes our installation of
initial tools
in the next lesson we will go ahead and
customize pixel studio code for c-sharp
development
visual studio code is a lightweight but
powerful source code editor that has
built-in support for javascript
typescript and node.js and has a rich
ecosystem of extensions for other
languages and runtimes
since all the code that you will write
across this learning pad will use the
c-sharp language and will run using the
network time you will need to install
the popular c-sharp extension
so to start extensions what you want to
do is go into your activity bar on the
left side this one over here and look
for the extensions view via this
extensions icon you can click on that
one
and this is going to show all the
available extensions in to the code
marketplace
of which there are really hundreds of
them
and then what you want to do is just
search for c-sharp
and the extension that you want is
usually the very first one on the list
and is the one that is provided by
microsoft and it says c-sharp for visual
studio code powered by omnisharp so
let's click on that one
and this is the extension that adds all
the editing support needed for c-sharp
including syntax highlighting
intellisense find all references and
many other features
it also adds support for building and
debugging.net and asp.net core
applications in your box so you have to
make sure that you get in this extension
in your box to be able to do proper
coding with c-sharp so i'll go ahead and
click on install
and this may just take a few seconds
after which you will be ready to start
coding in c sharp
okay so extension is ready and you're
ready to call on c sharp with visual
studio code here but let's also go ahead
and enable a few optional settings to
further improve your coding experience
so let's go to
let's first close this and let's close
that let's go to file
preferences
settings
and here let's type
place open race
on new line
and this is going to filter a few
options here and the ones that you want
to enable are
this one here javascript format place
open brace on new line for contour
blocks
and place of embrace of new line for
functions
these two settings will help you format
your control blocks like if else blocks
and your functions so that when you open
braces the opening brace automatically
goes to the new line
so you don't have to use this setting
but i find that my code reads much
better when i use it
the next setting is let me delete this
one here delete this
is um format on save
which is this option right here this
first one so i'll click on that one
so what this allows
is to uh make sure that all your code
for whichever file you're working on
will be automatically formatted as soon
as soon as you save it into your machine
right so you save the file and it will
get all the formats so that what again
we will help you
make sure that the code looks way better
without you having to do a lot of work
across your lines
and the last option setting that i will
recommend you is this one in file
how to save
so as the name says what this allows you
is to automatically save whichever file
you're working on without you having to
do anything so as soon as you finish
typing your code the file will be
automatically saved to your machine
so i find that very handy and to make
sure that i never forget to save my
files so i'm just going to click on auto
save
and that will enable the setting
the last thing that i wanted to show you
here is the visual studio code
integrated terminal which is the one
that you're going to use to type a bunch
of commands across this learning pad
so let me go ahead and close this
settings tab here and to open the
terminal what you can do is either go to
view
terminal
or you can go to terminal new terminal
or you can use a few shortcuts like for
instance in the case of windows you can
do ctrl tilde
double open terminal
or let me kill this
you can also use ctrl j and that will
also bring up a terminal so of course
the shortcut keys will depend on your
current operating system now as you can
see in this case this has opened a
terminal a powershell terminal in my
case and that's because that's a default
for windows
but you can always go ahead and use this
drop down on the right side
right here you can open up and you can
switch to any other terminal that better
switch your needs so if you want to use
patch you can use git batch here you can
use a standard command prompt or you can
switch to either even a wound based
terminal so it's really up to you what
terminal to use
in this course we'll be using mostly a
powershell because that's that's what i
mostly like to use but it's up to you to
use whichever terminal fits better your
needs
in the next couple of lessons we will
define the concepts of monoliths and
microservices
how they compare and which are their
pros and cons
before diving into microservices and
their benefits it is probably worth it
to understand first what a monolith is
its benefits and the issues it can
present
to understand what we mean by a monolith
let's look at one way we could design
our play economy system
we start with our desktop and mobile
clients
like we said they need some sort of
backend piece to enable the game
experience
therefore we introduce a server
component
likely hosted as a web server somewhere
in the internet
as we go through the requirements we
identify a model that needs to take care
of the in-game catalog of items so we
introduce a catalog model
right away we also perceive the need for
a place to store these catalog items
which means it is time to introduce a
database along with a table to store
these items
we also identify the need to store the
information about our players and in
general any user of the system
so we bring in a user's model which we
place in the same web server next to the
catalog model
also since we already have a database
configured for a web server we decide to
add tables for the user's model in that
same database
next we identify the need to store the
set of items that the player has
purchased
so we bring in an inventory model
and same as before we place it next to
our other models and add relevant tables
to the same database
we also need some place to perform the
actual purchase process and since this
involves both dividing jill from the
player and granting items to him we also
know we will need to use some sort of
transaction for this
so we introduce a trading model on the
same server
and we will let it take advantage of the
transactional capabilities of the
database
finally we will need some way to secure
the access to our web server so that
only players registered in the system
can make use of it
so we bring in an authentication and
authorization model which we will
abbreviate as oddc
as with everything else we will place it
on the same server and make it use the
same database
this system that we have just described
is what we call a model it
and more specifically a modular monolith
in this system all of our server-side
capabilities are hosted together in the
same web server and they all use the
same database
likely we also have the source code for
all the models in a single repository
we build all the code base with a single
bill process and we deploy everything
together
let's now look at the pros and cons of a
modulate
here for the pros and cons of a modblade
first the
pros convenient for new projects usually
when you're just getting started a
monolith is the best option since you
can put all the source code in one place
including all common libraries this lets
you iterate quickly for a while
tools mostly focus on them
most ides are built around the concept
of building a single application
which aligns pretty well with a monolith
there's great code reviews
since all the code lives in the same
repository it is easy to reuse code
across the multiple models of the
application
it is easier to run locally being a
single process it is a straightforward
to have the full application running in
your box usually with a single command
easier to debug and troubleshoot when
it's time to fix box there's usually a
single place to look for locks to find
out what happened you can also start a
debugging session in your box to
reproduce and fix the issue
there's one thing to build
a single command is usually enough to
build entire codebase locally
and if using a continuous integration
server a single build pipeline will do
the trick
there's also one thing to deploy
all the application models can be
deployed as a unit with a single
deployment pipeline
there's one thing to test end to end
end-to-end verification of application
can take place as soon as application
has been deployed with no other moving
pieces that could impact testing
and there's one thing to scale with
increased load demands more risk more
instances of the web application there's
only one app to scale
saying when the increased scale is no
longer needed there's only one thing to
scale down
now the cons
easily to get complex and to understand
since entire code base is in a single
place there will be a point where it
starts becoming too hard to navigate it
and understand the relationships between
the different components
merging code can be challenging
when using things like git
and with more and more people
contributing to multiple models in a
single code base eventually resolving
conflicts gets more troublesome and the
chances of a bad merge that could impact
on related models increases
it slows down ids
if the devs use an integrated
development environment or ide like
visual studio the massive number of
projects and source code will eventually
start slowing down the ide
starting with simple things such as
opening the work environment
long build times
the bigger the single code base becomes
the more time it takes to build it
things like incremental builds
can help here but this is something that
can easily not be configured properly
and regardless it is undesired to have
to build code for all the application
models when usually you only work on one
or two of them
slow and infrequent deployments
just like building the code takes longer
it also takes more time to complete the
deployment since there are a lot of
components to deploy with every new
build
not only that teams tend to delay
compound deployments to friday night or
even weekends due to the lack of
confidence on the impact of the changes
that go into that deployment
remember that with each deployment you
are deploying all the application models
all the time
long testing and stabilization periods
once a deployment is complete regardless
of what changes in the deployment you
still need to test all the scenarios
across all of the application models
not only this
is inefficient but also teams that don't
have testing fully automated may need to
run manual tests to compensate and run
them again for all the application
scenarios
rolling back is all or nothing
books will eventually make their way to
deployment and sometimes there's no time
to code and deploy the ideal fix
in these cases you just want to roll
back the previous version
however with a monolith you will be
forced to roll back the entire
application not just the faulty model
and
once the fix arrives you will need to
redeploy the entire thing again with all
the associated testing and stabilization
no isolation between models
the small spock in one of the models
that makes the web application crash
will take down all the models with it
it can be hard to scale
this really depends on the kind of app
that you're building but if you have
some model that needs say a lot of
memory and therefore needs to be scaled
to multiple instances to not take over
all the ramming a single server
while all the other models are fine with
a small amount of ram most of the time
you still need to scale the entire
application with all the models to
satisfy the ram needs of the first model
also it's hard to adopt new tech
if you would like to move one or two of
the models to the latest version of say
the.net platform you are forced to
update all the models along with it
which significantly increases the time
investment and associated risk of moving
to a new stack
moreover if you need to switch a model
to a different programming language or
web framework you still need to account
for how that change will impact the rest
of the models
in the next lesson we will start
learning about microservices their pros
and cons and when it's a good time to
start considering them
in this lesson we will understand what
microservices are how to decompose our
previous model lead into microservices
the pros and cons of using microservices
and when is the right time to start
thinking on using them
there are multiple definitions of
microservices out there but here's one i
have synthetized from a few sources and
that i think covers the fundamental
characteristics of microservices
microservices refers to an architectural
style that structures an application as
a collection of independently deployable
services that are modeled around the
business domain and are usually owned by
a small team
so instead of having a single
application deployed as a single
monolithic unit we break it down into
smaller services where each of them is
closely aligned to some part of our
business domain
each of these services can be deployed
independently which by the way includes
granting each of them their own database
which is one of the main challenges of
moving to microservices
also there's usually only one small and
fairly autonomous team behind each
microservice
let's see how this looks like for the
game back and example we talked about in
the previous lesson
we start again with our client apps
which will still interact with some
backend pieces to enable the required
game experience
and just like before we come up with
most of the models that we talked about
before to address the multiple scenarios
however this time each of these models
live in their own individual server
process or likely a web server process
fully isolated from the other ones and
with their own lifecycle
not only that but also each of these
services have their own associated
database that has no relationship with
the ones from the other services
also notice that we decided to group the
users and altc models in a single
process that we are now calling the
identity service
but even when these services are now
independent they still have ways to
collaborate with each other so that for
instance when a purchase starts in
trading
this service will communicate somehow
with identity and inventory services in
order to achieve the exchange of yield
for catalog items
this here is what we call the
microservices architecture pattern
next let's learn about the benefits and
drawbacks involved in the microservices
architecture
these are some of the pros and cons of
using microservices
let's start with the pros
they have a small easy to understand
code base
since the microservices are now
independent the source code for each of
them is usually stored in its own git
repository this implicitly results in a
much smaller repository which is much
easier to understand especially for devs
new to the code base
they are quicker to build
the smaller independent codebase per
microservice allows for building each
service much faster and in parallel both
on deck boxes and on ci pipelines
they allow for independent faster
deployments and rollbacks
each service can now be deployed
individually as soon as the relevant
source code has been built and testing
for the domain covered by the service
can start right away and is much smaller
in scope
also if an issue is detected with the
deployment it can be rolled back to the
previous version without having to roll
back any other service
they are independently scalable
different services can be skilled
according to their needs so if there's
one service that needs to scale given
the amount of ram or cpu it uses it can
be scaled independently of the needs of
any of the other services
there is much better isolation from
failures microservices are isolated from
each other
so that a crashing one service has no
impact in the availability of the other
services
they are designed for continuous
delivery since microservices are small
usually start fast and are independent
from each other they are great
candidates for continuous delivery they
can be deployed as soon as the code has
been built
and this can be done safely in an
automated way multiple times a day
it is easier to top new variety tech
different services don't need to use the
same versions of their multiple
dependencies including the.net runtime
even better if one of them needs to be
moved to a completely different language
or web framework this is much more
straightforward to do with a small micro
service than with a big model it
microservices ground autonomy to teams
and lets them work in parallel
the natural independence of deployment
and isolation of microservices and the
fact that they are closely lined to a
specific part of the business domain
results in the owning teams to have
great autonomy around the entire
lifecycle of the service
some teams might decide to deploy their
microservice every night while others
will do it every hour or whenever an
origin fix needs to be shipped
different teams will do what's best for
them
now the cons
it is not easy to find the right set of
services
how do you know that you have split the
app into the right set of services
are three microservices enough or 10
perhaps how much granularity
these questions are not easy to answer
but techniques like domain-driven design
and aligning the services to specific
pieces of the domain and the teams
behind them helps to find the right
balance
using microservices as the complexity of
distributed systems
the fact that each service lives in
separate silo introduces a lot of
complex issues that are non-existent in
modulates
how to have a service communicate with
another one if a model can no longer
make a simple method call to the other
issues like these are the reason for
this curse
the shared code moves to separate
libraries
any piece of code that needs to be
shared across two or more microservices
now needs to be either duplicated in
each service which is not ideal or moved
to a separate library and likely sharpie
and nougat packages
this is technically good since it forces
the owners of the share code to have a
good way to test the shared code
independently but on the flip side
things are no longer as easy as adding a
new shared class or method to any of the
services codebase
also you may end up with dozens of
shared libraries that may need to
collaborate and have the right set of
dependencies
there is no good tooling for distributed
apps
ides are usually focused on a single app
not uploading several services together
this means that devs will usually work
on one service at a time and will need
to figure out ways for their code to
interact with other services in their
dev environment where needed
releasing features across services is
hard
simple things like adding a new
attribute to say a user record and have
it been used across the entire system
can involve touching multiple services
in a very coordinated fashion even worse
updating or removing attributes from
data classes is extremely painful and
usually avoided as much as possible
it is hard to troubleshoot issues across
services
when a customer reports an issue with
the system or application
where you will start looking
with features potentially distributed
across dozens of microservices you are
forced to have a very good story around
tracing issues across services to be
able to quickly find out the root cause
and address it
you can't use transactions across
services
since each service has its own database
atomic transactions that impact multiple
tables are usually out of the question
how to ensure a purchase operation will
both debit jill from the user and
granted the relevant items when one of
the involved services could unexpectedly
fail in the middle of the purchase
process
a few new patterns and techniques need
to be introduced to properly handle
these concerns
finally it raises the required skill set
for the team
with each team fully owning the service
and since not all services will be built
similarly
each team now needs to learn not just
how to code features for the service but
also how to build it deploy it test it
in isolation diagnose it roll it back
etcetera
many times this also involves building a
ton of automation and shared
infrastructure to ensure teams can
remain agile building features and not
have to worry too much about all the
other aspects this requires a lot of
investment
let's close this lesson by understanding
when you should start considering
microservices
you should keep in mind that it is
perfectly fine to start with a monolith
and only later move to microservices
architecture
your business domain and the set of
requirements for your system might not
be fully flushed out by the time you
need to start designing and building the
system
therefore jumping into building multiple
microservices from the start could not
only significantly slow down the small
starter team at a time when quick proof
of concepts are desired
but also you may end up building the
wrong set of microservices with
additional cost of having to restructure
them later
the heavy investments on shared
infrastructure and automation will only
make sense as the boundaries are clearly
defined and the team has grown in size
you should start looking at
microservices when the code base size is
more than what a small team can maintain
the different teams can move fast
anymore due to the amount of share code
the bills have become too slow due to
the large code base
or the time to market is compromised due
to infrequent deployments and loan
verification times
in the end microservices are all about
team autonomy
anytime you notice multiple teams no
longer being able to deliver features in
an agile way due to the drawbacks of the
monolithic architecture
you know that your teams have lost their
autonomy and they could potentially
greatly benefit from using microservices
instead
in the next model we will get our hands
dirty by building our first microservice
in this model we will build our first
microservice from scratch
this will give you the foundations and
tools you will need to create
microservices with the.net platform
by the end of this model you will have a
solid understanding of the following
how to create a microservice from
scratch via the.net cli and visual
studio code
how to define the microservice rest api
with the most common operations
and what are and how to define the data
transfer objects to establish the
contract between our service and the
service clients
in this lesson we will create our first
microservice the catalog microservice
using the.net cli and visual studio code
to create our microservice project we
will take advantage of the.net command
line interface also known as netcli
which comes installed with the net sdk
so first thing i'll do is create the
folder where i'm going to store my
projects so to do that i'll go to
terminal new terminal
and then i'll switch to my d drive and
to my products folder and i'll create a
folder called
play that catalog
so everything related to the play that
catalog uh catalog microservice will be
stored in that location so i'll open
that folder and visuals to the code now
by going to file open folder
and then i'll look for that location
here
so this opens a workspace
in that location
so being here what i'd like to do is
create yet another folder to store all
the source files for the for the
microservice so i'll go on the left side
here i'll go and click on new folder and
then i'll type src so src is going to be
the folder that stores all the files
related to compile duplication i'll
expand this and then i'll right click on
src and select open in integrated
terminal so this opens a terminal
exactly the location where we're going
to create the project files
to actually generate the files what we
can do is type
net new
and at this point you can actually pick
from a bunch of different templates for
creating.net projects but the one that's
most useful for microservices is usually
the web api kind of project so we'll all
type
web api
and the name we're going to give it is
that
lay.catalog.service
hit enter
and this is going to go ahead and
generate all the files that we need for
the project which at this point you can
see on the left side also notice that
there's a small warning about the
asp.net core https development
certificate which we'll take a look in a
moment
now if by any chance you have multiple
versions of the net sdk installed in
your machine and you're not sure that
that n5 is your default version please
add the
framework argument to the net new
command and specify the value of net 5.0
for dot n5
that will make sure that you are using
the asp.net core 5 templates when
creating projects which will produce the
same files that you will see in these
and in future lessons now let's go
quickly across the files that just got
generated and see what they are meant to
be used for so the first one is going to
be alter i'd actually just close this
terminal the first one is going to be
the cs profile which is what we call the
project file so this is the file that
defines how the project is going to be
built
and
what version of the dotnet runtime is
going to be targeted in this case it's
going to be.net 5.
the next one is program cs which is what
we call the main entry point of the
application
but also notice that as soon as we open
our first sharp file visual studio code
is going to prompt us to add a few
regard assets to the project and we'll
say yes
so this will create a vs code folder on
the left side with a couple of files
that are needed to build and debug the
application
now like i said back in program cs this
is the main entry point so this defines
how we're going to start
the the host for our application
next file is going to be startup.cs this
defines how we're going to uh register
the services are going to be used across
application and what we call also the
request pipeline for espnetcore
the next one i'd like to show you is the
controllers folder this is where we
store all the
application controllers to handle the
requests that are going to come into the
application
and this is a campaign this is a
campaign with uh right now by a model
that's called the weather forecast for
the simple sample model that has been
set up in this template
next file is a launch settings.json
this one defines a few things but the
most important one is the application
url which defines which is the address
or the addresses
where our
microservice is going to be running so
in this case it is going to be available
in https localhost 5001 and on https
sorry http localhost 5000.
finally like i said this is the code
generated a couple of files
over here
that's a json which defines
how we're going to build the code from
visual studio code and launch
application that defines how to start up
how to
actually kick off
the execution of the application in
visual studio code
okay now i'll close this and it's time
to actually build this project to make
sure we'll build and run it to make sure
that it's running properly so in order
to do that what i'll do is i'll go back
to the terminal and you can do that by
going to view
terminal
which by the way you can also do via the
control j shortcut
faster that way
and then i'll switch to
our
play.catalog that service directory
play that catalog service
and then we'll be in there and what you
can do there's actually a couple of ways
that you can build this project so you
can either do
net build like i'll do now that will go
ahead and build the entire project
should be pretty fast
and the other way to do this is via
visual studio codes menus you can go
to terminal realm build task
and then you select build
and that will also go ahead and build
the project
now this second way is the way that you
will most likely be using a while being
exhausted to your code and to make this
actually a bit faster what you can do is
add a little bit of a couple of lines
into the task.json file so let me
minimize this a bit
so go to that json
and here under the under the build
section what you can do is just add one
little group here
let's add it it's called group
and then we're going to go for kind
build is evil true
i'll save this
and after doing that what you notice is
that when you go to
terminal and you say run build task it
will build it right away as opposed to
opening yet another menu to do the build
at this point you can also do
uh you can also use the ctrl shift b
shortcut like i'll do now
to kick off the build without having to
go through any menus which is pretty
handy
okay now that we know how to build the
project and i'll actually just close
this
how do we
how do we run it so there's a couple of
ways to do that too
so i'll actually switch in this drop
down i'll go back to our terminal the
partial terminal
and the way to run the this microservice
this microservice project is by just
typing.net run
so that may build the project depending
on the current status but after that it
will go ahead and run it as you can see
and it reports the current status uh the
the the address where the
where the host is listening the
addresses in this case 5001 5000 in
localhost
and how to actually turn turn down the
application if needed by ctrl c
that's one way and i'll actually do a
control c to stop it
the other way to do it is by going to
the
to the wrong view on the left side
and here you can click on this on this
icon here says start debugging it will
actually start a debugging session
of the project as opposed to just
running it so i'll click on it
okay
and this will open a browser window as
you can see here
for our project
now if you see this
this kind of an error
stating that your connection isn't
private this is totally normal so this
just means that the development
certificate for the
for the web host has not been installed
yet
so in order to address this let's
actually go back let's close this and
stop it
and what we have to do is just install
the certificate i mean trust the
certificate in our machine so i'll go to
terminal
switch back to the partial terminal here
what i'll do is use the
net dev search tool you have to type
https
trust
hit enter
and this is going to pop up
this little warning here which is
totally fine and say yes and that adds a
certificate into your thruster rule
certificates
stored in your machine
so after doing that i'll go ahead and
instead of clicking on this i'll just
hit f5 which is a shortcut for start
debugging so i'll hit f5
so that obviously browser came and as
you can see there's no errors anymore
and yes it is not showing anything uh
that that's because there's nothing
really happening in the in the root of
the website so if you actually want to
see something you can do slash swagger
and this opens the swagger page so i got
ui page so this is the page where you
can start
exploring the different methods exposed
by your
web api or your res api
in this case we have not really coded
much the only thing that you're seeing
here is the default stuff that's coming
with the template so we'll not pay too
much attention into it but later on
we'll start using this page heavily to
start
working with our microservice
i'll close this
and i'll stop the server
so that's it for this lesson and in the
next lesson we will define the rest api
for our catalog microservice
in this lesson we will define the res
api for our catalog microservice
the res api defines the operations
exposed by the microservice
since the catalog microservice owns the
items that players will be able to
purchase
here are the operations that it should
support
get items which retrieves all the items
currently stored in the service
get item by id which retrieves the
details of a specific item
post item which creates an item in the
service
put item which updates a specific item
and delete item which deletes the
specified item
as part of the definition of the res api
we also need to define the relevant data
transfer objects
so what is a data transfer object
a data transfer object also known as dto
is an object that carries data between
processes
for example
let's go back to our client and the
catalog service
when the client needs to retrieve the
details for a specific item it will send
a get request to the service with the
item id
and the service will in turn return the
item details
this payload returned by the service is
what we call the dto
the dto represents the contract between
the microservice and the client
we'll define this contract has
significant implications
imagine what would happen if we decide
to rename the price to item price
our clients would break and they would
need to get updated right away to ensure
no disruption to our customers
as a general rule you need to think
carefully about each of your details to
ensure you minimize the need to update
them later as much as possible
it's time to define the res api for
catalog microservice
we'll start by deleting a few files that
were created by the template that we
will not be using across this
microservice which are the weather
forces controller i'll delete this
and the weather forecast class over here
now the first thing that we're going to
do is declare
the details for our service
now we will use record types for dtos as
opposed to classes basically because
they are simpler to declare
they provide value based equality which
means that when comparing two of the
items then we will consider equal if all
their properties have the same value
which is not the case with classes
they are immutable by default meaning
that modifications after creation are
not allowed
and they have a built in to a string
overwrite that shows the names and
values of all the record properties
so to create the dtos
file
you can right click on play catalog
service right here
say a new file
and then let's name it
dtos.cs
in this file first thing we're going to
do is just declare a namespace
so
namespace should have the name of the
folder to start with so play
catalog service and then we will append
dtos
now let's declare our first cto this is
going to be the dto that is going to be
used to return information from our get
operations
so
public record
item dto
and the first thing that is going to
have is an id it's going to be of type
good
and good is a type that is going to need
a namespace import so to import
namespace i'm going to use a light bulb
here
and i'll select using system so that
imports the namespace
and then we're going to declare
a name
a description
a price
and
a created
date
okay
now the next cto is going to be used for
the creation of our items
so let's say public record is going to
be named
create item dto
this cto does not need an id or a
created date because both of them are
going to be
automatically generated within the
service so they don't need to be
provided by the client so we'll specify
a name
a description
and a price
finally we're going to declare a dto for
updating an item
so pull the record
update item
dto and this is actually going to have
the same members as create item dto so
i'm going to copy those
and uh it happens to be that right now
they have they need the same members but
it could be in the future that they need
different
different properties so
a good convention is to keep them
separate even if they have the same
properties to start with
in the next lesson we will add a
controller to define our res api
operations
in order to add our api operations we
will need to introduce a controller
specifically a web api controller
the controller groups the set of actions
that can handle the api requests
including the routes authorization and a
series of other rules usually needed in
rest apis
so to start let's go to our controllers
folder here right click
new file and the name that we're going
to get to this controller is
items controller
since this is going to be the controller
that's going to be managing our catalog
items
so let's go ahead and collapse our
navigation pane so that we have more
space for looking at the code
let's start by defining a namespace
the namespace
catalog service controllers
okay and now let's define our class
it's going to be items
controller
and so each of your web api controllers
should derive from
controller
base
and i'm going to import the missing
space by doing control dot
using microsoft switch core mvc
so you always want to derive from
controller base not from controller but
controller base because this provides
many properties and methods useful when
handling http requests
like the battle requests not found and
created attacking methods
which we'll be using in these and in
future lessons
now you should always also add to each
of your controllers the api controller
attribute so api controller
this attribute enables a series of
features that improve your sapi
developer experience
like for instance having model
validation errors automatically return a
400 request error
or how to bind incoming requests into
our method parameters
the other attribute you want to add here
is the
route attribute
this one specifies the url pattern
that this controller will map to for
instance if we use
items here
that means that this controller will
handle the
rewards that start with slash items so
for instance
if we get let's say
i'll just add a little comment here
so we have localhost 5001 and if
somebody navigates into items
that means that since the route
specifies items here that means that
items controller is the controller
that's going to
handle
that specific route
okay so i'll remove this
and you can also use route for the
different uh
operations that we're going to define in
this controller you can specify your own
routes but for now uh this is going to
be our root route for all the the
operations in this controller now since
in this lesson we would like to focus on
the rest api part of microservice we
will not be interacting with the real
database just yet
we will use an in-memory list of items
that our api variations will interact
with and in a future lesson we will
introduce a proper repository class that
will take care of interacting with our
database
so let's start by defining this a static
list so i'll declare
probably static
read only we'll make this list read only
because we will only allow to construct
it i mean to create it or instantiate it
during a controlled construction time
and after that there will be no need to
modify the instance of this list
so it's going to be list
of item dto because uh uh this is going
to be the list that we're going to be
returning when somebody requests the
items from our rest api so we want to
specify the contract that we already
find for our items here so item dto
and then it's going to be named items
equals new
and so let's see we're missing some more
next spaces here
okay so i'll do ctrl dot again
system collection is generic and we also
need our
play catalog service dtos namespace
so let's find our first item here so
i'll just define it in line here so new
item dto
for the id we'll just generate a
generate a random good so a new good
mainly another nice space import
yup
and for the name let's name this one
potion
the description is going to be
restores a small amount of hp
the price is going to be let's say five
and for the created date let's just do
the time of set that utc now okay it's
going to be the the current time in utc
time
so let's add i'll just copy this to add
two more items
the second one is going to be let's say
an antidote
and so the antidote
cures poison
price is going to be let's say seven
credit date is utc now
and the last item is going to be
let's say
[Music]
a brown sword
and it deals a small amount
of damage it's going to be a big price
here let's say 20
and yeah utc now
column save
okay
also notice that we're using a static
list here
so we do this so that the list does not
get recreated every time somebody
invokes one of our res api methods right
otherwise the list will be recreated
every single time
that a method is invoked which we don't
want
so now let's define our first operation
this is going to be the operation that's
invoked anytime somebody tries to get
all the items that we have in the rest
api
so we're going to say
public innumerable
off item
dto
get
okay
and so
yes we're returning a list
of identito
now each of your
api operations should be
a marked with the correct http verb
right since this is going to be
responding to our the get verb we should
mark this with the http get attribute
and then for for this method really is
super simple we only need to return
the current list of items right so we
just return items
so that's our first get operation the
next one
is going to allow us to return one one
specific item so we'll name it
public item dto
get by id
okay and then we're receiving the the
specific id as a good
and just like we did before we need to
decorate this with the http get
attribute
but here we also need to specify
uh what part of the of the route
that the user specifies
is going to map to that id so in this
case we do that by specifying id here
okay so that means that uh if somebody
comes with and i'll put it so here so
somebody go does it get
there's a little comment here does it
get into
our items route
and then they specify some id like one
two three four five
uh that one two three four five is one
is is captured as the id in the http get
route and that's mapped into the id
parameter over here
okay so the route would look more like
in a more generic case it's going to be
slash items slash
id
and so to do this the only thing we have
to do is just find the correct item in
our list so we'll say
bar item equals items where and for this
i'll need ctrl dot system.link
so for each item we will do a item.id
should match
the id that we got in the parameter and
then we will say okay so let's find the
only
the only item that should match with
that id get that one
otherwise i mean with single default we
can say either get the item or just
return null in this case
and then we return that item
okay
so
that's what we need uh for our get
routes so let's try it out to see how
that that goes so i'll hit f5 my
keyboard
to start a web server
that opens the browser
and let's now navigate to our swagger
page so slash swagger
and here you can see that we have our
two first
api operations defined items and items
by id
and we also have the the schema of our
itunes dto showing up here right so if
you expand this one we can see the shape
of our item video right there
so if you expand the items route
you can see a little example here of
what it would return
and expected a return for a successful
case and then if you want to try it out
just have to click on try it out
then you click on execute
and here you can see the actual the
request url that was invoked into our
api
slash items
and then you can see the response body
here along with the status code 200
and the response body has the three
items that we have in our static list so
that's working fine
and let's say that we want to try the
other a operation where we have to
specify an id so i'll just copy the id
of one of these
i'll collapse this for a moment i'll
expand the other
so this one expects an id this parameter
so i'll do try it out
i'll paste the id here and then i'll
click on execute
and just before it it will go ahead and
use
the items a route but it will append the
id of the item
and as you can see we got a 200 okay and
we got in the body we got the actual uh
the body of the of the item that it was
retreat okay so that's working fine
so let's now add a method for creating
an item
so minimize this stop debugging and then
i'll close the terminal
okay so to create items we're going to
be using the post http verb and let's
create a method for that so it's going
to be
public
action result
now the action result type uh so this
one
allows us to return a return a type that
represents one of the several http
status codes
like 200 okay or 400 requests
but it also allows us to return a more
specific type like a dto type if we need
to so we can return different types
depending on what we have available so
let's see how we're going to be using
this
um so action retooled off type
item dto
and it's going to be named let's just
name it post for now
and then
here is where we're going to receive our
create idm dto contract right so that in
that way we enforce that uh whoever
calls this this api has to follow our
contract for creating items
so create item dto
and this one has to use
also the correct http verb it's going to
be http post
and then for creating an item we will
just create it in line here
so
i'll just say var item
equals new item dto
and we'll assign a random id here just
like we did with the with the list
you do it
and then we will say for the name we'll
say create ideo.name
for the description
that description
for the price
created you that price and for the day
for the great date again
daytime offset you'd see now
so that's the item and now now that we
got it we will just say
items dot add
to add the item to our to our static
list
finally we're going to return the type
created action
uh which is a is derived from action
result so this so this is going to be
used to say hey so the item has been
created and you can find it at the
following route uh which route is is
going to be well is the route with the
name
so name of
get by id so this means that uh the
caller will be able to find i mean we're
going to produce a heater in the
response that includes the exact route
of the item as provided by the get id
operation over there
we will also provide the id of the
created item as an anonymous type here
is going to be id equals item.id
and lastly the actual
the actual body of the response which is
the entire item
right
so it's ready i'll do f5 so we can try
that out see how that goes
okay back here i'll just close this one
so back into the previous tab i'll do f5
as you can see now we have the
the post operation listed here and the
create item dto listed at the bottom
so i'll go for post i'll expand this and
to try it out i'll do try it out
uh so here's where we can create a new
item right so let's let's figure out
some new item to create here let's say
we're going to create a high potion
and so this one is going to
restore a medium
restore
restores a medium
amount of hp
and the price is going to be let's say
nine
okay and so now i'll do
execute
as you can see it invokes uh the same
route
but in this case it was with a
with a post verb
post
and uh yeah so we got 201 which means
created a created route create or
created at
here's a response body so the entire
created item including the auto
generated id over here
and here you can see the heaters
includes the location
the location of the just created item so
if i wanted i can grab this id
and i can collapse let's call exposed
and then expand get inside id
try it out and i can paste that id here
and i should be able to find that just
created item
as you can see
or here's the high potion
so post is working just fine
so now let's say that we want to update
an item so that's where we need to
introduce the put
the put operation
so let's go back to our piece of studio
code stop this and close terminal
and let's declare a method to update
items
so for this term for this one i'm going
to declare
public action result and i'll be using i
action result because in this case we
don't really need a specific type for
the return we will just return this one
called no content meaning uh that's
that's what um uh you usually do for a
put operation you don't want to return
anybody you just say hey uh yeah i did
my job but there's nothing to return
so it's going to be named put
so we want to receive the id of the item
to update and
we will use the update item dto contract
to receive
the new
the new payload or the new information
for this existing item
it's updated in dto
and we also have to specify the proper
verb so http put
and just like we did with the get by id
we have specify what part of the route
is going to be used for the id parameter
so just like before it's going to be id
okay so once again when somebody comes
with a something similar with get items
by
id
somebody comes with uh not get but
put items slash id and somebody then
this is the operation that's going to be
honoring that route
so how do we implement this so the first
thing that we want uh that we want to do
is probably find the item that we're
going to be updating
so what i'll do is i'll just say
existing item
listing item is going to be
done under items list
uh
items list where item
uh item.id
is the id that we distributed the
parameter
and then again singular default right so
if you have it i will find it right
there
now we found the item we're going to
update it and to update it we're
actually going to do at this point is
just
clone it into a new item with the
updated values so we will say
updated item is going to be
the existing item with
the name that is going to be update item
update item dto dot name
description
date item dto that description
[Music]
and price
updated in dto
price
okay so that creates a clone of the
existing item and the in into updated
item and that's the one that we're going
to be updating into the list
okay so now we'll do is we're going to
find the place in the list
that uh that has the item that we need
to update so to do that we're going to
say
so the index of that item is going to be
in the list
find index
okay so it's going to be
existing item.id
equals id okay so that finds the index
on that list where the item is and then
now that we have the index we're going
to say
items index equals updated item
replaces that in the list and then like
i said we will just return
no content
there's nothing to return
okay so let's try this out so i'll do f5
once again
start the web host
and
close this page and then i'll just
refresh our swagger ui page and as you
can see now we have our put operation
here at the bottom and all the way to
the bottom we also have our update item
dto specified
so i'll expand put
this is going to require first the id of
the item to update so to get an id i'll
actually execute our get items route so
i'll try it out
execute
and let's say we're going to update our
antidote so i'll copy the id of the
antidote
collapse this
and then back in the input i'll say try
it out i'll put the id here
and then let's grab a few of the
properties of the antidote
we don't have to start from scratch
there
collapse this and then i'll place those
items here remove this comma
and then let's say we want to update
just the price and we'll say that the
price the antidote is going to be let's
say nine
and i'll go ahead and do
execute
and as you can see in this time it
invokes the api with a port with the put
verb
into this request url that includes the
id of the item we get a 204 result
meaning no content so as you can see
there's nothing being returned here but
the item was certainly updated and we
can confirm that by grabbing the id of
the item once again
and going to our get items by id route
we can try it out paste it there
i'll execute
and then you can see now we have the
antidote with price nine
so the update operation succeeded
so finally let's add the operation to
delete an item
so let's minimize this once again stop
and close
and
before adding our delete route just for
completeness let me do let me add the
comment here for our http post route
which i did indeed didn't do
uh this the post route is going to as we
as we saw responds to the post verb and
the browser is going to be like just
items right so jose we have that comment
over there
now for the delete route
uh is we're going to be using uh a
method that is also be returning a
action result just like in the boot case
because we're not we're going to be
returning no content here also
and it's going to be delete
and we're going to receive the only
thing that we need to receive here is
the id of the item to delete
and we also have to respond to the
http delete verb
and again just with the we put we have
to specify which part of the route we're
going to be using for the id of the item
to delete so that's going to be a id
once again
and here uh just like we did with update
we need to find
the index of the item to delete so i'll
copy that line from put
copy that
into here
okay
and so once we found the index of the
item to delete we're going to say okay
so from the list
remove add
and we'll say index so that removes the
item at that index location and then we
will just return
no content
so again for completeness let's add a
little comment here so when somebody
comes with a delete verb
and says lash items and then slash
some id
this is the method that's going to be
honoring that that deletion
so to try it out again i'll do f5
okay so back in swagger ui i'll refresh
the page
and as you can see now we have our
delete route a little operation showing
up here
and so i'll expand that so we need an id
to delete
so let's actually execute our get items
route try it out execute so we can pick
something to delete let's actually
delete this antidote once again so let's
copy the id of the antidote
and so i'll go back to delete try it out
i'll paste that id
and then i'll hit execute
and as you can see now we're using the
delete verve
invoking the api we delete
here's a url of the of the item that
needs to be deleted
and we got a 204 no content so as you
can see there's nothing returned but the
item should have been deleted so if i go
i'll collapse this and i'll go back
again to our to our a get items route
i'll to
execute again
and as you can see the item
the antidote item has been removed it's
not here so delete succeeded
so yes rest api seems to be working just
fine
um
however you can try querying for an item
that uh that does not exist and exit on
an existing item or perhaps creating an
item that does not have a name uh what
will happen in that case
so we'll need to do something about
those those situations
uh in the next lesson we will see how to
properly handle these kinds of invalid
inputs
let's try a few of the unexpected
scenarios that our microservice dress
api could face from time to time
so i have our catalog project open here
and i'll just do a five to start a web
server and go to our swagger ui page
so here we are in the browser i'll go to
[Music]
swagger
and let's start by getting the full list
of items as we have them right now so
open our
get items
operation try it out
click on execute
and here are the three items that we
have available right now
so let's say i want to query for one of
these items the potion
so i'll copy the idea of the potion
i'll close this and then i'll actually
go to our get is by id operation
okay so i'll do try it out i'll paste id
here but i'll actually going to i'm
going to flip a one of the characters
here i'll flip this one to two so this
is an on existing item we don't have
that available and i click on execute
see what we get
so what we're getting is a 204 result
right
which is not expected when when an item
is not found in the rest api the
expectation is that you would return a
404 status code or not found
so let's see what's actually happening
back in visual studio code
see where we're getting this
so i'll put a breakpoint in
over here in organic by the operation
and then i'll go back to swagger i'll
try this again
so i'll hit execute
and here we are this is studio code
so we try to find the item and
of course the item is two we cannot find
it
okay
so
what can we do about this
let's see i'll just stop debugging here
close terminal
and so really the fix is fairly
straightforward here
um
what we would like to do is just check
that if the item
is null
we will go ahead and return not the item
but would like to return the not found a
action result
however of course uh intelligence is
complaining here because
uh
we
not found does not convert into item dto
here right so here's where action result
becomes super useful
now we can say
action result
of item dto and that gives us the
ability to return it in the either the
item over here
or the not found result over here in
this case so as you can see we can
return more than one type of result
depending on the current situation
so let's try that out i'll hit 5 once
again i'll remove this breakpoint first
and then i'll hit a 5.
okay
so here we are again
i'll just copy this id
and refresh the entire page
should still be and not found items so
get items by id i click on try it out
i'll paste that id here and i'll hit on
execute
see what we get
so as expected this time we get a photo
for
a result saying not found so this is the
correct status code
for an item that cannot be found in the
in the rest api
and likely we're going to have the same
issue with our put api
right
so let's see
exactly which apis will be impacted so
not post but put is going to be impacted
because it needs to find the item
and likely the delete operation could
also be impacted because it needs to
again find the item before it can delete
it so let's start by fixing put
[Music]
it's going to be pretty similar
basically if existing item
is no
we will
say
not bound
okay
so that will do it for put
and then in the case of delete what
we're going to do is
just
that if
index
is less than
zero so basically a negative number it
means that we cannot find the index of
the item therefore we have to say
return not found
okay
so i should do it i'll hit f5 and see
what we get
i'll close this
and and i will um
yeah i'll copy
that's this id one existing id once
again
and i'll try to do a put operation now
so i'll try it out i'll put this id here
and uh
i'll put just something here for the for
the body
so some item
some item description
and
price too so just to try it out
and so i'll go ahead and say
execute and as expected now we can get a
404
on that case
not found
i'll take that id once again
and let's try out our delete operation
so let's try to delete that an existing
item
see what happens
so yeah as expected delete is also
returning a 404
so we can now say that we're probably
handling the case of not finding items
in in our different res api operations
now let's try something actually
different so what happens if we try to
create an
item
with some missing item properties
right so let me collapse this and
collect this and then let's go to post
okay
so i'll try to post an item
uh let's say without a name
we shouldn't be allowed
really
and let's say that this was really for
our high potion
which the description would be
restores a medium amount of hp
and that price was five right
perhaps seven
and so let's try to create an item with
no name
so
go ahead and hit execute
go down
and
201 meaning create an action so it
actually got created but look at this
the name is nu
and if we try to query for that item
with this this id
so let's do get by id
try to query for it
as you can see the item is is now in our
collection and is with a new name
and not only that let's see what happens
if we try to create it
with a negative number right so not
seven but let's say
minus seven
what happened in that case
uh so let's do execute
and again it got created to 201
and then now we have this order id
and so
now this item actually has a
a null name
and a negative price
so this is really bad so what what can
we do about this situation
um let's go back to visual studio code
just open close
and then i'll expand our navigation pane
again
so what we can do is actually do some
model validation right so back to the
dtos
we need to introduce a couple of
attributes to properly validate the
inputs here
and the details that we would care about
in this case are both in the create and
the update details
so what we can do is let's say for the
case of the name if the name is always
required what we can say is just add
this attribute here called required
which might require a namespace import
system company model data annotations
import and that makes it so that name
will always be required any time
somebody uses this create iron detail
okay and i'll also add it for our
uh
name
name property in the updated identity
and then also
i'll do
we can do something about the price so
in the case of the price
let's say that well let's add an
attribute here and let's say that what
we want to enforce is that the price
should always be let's say between 0 and
1000g right let's say but we actually
want to allow free items so they can be
zero but definitely not negative and
only up to a thousand so we can do is
use a range attribute here
and we can say here the minimum value
which is going to be zero and the
maximum value let's say it's going to be
a thousand here
okay so that makes it so that anytime
somebody specifies a price here it has
to be in this range
that implicitly also makes sure that uh
it cannot be null right but however i
mean since if this is a value type
decimal really this value can never meet
dual so worst case it will be zero but
with this we ensure that it has to be
between zero and a thousand
i'll do the same thing for our
item detail hit save
and now let's try it again so i'll hit a
five
okay
back here
and i'll go ahead and
i'll just copy this
and i'll refresh our page
so let's go ahead and try to do a post
try it out
and so let's start first with no name
so i'll say
the same price is still positive but we
don't have a name and let's try to
execute this and see what happens
so as you can see this time we do get a
400 but request error which is expected
in this case and we do have a the proper
validation message coming out of the the
errors these errors array
that is available now so one or more
validation error secured status 400 and
the name field is required so that's
great
and furthermore if we still want to use
that negative number so i'll do -7 hit
execute
see now
both validations have been performed so
the name
is name field is required and the field
price must be between 0 and 1 000.
you can also try using invalid input for
our put api operation now and you should
get similar validation errors
in the next model we will learn about
the repository pattern and we will stand
up a proper database to store our
catalog items
in this model we will update our catalog
microservice to be able to store and
query for items that live outside of the
service and into a proper database
by the end of this model you will have a
solid understanding of the following
what is and how to use the repository
pattern to store and query data
how to use a mongodb database as the
underlying data store of catalog items
how to use docker to run infrastructure
services like mongodb server
what is and how to use the dependence
injection technique for proper
decoupling of dependencies
and how to use the net configuration
system to specify settings that could
change across environments
in this lesson we will learn about the
repository pattern and how to implement
a repository to manage the catalog
service items in a mongodb database
so what is a repository
a repository is an abstraction between
the data layer and the business layer of
an application
to understand why you may want to use a
repository let's say that today we have
the application logic of our service
talking directly to our mongodb database
however a few months or years from now
requirements change and we need to
switch to a different database provider
given the way that things have been set
up we would likely need to rewrite a
good chunk of our application logic in
order to talk to the new database which
is pretty bad
instead what we can do is introduce a
repository
this repository is the only one that
knows how to talk initially to our
mongodb database and is the only one
that our application logic will
interface with
then if we ever get the requirement to
move to another database the only thing
that we would need to change is our
repository but the application logic
stays the same
so the repository pattern is important
because it decouples the application
logic from the data layer
and minimizes duplicate data access
logic across our service
we will be using mongodb as our database
of choice for all the microservices in
this course
mongodb is a document-oriented non-sql
database which stores data in a
json-like documents with dynamic schema
we will prefer a non-sql solution as
opposed to a relational database for
microservices because
we won't need relationships across the
data because each microservice manages
its own database
we don't need acid guarantees where acid
stands for atomicity consistency
isolation and durability which are
properties of database transactions that
we don't need in our services
we won't need to write complex queries
since most of our service queries will
be able to find everything they need in
a single document type
and we need low latency high
availability and high scalability which
are classic features of nosql databases
let's go ahead and implement our items
repository
before implementing a repository we will
need to decide which is going to be the
class that represents the objects that
will be managed by the repository and
that will make their way into our
database
the classes we use for this should not
be confused with our details because we
want to have the freedom of updating how
we store the items in the database at
any given point regardless of the
contract that we'll need to honor with
our service clients
we will then give the name of entities
to the classes that are repository use
so let's start by adding a directory to
store these entities so right click on
play catalog service let's add a new
folder let's call this one entities
and inside entities let's add a new file
and our main entity here is going to be
the catalog items so let's just call
this one
item.cs and here let's go ahead and
delete our namespace
it's going to be namespace
entities
and now let's declare the class
all right so our item entity is going to
have
a good
which is going to be the id
and let me ctrl dot to import the system
a space
it's going to need a name
it also needs a description
and we also need
the price
and finally we are going to need
a daytime offset that's going to be the
created date
okay so now it's time to actually add a
repository but before doing that we're
going to need a nuget package the
mongodb driver nuget package because
this is the one that's going to allow us
to actually interface with the bongodb
database so to do that i'm going to do
ctrl j in my keyboard to open the
terminal
and i'm going to switch to the directory
where we have the
catalog service so that would be
a catalog service
so then i'll just do
net
add package
mongodb.driver
so this will bring in a bunch of uh
libraries
that we're going to be using
um
for interacting with bungryb
so and you can configure the the package
was added if you click on play catalog
service csprock you'll see that we have
the new library right here
okay so now uh let me just close this
terminal
and now we can actually create a
directory for our repositories so i
right click play catalog service new
folder repositories
and in this folder i'll create a new
file uh again since this repository is
going to be managing our catalog items
i'll name it
items repository
that's yes
and at this point i'll just close this
navigation pane so we get more space
let's add a namespace
it's going to be repositories
and the name like we said
public class items repository
okay in order to be able to interact
with mongodb we're going to need a few
class level variables here
the first thing that we're going to
define is actually a constant
we're going to name it
collection name
collection
name
which is going to be the value is going
to be just items so the collection name
represents the group a a collection
represents a group of objects in mongodb
similar to us in a relational database
you will have a table in mongodb you
have a collection okay so the collection
that we're going to store all these
items in mongodb is going to be named
items in our case
now we're going to define the variable
that's going to hold the actual instance
of this mongodb collection so let's name
this one
read only i
[ __ ] collection
of item
db collection
okay so i'm i'm going to need to start
importing spaces here so ctrl dot to
import mongodb the driver
and ctrl dot to import play catalog
service entities like i said dvd
collection is the object that represents
our actual mongodb collection
we'll add one more
class level viral here to
represent the the the filter builder
that we're going to be using to build
the filters to query for items in the
mongodb
so
let's declare a filter
definition builder
of type item
let's name it filter builder
and we can get that from builders
of item
dot filter
now that we have that we can go ahead
and declare the constructor of this a
repository
so
public items repository
and here what we want to get is to
actually construct the instance for db
collection but before we can do that we
have to start by
using the [ __ ] client class which is
the one that you can use to actually
connect to the database here's where you
declare how you're going to connect to
mongodb
so we're going to say [ __ ] client
equals new
[ __ ] client
and here we can specify the connection
string to connect to mongodb for now
we'll just declare this connection
string
right here in plain text but later on
we'll move this connection into a more
to a more suitable place
so it's going to be mongodb
localhost
27 0 17.
also in a future lesson we will learn
how to actually stand up that mongodb
server so that it actually lives in
localhost 27017.
now we're going to declare the object
that represents the database the actual
database where these
catal guides are going to live so
database
equals mongol client
get database
and then the name that we're going to
give to this database since this is the
catalog microservice the name is going
to be just catalog
finally we can give get an instance for
db collection and we can do that
by doing
database
that get collection
of item and then we give it the
collection name that we have already
declared
okay we'll be using this divi collection
object for a few a few operations in a
moment
now for the repository public methods we
will be using the asynchronous
programming model this will avoid
performance bottlenecks and enhance the
overall responsiveness of our service
to take advantage of this model all
fermenters will become asynchronous by
returning asynctask and by using the
await keyword anytime they interact with
the database
we will also use the async suffix on all
the methods to surface the fact that the
methods are asynchronous
okay so the first method that we're
going to implement is the one that's
going to be able to return all the items
in the database so let's name this one
fully async task
of i read only
collection of item
get all async
okay so i'm using a i'm using a
namespace here so like i said we need to
return task to make this method async
and i'm also using i read only
collection here because really the
expectation from the the point of view
of the consumer is that we're going to
provide a collection of items
that the the consumer should not need to
modify so this is a collection that
should only be read right so this is a
good api pattern to follow
how with this collection of items so
basically we can do
return await
tv collection then we can do find define
operation
and here since we are not going to
really provide any filter because we
want all the items we can just say
filter builder dot empty
delete sync
to convert that list into an
asynchronous
list and then yeah that will give us all
the items in the database
okay so let's now declare a method that
we can use to get one specific item from
the database so i'm going to declare
public async again task of item in this
case
and we'll name this method get async
it's going to receive a good it's going
to be the id
of the item and i'm going to import the
system in space for this
okay let's scroll down a bit
and then
to be able to query for this item we
need to create a filter so i'm going to
declare a filter definition
of type item
let's name it filter
and then
we're going to use the filter builder
to say that we want to build an
equality-based filter
we're going to receive this this entity
object
where the entity.id
should match the id of the of the
parameter that we just received okay so
that's how you can build a filter to
find a
one of the items based on id
then we can just say return await db
collection
find
that we provide the filter
and we'll say
we want to get the first item that we
find so we're going to use first or
default async in this case
so that will find the first item in that
collection that matches that filter
let's now add a method to be able to
create an item into the database
so to do that we can define
fully case in task
create async
receive
our item that we're calling it an entity
here
and the first thing we're going to do is
a quick check uh to make sure that the
that receive parameter is not null so
if entity is no
we're just going to run a section
[Music]
argument exception and we're going to
name
and give the name of our entity
parameter
okay and then to create the actual item
is as easy as saying
um
await the collection
insert one async and then we provide
right so that will go ahead and create
the item into the database
the next method we're going to implement
is i want to update an item an existing
item into the database so to do that i'm
going to declare
public async task of data is sync
notice that both create and update are
not returning really anything so the
citation is that we just insert or
update the item but we're not going to
return anything back to the client
um
here we're going to receive
the item to update
let's call it entity that's the item to
update
all right
and just like we did with create let's
do a quick check make sure that we're
not getting an old value here
and now we're going to build our again
our first definition to be able to find
that item and i'm going to copy the one
from get async just because it's a very
similar filter
the only difference here is going to be
that we're going to rename this this
parameter here to
existing entity just to not confuse
with the the entity that we're going to
use to find the id so we're going to say
we need to find the existing entity
whose id matches the entity that we
received
that id
so that's a filter to find the existing
item and then we can go ahead and say
weight the collection dot
replace one async
we pass the filter
and we pass the entity that has to
replace the existing item found by that
filter
and finally let's implement the mentor
to delete an item from the database
so we're going to say
public acing
task
it's going to be remove async
you find the id of the item to
to delete
again we're going to use a filter very
similar to the one we use for
get async so i'm going to copy that one
once again
so copy that
that finds the item
and then we can say
weight db collection
delete one async
and we pass the filter
yep that should go ahead and
delete the item from the database
and with that our itunes repository is
ready
so in the next lesson we will integrate
it with our existing isis controller so
that it can start creating items from
mongodb
it is time to integrate our new items
repository with our existing items
controller
but before we can do that we are going
to need a wait a way to translate our
new item entities into our existing item
dto
specifically for the purposes of
returning these ctos in our
get operations in the rest api
so there's a few ways to do this but one
simple way that we can achieve this is
by introducing an extension method so
let's see how to do this we're going to
right click on play catalog service and
we're going to add a new file that we're
going to name
extensions that's cs
let's add any space here
namespace
play catalog service
and here we're going to declare
a class that we're going to name those
extensions
and in this one we declare
a public static
method that returns itdto
and this is because all extension
methods should be
should be static
and we're going to name it as dto
so this method is going to receive a
current instance of an item entity
okay and then let's import namespace
control dot play catalog service ctos
and
play catalog service entities
okay so the purpose is to just turn the
item entity into the item dto and to do
that we just have to do
return new item dto
and we're going to provide here the
different parameters right everything
comes from the entity so item id
item that name
item description
item the price and item that created
date
okay so as you can see it's a very
simple method that just turns an item
into an identity
we'll see how we use this in our
controller
so now let's open up that controller so
controllers items controller and i'm
going to close the navigation pane once
again to have more space
and the first thing that we're going to
do is to actually get rid of this list
we don't need it anymore
and we're going to replace it with a
variable for our repository so it's
going to be private
again read only because we don't want it
to be modified after construction
items
repository
and we're just going to say new so it's
going to get constructed
when the controller gets constructed i'm
going to import the writing space here
so let's start using this item
repository here
however since you remember all of the
methods in itunes repository i are
asynchronous methods we will also have
to turn all the metals in this
controller into asynchronous methods
that way we can have the asynchronous
benefits all the way from the controller
all the way to the
to the repository and to mongodb
so to do that i'm going to turn
let's start with get the get all so
we're going to turn this into async
task of innovable of identito
and we're going to append the async
suffix to this method
let's import a missing
treating tasks
and now to return the items well this is
what we can do
items is going to be
weight
item repository
get all async
okay
and then from that we're going to
project these items into these item
entities into dtos before we can do that
we have to
put this into a parenthesis
and then we can say okay so from that
let's do
select
and each of the item entities is going
to be turned into a dto via our new
astitu extension method that's there you
can see how it how easy it makes it this
extension method to turn an existing
entity into a dto
and then we just return those items
okay so let's go to the next method so
this is get by id so once again we will
turn it into async task
of action result of it and dto
get item get by id async
and then to get the item
what we're going to do now is just
wait i can repository
get
async
and we provide the id
and at the end of this method we can
just return that item entity we have to
say as dto so that turns the entity as
into a dto
let's now go for the post method
let's scroll down a little bit
so once again this has to be an async
task
of action result of identity
and it's going to be post async
task instead of doing this we're going
to uh
create an item entity in this case out
of the properties of create identity so
we're going to say bar item equals new
item and we're going to start giving it
the the properties values so
create individual name
description
description
and create a date
uh here's where we're going to give the
current date as the creation date of
this
of this item
also remember this is not identity or
this is just item
okay i may need a name space here yeah
empty disney space
now we can go ahead and actually create
the item via our
items repository
that create async methods and then we
pass the item
and finally we have to rename this
method from get the id to the new name
which is get via the async the one that
we just renamed
because that's where the created action
should point to
let's now go ahead and implement our
boot method
scroll down
so once again we turn this into public
async
task
of i action result
put async
and once again we have to do things a
little bit different now
so i'm going to actually remove this
this whole block here
and first thing we're going to do is
find the item now in the via the
repository so it's going to be existing
item
we're going to see it's going to be
await item repository that gate async
notice also how easy it is to actually
interface with mongodb via our item
repository without having to write the
same piece of code once and again right
at the filters and all that so we just
got the item just like that
and then
yeah if you if we cannot find the item
in the database in which case it will
return no
we want to keep returning
not found just like before
and here once we find the item we will
have to just update these properties
based on update item dto so that's going
to be
existing item that name
equals update identity of that name
existing item the description
date identity of that description
and existing item that
price of the identity of that price
and with that we can go ahead and say
await item repository
update async with the existing item
and finally let's go ahead and update
our delete method
so we're going to say
again
async task
i can result delete async
and we're going to do a similar logic to
find the item as we just did with update
so i may just copy this piece here
okay i'm actually going to remove all
this
paste that
okay i'm going to say
so yeah so var item is dedicated async
if the item is no we'll say not found
and otherwise we can go ahead and say
weight
item repository
dot remove async with item that id
and then one last thing that we may want
to tackle here since we are making these
changes is to actually um
fix an issue a kind of a breaking change
that happened in asp.net core 3 where if
you try to do let me go back to post if
you have to do a post and do create an
action into a method that ends with
async with an async suffix uh that's
actually not going to work because at
runtime uh
sp netcore is going to remove the async
suffix
from the method and that will make it so
that created action will not be able to
redirect to the right place or to
prevent to produce the heaters that it
needs to produce and so there's an easy
fix for that so let's actually make that
fix right away so i'm going to back
going to go back to explorer
going to open startup
and let's locate the section
where we do add controllers in configure
services inad controllers
we're just going to add a little option
here
so it's going to say
options
and then we open and close
braces and we're going to say options
that
suppress async suffix
in action names is going to be false
and with that at runtime uh asp.net core
is not going to
remove the
async suffix from any any four metres
and that will make possessing work just
fine
so a rest api is ready to use our new
repository to store and query the items
in the mongodb database however we still
don't have an aqua mongodb database or
even a mongodb server
but that's a problem that we can easily
solve via docker
in the next lesson we will learn about
docker and how we can use it to run the
infrastructure components needed by our
microservices
in this lesson we'll learn about docker
and how it can be used to run
infrastructure components needed by your
microservices
so what is docker
docker is a platform that provides the
ability to package and run an
application in a loosely isolated
environment called a container
here's how it works we start with our
catalog service which as we know needs a
database to store and query for items
the piece of software that knows how to
stand up and operate this database in
our case is mongodb
the mongodb server along with all the
software prerequisites has already been
packaged in what we call a docker image
and this image is publicly available in
a place called docker hub
we want to download and run this image
in our box and to do that we use the
docker engine
which is one of the pieces that you
installed at the start of this model
all docker images are guaranteed to run
anywhere the docker engine is available
to pull and run this image we will use
the docker run instruction in our box
once the image is run or executed it
becomes what is known as a docker
container
a mongodb container in this case
this is a fully working mongodb server
ready to respond to the requests of our
catalog microservice
the catalog service will create a
database via the mongodb container and
will start interacting with it via the
mongodb driver4.net
notice that even when this container
manages the catalog database the
database itself does not live inside the
container but outside of it to ensure
that it is not deleted once the
container is destroyed
let's try it out
to start using docker in my box i'll
start by opening a terminal so i'll
press ctrl j
and then i'll also close our navigation
pane just so we have a bit more space
and the first thing that i'll do is i'll
just type docker run to run a container
and then i'll specify the demodifier so
that we don't keep being attached to the
docker process all the time
and then i'll do
rm so this we'll use so that whenever we
stop running the container it gets
automatically deleted so that we don't
keep hanging it around in the box
next i'll specify a name
which is going to be
just [ __ ] so you can put any name here
but the idea is that uh you don't lose
track of this a docker container because
otherwise you get a random name and it's
a bit hard to identify
next we have to specify a port so we
have to specify which is the port that
we're going to be using to talk to
mongodb the among the v server so we'll
specify
p
27 0 17 map to 27 0 17. so this means
that in order for us to reach the
mongodb container we can use port 27017
is the external port
and then uh in order to
to to get that mapped into the internal
mongodb server we have to map into 27017
also so this port is the default port
that mongodb uses internally and this
just means that from the outside we open
kind of a window uh in order to talk to
the container via 27017 and then that
can be mapped into the internal port
where mongodb is already listening
you could be using any port in the left
side as really up to you we're just
choosing a default map in there
then we'll specify a volume the volume
we're going to be using so that we
specify how we are going to store the
database files that mongodb is going to
be using so we're going to say
mongodb data
colon slash data slash db so this
section on the right side of the column
slash it is tv is a default location
where mongodb stores the database files
so this mapping means that any time that
the mongodb server tries to store files
inside the container under slash data tv
those files are actually not going to be
written inside the container but outside
of the container into this location
called mongodb data which is part of our
local localhost machine so it's outside
of the container so this is the way that
we can prevent
those database files from being deleted
anytime the docker container gets also
deleted
and finally we'll specify the name of
the docker image that we want to run in
this case is [ __ ]
now i'll hit enter
i'll perhaps expand this a little bit
more
so at this time uh docker is pulling the
all the layers of of the mongodb docker
image into my box
okay so layer by layer it gets unloaded
uh just the first time uh and this this
may take a while but the second time
that you do this and any subsequent time
this is going to be much faster because
the image is already there so if i did
if i did that again it will run
instantly
then we can confirm that the docker
image is actually executing by just
running docker ps
as you can see the docker image is up
and running it's been running for 14
seconds right now
okay so now we can try running our res
api against this soccer container and
see how that goes so i'll hit a five
here
and i'll go to our swagger page
so the first thing that we can try just
to verify that there's nothing here
because it's a brand new database is our
get all items um operation so i'll try
it out
i'll hit execute
and as you can see there's nothing in
there the databases is all empty
so let's next let's try creating
something so i'll go to our post
operation try it out
and let's let's try to create something
here
so we will go back to our
back to our potion sample so i'll just
name this potion
and this is going to
restore a small amount
of hp
and the price is going to be five
and with that i'll hit execute
and as you can see the item has been
created we got a 201 response code
create that action here's a response
body and we also got the location here
to find our item
so in fact we can copy the this id of
this item and we should be able to use
our get by id operation to find it so
i'll collapse this i'll expand get items
by id
i'll try it out
paste the item here
execute
and certainly we can find the item
so the item has been stored into the
database
but now if you wanted to know how this
item has been stored into the mongodb
database there's an easy way to figure
that out so i'll go back to visual
studio code
and then i'll just stop and close this
and what you can do is use a mongodb
extension for visual studio code so to
install that just go to the extensions
hub on the left side
look for mongodb
and should be the first hit on the left
side so i click on that i'll click on
install
and now there's a new icon showing up on
the left side for mongodb which i'll
click now
and then i it should connect
straightforwardly into the mobile dvd
database just by expanding this node for
localhost 27017 since it's the default
port it just connected so i'll expand
this
and as you can see there's a catalog
database available right there
so it has been created if i expand that
there is an items collection available
this is the one that we will be storing
our items and then i'll expand that
further
and as you can see there is one document
already created into the catal database
if we expand that we can see that
there's an item in there
however if we try clicking clicking on
it let's click on it
but you can see you can see
most of the members of the created item
but some of them are not easy to
recognize like for instance the id is
not the gui that we were expecting and
the created date is a bit hard to read
the other elements are there so potion
description and price
so how can we get a better a more
friendly uh
the more friendly representation of
these items like id and created date so
ideally we want to see something more
easily recognizable
so there's actually an easy way to to
fix this let's go back to our explorer
and let's go to our startup class
okay once again i'll collapse this
so to fix the json representation of our
items we just need to register a couple
of mongodb serializers we can do this in
the configured services method of the
startup class
we will talk more about the role of
startup in acefinite core apps in next
lesson but for now let's just think of
your services as the place where we
register services that can be used
across entire application so let's
scroll down a little bit here we are in
configure services
and what i'm going to do is just expand
this a bit
and i'm going to add
visual serializer
and for this i may need to import
namespace mongodb that based on that
serialization
that register
serializer
and here we're going to provide the
serializer we want to use in this case
it's going to be new
good serializer
and then i'll import mongodb bsun
serialization serializers
and then it's going to be
and type
and then import one more namespace
that string
okay so that means that anytime we store
any
document into mongodb
with a good type it will be stored
actually as a string as opposed to the
representation that we're looking at a
moment ago
and we're going to do pretty much the
same thing
for our the datetime offset so in this
case we're going to say so
instead of quick serializer we'll use
date time offset serializer
and then this line now says that anytime
we store any document with a datetime
offset a property it should be stored
that probably should be stored as a
string
so save that and that should be enough
to fix our representation of the items
in there however uh to to not mix things
what i'll do now is i'll actually delete
our existing database so that we can
recreate it with the proper esterization
type so i'll close this here and i'll go
back to our mongodb extension
and i'll right click in the catalog
database i'll say drop database
i'll type the name
enter and if we refresh this there
should be no database available anymore
okay so with that
let's hit f5 once again
okay back in soccer ui let's see if we
still have the post available here yes
we have
so i'll just refresh the page
and i'll go back to post
and once again we should have no items
so actually i'll go to get all items try
it out execute so there's no items
because a new database has just been
created because we deleted the previous
one so back into post
i'll try it out
and i'll paste the what we typed a
moment ago so it's a potion price five
restore small amount of hp
and i'll hit execute
and once again the item has been created
with this id
and this time we'll go back to visual
studio code
and let's see how that got stored so
i'll refresh this right click refresh
expand catalog items documents and as
you can see the id it already looks like
a good and if i click on it
and i'll close this a bit now we have a
much friendly representation of the item
the id is a proper good
and the created date is a daytime offset
that we can actually understand
so that's the effect of using these
serializers in there
so let's continue using our res api
let's make sure all the operations are
working properly so as we saw we just
created this item
and if we use get items by id we should
be able to find it so let's confirm that
paste it there execute
so yeah indeed we were able to find the
item
now let's try an update on an item so to
do that let's use the put api so i'll
click and expand this i'll say try it
out let's grab the actually the id of
that item once again
so it's over here
here's the id
so i'll paste it here so we're going to
update that potion
and then for the
for the elements of this
of this potion let's copy also a few of
the existing elements
so i'll copy this from our gave id route
into here
actually inside
there i'll remove this extra comma
and so the only thing we're going to
define here is just the price of the
potion so instead of being five i'll say
it's going to be price seven
and i'll hit execute
i've got a 204 so no content
successful no content so this means that
the item has been updated and to confirm
that let's go back again into our get by
id route
let's execute again
and as you can see the price has been
updated so output route is working just
fine
and for the final exercise let's try to
delete this potion right so i'll go
ahead and copy
again the id of the position
and let's collapse this and that and
let's go to the delete route
try it out
paste here hit execute
204 no content
and it is a success
so
the item should no longer be there so
i'll try to actually get this item by id
once again let's see what happens
i suspect it's 404 it can't find the
item
and in fact if we go to get all items
there's nothing there so the item was
deleted
okay so at this point we have a fully
working res api with all the basic cloud
operations that's working against a
mongodb database
but we still need to polish a little bit
the code base that we have so far
so in the next lesson we will learn
about the dependence injection technique
and the net configuration system
in this lesson we will learn about the
dependency injection technique and the
net configuration system
what is defense injection
to understand what dependence injection
is we can start by thinking about a
class that uses some other class
for instance our items controller uses
the item's repository
when you have this relationship where
one class uses another class we say that
this second class is a dependency of the
first class
now if instead of constructing the
item's repository object directly as we
are doing so far
we receive an instance of items
repository in the items controller
constructor
then we are injecting item repository
into itunes controller
this is what we call dependency
injection
but also notice that the constructor is
not exactly receiving an instance of
item repository but instead it receives
an interface called items repository
this relates to what we call the
dependency inversion principle
the defensive version principle states
that code should depend on abstractions
as opposed to concrete implementations
let's bring again our class and one of
its dependencies dependency a
currently the class depends directly on
dependency a
however we can change this so that the
class instead depends on an abstraction
which in the case of c sharp is an
interface
and then we can have the dependency
depend on
or implement the interface
why would we do this
well by doing this our class
implementation is decoupled from the
dependence implementation in such a way
that if we ever decide to switch to a
different or updated dependency our
class does not need to change at all
the only thing that the dependencies
need to do is to implement the interface
that our class depends on
so by having our code depend on
instructions we are decoupling
implementation from each other
and this also makes our code cleaner
easier to modify and easier to reuse
now that our code is decoupled from
these dependencies we have a new problem
how and who is going to construct the
dependencies
imagine once again that we have our
class which depends on an interface
implemented by dependency a
since our class cannot construct the
dependency directly
because it only knows about the
interface
a third actor comes into play which is
called the service container
which in asp.net core is known as
iservice provider
loading application startup which
typically happens in serap.cs in asp.net
core apps
we would register our dependencies with
the service container and this one in
turn builds a map of all the register
dependencies
then eventually when our class needs to
get constructed the service container
first finds
constructs the dependency or reuses it
if it already has been constructed
and then injects it into our class as it
creates our class instance
this is very powerful because you could
even have dependencies that depend on
other dependencies
but as long as they all have been
registered with the service container
they will all be resolved properly
whenever any class needs them during the
application life cycle
let's also talk about configuration
at this point our service is able to
talk to our mongodb database via the
host and port information that have been
hard-coded in our service implementation
however this is not ideal since
eventually the mongodb docker container
will live outside of our local box where
localhost will likely not make sense
and port 2717 is not guaranteed to be
available
luckily afia net core supports a few
configuration sources that are able to
store and provide such configuration
details to our service when needed
one of the most popular sources
especially for local development is the
app settings.json file
where we can store all sorts of
computational information
that we expect could change across
environments
like the database host and port
and the good thing is that just like
this one there are several other sources
like command line arguments environment
variables
local secrets
and even the cloud
all these configuration sources are
automatically read for us and loaded
into the configuration system during
host startup which is configured in the
program cs file in asp.net core
applications
and from there we can get access to them
typically in our startup.cs file
let's now update our catalog service to
take advantage of both the penis
injection and the acl net core
configuration system
in order to start using dependence
injection in our microservice we will
need to start using interfaces as
opposed to concrete types when
constructing dependencies
let's start by updating item repository
so that it implements an interface that
we can use in ads controller
so let's go to
our repositories directory
items repository
and then we want to do is to extract the
interface that represents items
repository and we can do that by
clicking on item repository and as you
can see there's this yellow light bulb
over here you can click on that one and
then you can click on extract interface
by doing that as you can see the full
skeleton of the interface has been
extracted out of the
item repository class and item
repository is now implementing items
repository our new interface
we also want to have the interface
living in its own file just to follow
some good code organization across our
microservice
what i'll do is i'll click on i items
repository i'll click on the light bulb
and then i'll click on move type to
itemsrepository.cs
now i add the repository leaves in its
own file over here on the left side i
add repository in the same repositories
directory
and so with that done we are able to
start doing dependency injection of item
repository into the access controller so
i'll open the controllers directory i'll
go to items controller
i'll scroll up
all the way to the start of the class
and i'll start by updating our items
repository
definition here so that we actually use
i item repository as opposed to item
repository
and i will not create an instance right
there
it is time to introduce a constructor
for this controller so i will do
public items controller
and here we are going to inject the item
repository dependency so i items
repository
item repository
and here we'll just do
this that oh sorry
this that item depository equals item
repository
so just by doing that uh at the
repository has been injected into ideas
controller
now the same way that we are doing this
we also want to use dependency injection
in items repository itself so let's go
back to that file
because we don't want to be constructing
the mongol client like we're doing it
here we want to just receive an instance
of our
of our mongol database or imongo
database directly as appendix injection
so what i'll do is i'll just declare in
itunes repository and
imongo database
object and we'll say database
and with that we'll get rid of these two
lines
so now eisenhower repository is ready to
receive an instance of database via
defense injection
however now that we have removed those
lines we need a way to actually
construct this database object and
configure it
so let's go into the configuration part
of this now
to configure the
the host and the port that our service
needs to connect to what we can do is to
declare these settings in our app
settings.json file so let's go to app
settings.json
and here's the ideal place for you to
declare
these kind of configurations that could
change with different environments
so what i'll do is i'll open up another
section here
let's call it mongodb settings
so we'll open up a section i'll put a
comma also here
and then the first setting is going to
be the
host which in our case is we're running
against a
a server in our local machine it's going
to be just localhost
and the port
is going to be
27 0 17. the default port and the one
that we've been using in our docker
container
we are also going to add another
settings section to define our service
name this service name is going to be
used across a few places in our
microservice
so let's declare that just on top of
mongodb settings we will name it
this section is going to be service
settings
service settings
and we'll just declare one property here
which is going to be
service name
which in our case since this is a
catalog service we will just put the
value of catalog
okay so now we have a setting for the
service name and for the mongodb host
and port
now the thing is how do we consume these
settings in our codebase so there's a
couple of ways to do that but i think
the most straightforward way is to
define a class that represents each of
these two settings so that then our
codebase can start using them right away
so to do that what i'm going to do is
just right click on play that catalog
service or create a new folder that
we're going to naming
settings and in this folder i'll declare
classes for both service settings and
mongodb settings let's start with
mongodb settings actually and i'm
actually going to copy the name of the
settings so to make sure that the class
that we create here matches exactly the
name of mongodb settings in there so i
right click new file mongodb settings
dot cs
basically namespace
going to be play catalog service
settings
and let's declare our class
mongodb settings
and just as we just did it should have
properties for host and port
so let's declare
drop string
host
and prop string
for tactile this should be an integer so
prop import
and then since we are not planning to
change these settings after the the
microservice loads we will switch from
this this setter from set to init so
that will prevent any anybody on any
piece of the code
to modify the values after
they have been initialized
next we're going to also declare another
property kind of a calculated property
that's going to define the connection
string to mongodb so we're going to
declare public string
connection string
and we'll do a little bit of
string interpolation here
where we're going to declare mongodb
and that's going to have the host import
so the host comes from our host property
and the port comes from our
port property
okay so this is what we call an
expression body definition so it's a
property defined directly by the value
on the right side
right so we have a connection string
there
the next thing we need to do is define a
type class for service settings so i'll
copy the the name of service settings
here and then again alright click
settings new file service settings
dot cs
let's declare again namespace
catalog service settings
public class service settings
and the only property that we have for
this one is the service name
so prop string
service name
and again this will be
in it
now that we have all this defined it's
time to
start
constructing all these services
registering i'm constructing and
registering and registering and
constructing all these uh services that
we'll be using for depends injection and
also taking advantage of configuration
so to do that we'll go to the startup.cs
file
and i'm going to collapse this to get a
bit more space so we can see
and the first thing that i'll do is i'll
go to the
top of the startup class and i'll define
a variable a local class level variable
for our service settings just because
we'll we will be using it in a few
places across classes subsequent lessons
so
private
serv
service settings
service settings and i'll have to do
control dot to import play catalog
service settings
all right
and then
just before adding controllers
i'm going to open a section here
where first we're going to retrieve the
value of those service settings so we're
going to do is service settings
equals and here's where we access the
net configuration system where we'll be
at the configuration property that we
have available right here at the top
configuration so we're going to say okay
so configuration
we're going to get section
so we want to get the section that has
the name of
our service settings
class so this is what we wanted to make
sure that the class is named exactly as
the name of the configuration
and what we have got in that we're going
to turn it into the actual type so we're
going to say that get
service settings
there
so with that
we are
digitalizing the value of several
settings that has already been loaded
into the temp configuration system into
this service settings variable here
the next thing we're going to do is to
construct our mongodb client
to do that we're going to be using our
services collection so
we will do services which we receive in
the um as a parameter to configure
services
we're going to say at singleton
uh add singleton allows us to register a
type
or an object and
make sure it makes sure that there will
be only one instance of this object
across the entire
microservice in this case
so any class that needs it will get this
one instance so it so they can use it
so here we're going to receive the
service provider
okay so now we'll open an expression
here and i'll close it this with that
and just like we did with service
settings we're going to now define
or retrieve our mongodb settings
so i'm actually going to copy this
section here and we're going to say
this is going to be
mongodb settings
okay so is configuration get section
name of
mongodb settings
and then we will again convert it into
the actual mongodb settings type
now that we have the settings we are
able to construct the [ __ ] client which
like i said before is the the
class we need to use to actually connect
to mongodb so we will say
[ __ ] client
is a new [ __ ] client
and i'll import mongodb driver here
and here what we want to pass is the
connection string so to pass the
connection stream we will do
mongodb settings dot connection string
and finally now that we have the bongo
client we can
get the
instance of the database object that we
care about so we will do
return [ __ ] client
get database
and then what's the name of our database
well the name of our database is going
to be the one that we defined for the
service name service name is catalog our
database will be just catalog so service
settings that service name
and that's it
so with this uh
with this section we have defined a
singleton object that represents a an
imongo database that's going to be
injected as remember into um
items repository over here is going to
be landing over here i'm on the database
so here's where we're constructing and
registering it with the service
container
and then one more thing that we need
here is to uh also in register
the items repository dependency so we're
going to be doing
services that add singleton
and then we will use our new i items
items repository interface and then
i'll import the play catalog service
repositories namespace
and then the concrete type is going to
be
items repository
all right so this is this registration
is a bit different than the previous one
because the previous one in the prison
we're cons explicitly constructing
our mongol client and the mongol
database before registering it with the
service container well in this case
we're just declaring which is the type
that we want to register and which
interface implements and the exponential
runtime will take care of constructed
that instance whenever it is needed
so we should be ready to try this out
but what i'll do is i'll place a few
break points so we can see how things
start lighting up
as they do
so i'll put a free break point so i'll
put one over here
then i'll go to item repository and i'll
put one in the constructor over here
and i'll also go to our items controller
and i'll put another breakpoint here
and now i'll hit f5
okay so we can go to our soccer ui page
i'll go slash
swagger
and of course we don't have anything in
our database right now but regardless
our servers will need to construct all
these dependencies to be able to figure
out that this is actually no items right
now so i'll open up our get all items
operation i'll click on try it out and
then i'll click on execute
now back in vs code and now collapses a
bit
we are now in our startup file
and notice that we right away we are
entering into the add singleton section
here this is because uh so there is one
or more
services that need this [ __ ] imongodb
objects
so if we inspect the value of mongodb
settings
we can see that we already have defined
the host port and the calculated
connection string is right there and
that's what we are using to fit into the
[ __ ] client connection string
we should also have a value for service
name here from service settings has been
read from configuration and it's been
used to get the database
form that we're going to be using this
database is being will be constructed
the first time and the next time it will
be just reduced
so i'll hit
continue here
and now we are into items repository
which now is able to receive retrieve
that instance of the imongo database
object that has been constructed and
it's been injected here and it is via
that one that is going to be able to
retrieve the items collection that's
going to be used across the is
repository
then i'll click
continue and now we are in the itus
controller which is not able to now able
to retrieve
to receive that injected as a repository
that is going to also be been used be
used for all the operations
i click
continue and we're back into play
catalog service the socket ui which of
course it says there's no items right
now
but we know we can easily go ahead and
start creating items updating items and
all these things with the swagger ui
but yeah so depends injection is
configured and the configuration system
is enabled too
so we have reached the end of this model
with a fully working decoupled and
configurable microservice that is able
to store and guided for your catalog
items in a mongodb database
in the next module we will introduce our
second microservice and we'll be
learning about the multiple challenges
of having microservices talk to each
other
this module is an intermediate step to
get ready to build our future
microservices
we will learn about a few new tools that
will help you as you start working with
more microservices
and we will build a useful library that
we will use in future models
here's what you will achieve after
finishing this model
you will learn how to use postman as an
alternative to swagger ui to interact
with your microservices
you will generalize the items repository
so that it can be used with any future
entity
you will create a nuget package where
you will place all common classes that
you would like to reuse in future
microservices
and finally you will use docker compose
to simplify how to run mongodb and the
multiple infrastructure services to be
used in future models
let's get started
in this lesson we will learn about
postman which is a popular api client
that we will be using starting with this
model
postman will allow us to interact with
our microservices res apis without
having to open a browser to navigate to
the swagger ui page of each of the
services
in addition it will offer us a few
additional capabilities that will prove
useful across this course
the only additional tool required
starting with this model is the postman
client which you can get at this
location
let's get started
let's go ahead and install postman
i'll go to the postman download page at
postman.com
downloads
and here i'll just scroll down a little
bit i'll click on download the app
i'll pick my parent system
and that will start download
in the same way depending on your
operating system you can choose the mac
os or linux version
this should take just a few seconds
okay so it's downloaded i'll click on
the installer
and yeah the way that installer worked
for pulseman is that it will just pop up
this screen here so it's already
installing the application uh it will
take a few seconds and then the our the
postman ui will just pop up in your
screen
and here it is
and so at this point you have the option
to create an account with most men if
you want to keep track of your
collection settings and a bunch of
things that you may be interested in
but in our case
we really don't care about that at this
point so i'll just click that link at
the bottom side here skip signing in and
take me straight to the app so i'll just
click on that
and then we are in the postman uh user
interface
the first thing that i'll do here just
because i don't like this theme at all
so i'll just go to settings over here
settings
teams and then i'll switch to the dark
emote setting
okay so now that we have postman
available let's go back to our catalog
service and this code and let's start
waiting for its several apis so let's
minimize this i'll close this browser
and yeah here we are in the catalog
service
and then yeah i'll just do f5
all right so as usual the browser opens
but this time we are not going to be
using the browser we are going to go
straight into postman over here and here
uh what you can do to start creating
your rest api is uh if you have the
launchpad open like me you can click on
create a request over here or if you
don't have it open you can click on this
plus button to open a brand new tab in
this tab what you want to do the first
thing you want to do is figure out which
is the verb that you're going to use for
your res api if you click on this
drop-down you're going to find a bunch
of http verbs for the different
operations so let's say that we want to
start by doing a get uh so click on get
and so that we want to get the list of
items in our catalog api
uh so then you want to type here the url
of the address api and if you don't
remember the the host where you're
running your web server you can easily
find that out by going back to visual
studio code
and here you can find that
that url either right here in the debug
log where it says now listening on is
right here
or you can also find it if i scroll down
this a bit and then you open
properties launch settings.json
is right here close to the bottom where
it says application url is over here so
https localhost 5001. so i'm going to
copy that
and back into postman and so i'm going
to paste that over here
and then what you want to do is add the
route for our controller so once again
backing visual studio code if you open
controllers iris controller you're going
to find a route right here so router is
items
to copy that
back into postman
and i'll say slash items
and with that you can just hit send and
that's going to query the rest api
now if you get an error like the one
that i'm getting down here which says
ssl error unable to verify the first
certificate this is actually expected is
a default verification for the
certificate of your web server since we
are using a self-signed certificate that
comes bundled with asp.net core
that's not really a friendly certificate
for postman
but it is okay to get past that
verification because it's just a local
web server for development purposes so
what i'll do is i'll just click on
disable ssl verification
and that's going to go ahead and i'll
just close this and that goes ahead and
queries the rest api without issues
of course we don't have any items
available in the database right now so
that's why we see an empty array over
here but we can actually try out to
create a brand new
item and to do that what i'll do is i'll
click on the plus icon over here
which opens a new tab
and i'll switch from get into post
and once again i'll paste our our entire
route here so i'll copy from get i'll
paste it here in post
and then we want to do is go to the body
section over here
and we want to choose raw
and at the end of this section i'll pick
json
so i'll open up this
and here we go where we can define the
body that we want to send to this post
request so i'll open up a section uh as
a json section here
and i'll start typing the elements for
creating a in this case uh an item so if
you remember the the elements are a name
so we need a name
and let's say we go back to our portion
example so i'll just say potion
then we need a description
a description
is going to be
restores
a small amount of hp
and finally we'll set up a price
which is going to be let's say five
okay so with that done i'll do this i'll
go ahead and hit send
and as you can see the item has been
created
okay we have an id
and we if we wanted to we can now go
back to the get
tab here and we can query for items once
again so i'll click on send
and now we can get items
so just like this you can keep going on
and using the rest of our rest api
operations by opening new tabs and
opening and using the different verbs
over here
however
each of these times you'll have to
remember
what to put exactly on the on both on
the url and in the case of pause for
instance uh the body and the elements
that you want to use uh for the uh for
the for the payload to send in that body
right uh so what if you don't remember
exactly what to put in all these cases
so what i'd like to do is just show you
another way to do this to simplify a
little bit this this oral process so
what i'll do is i'll just right click
here and i'll close close all tabs
so
actually i'll say cancel
let me close this down save close that
so
one thing that you can do if we go back
into our browser over here is we can go
ahead and find the open api
specification for our api so if i go to
slash swagger
hit enter we're back into our soccer ui
page but this time we're not going to
use any of these methods we're going to
do is click on this if you can see this
swagger.json
link over here i'll click on it and this
opens the open api specification so this
describes the entire res api
in a standard way
so what i'll do is i'll copy this entire
url
and then i'll go back to postman and
i'll go into the import button over
here i'll click the link section
and then i'll paste that url over here
click continue
and finally i'll just say import
and now if we go into the collection
section over here
you're going to see that now we have a a
description of our play catalog service
listed here with all the requests so if
i open this
and there's the items
the items route and if you open that you
can see that we have routes a forget and
for post and also if we want to go by id
we can go ahead and get an item by id we
can do the put which requires an id and
we can do also the delete
so this time if you want invited to get
a ghetto items what i can do is just
click on
get items
and then that's going to open a
a tab with an already filled in
verb and url to go ahead and request the
items
however you're going to notice one new
thing here which is the base url so the
visual represents uh really the root of
your or where you're hosting your res
api at this point so this is the
localhost 5001 section so postman just
doesn't know that information just yet
it just knows about the routes and the
payloads so to fill in this this
variable here base url what you can do
is go to back to play catalog service
over here click on these three dots
click on edit
and then you go to the variable section
here
and then you want to put a value for
for current value so what i'll do is
i'll just put https
localhost
5001
okay i'll also put that in initial value
this is what's somebody else that wanted
to reuse your postman collection it
would have as an initial value if they
wanted to so i'll just keep the same
value for both of them
so then i'll just hit update
and now if we hov a hover over base url
you can see that now we have
the result value being pop-up there uh
for our res api
so now i can go ahead and hit send
and once again i get my items
but more interestingly if i wanted to do
a post this time i can click on post
and then again the the url the birth is
filled the url is right there and the
body is already pre-populated with all
the elements required for this api
let's actually try to do a put so i'll
go ahead now into put
and again the url is pre-filled in there
we want to do is to in this case
first we need the id of the item which
we can get from the get items tab here
so i'll just copy that id
back to put and i can put the id right
there
and then in terms of the
of the body
i can go to the body section and like i
said it is pre-filled so i just have to
put the elements for this body
so i'll actually just copy
those elements from here
okay
and now do a proper indentation
and so here's where we can go ahead and
update something about this potion so
i'll just update the price again so i'll
say seven
and then we're going to click on send
and we got a response uh 204 no content
meaning that
it succeeded and so now we can actually
try let me copy the id of this item we
can try our get buy id api
and then again the url is pre-filled
i'll just paste the id over here i'll
hit send
and there it is we got a our potion
so as you can see it is pretty handy to
just import the open specification of an
api specification into postman and be
able to be able to quickly very quickly
start working with your rest api
imposement
now a few other things that are
available in postman as opposed to our
previous swagger ui page is things like
for instance of course we have the the
concept of these collections which in
fact you can actually export if you
wanted to and share this with somebody
else in your team or some of your
teammates you can easily export this
collection
and you will do that by clicking these
three dots and you can click on export
and there's going to be a few options
for you to export this for somebody else
then also we you have a this this tab
over here that says history this will
show the history of all the
previous implications of your res api so
if you wanted to go back to something
that you did in the past with the
specific payload that you did and url uh
you can do that so this is going to keep
a long list of all the
the queries that you've made to your api
across your different sessions
there's also this concept of
environments over here
which you can use to define the
different environments where you want to
invoke your request api so if eventually
you're not just running in your
localhost machine but perhaps you have
deployed this to some a cloud
environment you can define variables
over there so that you don't have so
that for instance device url
automatically changes as you change the
environment that you're specifying over
here
that way you don't have to keep opening
more and more tabs for the different
environments
there's also the ability to specify
authorization options over here
for the different authorization types
uh so that you can for instance generate
a generate and use uh
authorization tokens to call your res
api if your recipi is enabled for that
that's actually something that we'll
look at in a future a model okay so now
that we have done that uh one more thing
that we want to do is to since we are
not going to be using post one we don't
really want to be opening browsers all
the time so how can we prevent the
browser from uh keep opening every
single time so let me just go back to
the browser and i'll just click close
this
and then i'll go back to visual studio
code
and let's stop and close this
and what you can do is to go back to we
go to explorer
and we're going to go to that vs code
launch.json
and you want to look for this section
that says server ready action
so this section here is the one that
visual studio code uses to define if
they wanted to open a browser after
something happens with the web server in
this case it's just looking for the
message that says now listening on
so when it finds that it knows that it
needs to open the browser so in our case
we don't want to open browsers anymore
we'll find with postman so we're just
going to remove this section
delete
and now if i do f5
okay
no browser is going to open
we just stay here
uh but as as always you can just go to
postman and start creating the api like
we already did
okay so that's it for this lesson and in
the next lesson we will start extracting
a few of the classes that we are using
in catalog microservice into some shared
components that we can use in our future
microservices
in this lesson we will learn about the
need to reuse common code across
microservices and how the nuget package
manager can be used to package and share
code across services in a
straightforward way
one of the things that you will likely
realize as you start building more than
one microservice is how much code starts
getting repeated between each service
implementation
for instance our catalog microservice
currently has a repository
implementation for querying and storing
data in its mongodb database
it also has a couple of settings classes
to more easily use the different service
configurations that are stored in our
app settings.json file
eventually we will also add classes to
interact with our service broker
code to add instrumentation to the
services and likely some more code that
is not directly related to the purpose
of the microservice
the problem with this is that as soon as
we bring in our second microservice the
inventory service we would likely need
to copy to it that same code with very
little modifications
this is time consuming and goes against
the don't repeat yourself principle
which states that every piece of
knowledge must have a single unambiguous
authoritative representation within a
system
which in our case means that our common
code should live and be maintained in a
single place
therefore
we could be tempted to keep our common
code in one of our microservices and
have all the other services simply
reference that project to get access to
the common code
however this is not a good idea because
microservices should be independent of
each other to ensure each of them can
evolve quickly and have no ties to the
internal implementation of others
we can solve this problem by introducing
a new library project that we will call
the common library and then we can
extract all the common code into it
the common library becomes the single
place where we have all the code that is
not specific to any microservice and
therefore is the single place where we
will perform any updates to it when
needed
but then
how can we make the code in this new
common library available to our
microservices
we could have our microservices add a
direct reference to the library project
file
but that's not a good idea because as
new members join our team each of them
might want to work on one microservice
or the other or even in the common
library and therefore they will only
graph the code base for the project they
are interested in but not the code basis
of all projects all the time
plus eventually each microservice and
the common library should get their own
independent source control repository
where they can be tracked and built
independently
so if the microservice projects can
access the common project directly what
can they do
here is where we can use nougat which is
the package manager for dotnet
with nuget we can execute a simple
command like dotnetpak to bundle all the
output files from the common project
into a nougat package
another package is nothing more than a
zip file with a new pkg extension that
contains all the files that are to be
shared with other projects
now each of our microservices can
reference the nougat package to get
access to everything that the common
library has to offer
and the good thing is that microservice
projects don't need to know where these
nuget packages are hosted
we will initially place the package in
our local machine but eventually you
will likely want to host them in a
cloud-based location either accessible
just by your team or by anybody on the
web the important thing is that
regardless of the location you won't
have to change how the microservices
access the common code
with our new common noked package our
common code is now maintained in a
single place
and the time to build new microservices
is significantly reduced
in the next lesson we will extract our
current common code into a new common
library and we will produce our first
nuget package that the catalog
microservice and every filter service
will be able to reference to get quick
access to the common code
if we take a look at our item repository
class over at repositories items
repository
we will notice that there's a lot of
code here that we will need to reuse in
future microservices
and the same goes for our settings
classes over in the settings directory
mongodb settings service settings
we can certainly reuse these in future
microservices
but before we can move anything to a new
shared library we will need to do some
good refactoring to keep the generic
pieces separated from what's really
needed in the catalog microservice
so let's start by looking at our items
repository
and if we take a closer look at what's
going on here there's one piece that's
really repeated a lot across this class
and that is the use of the item entity
the item entity is being used uh
in several cases like for instance in
ghetto lacing is being used to return
the items that are going to be queried
and we are also filtering by the id of
this item
in both in engage async method and also
in the update async method will
filtering by id and also in the remove
async method
so we need to find a way to generalize
the use of this entity so that it can be
used in like i said in a more general
way in this repository so let's actually
go to the item entity so right click go
to
definition
but what we're going to do here is to
actually extract an interface out of
this item class
uh to
nail down narrow down the pieces that we
really need to generalize about the item
so we're going to do is just click on
the light bulb
and say extract interface
and now we have the item interface here
that our item class is implementing
however we don't want to call this
interface i item we actually want to
call it
i
int
and this ai entity
is what our item class is going to
implement
but also we don't want to have all these
properties in the interface but only
daily having the id will be good enough
to be used in the repository class we're
going to implement
now we also want to move this interface
into a different file
so i'm going to click on the light bulb
and i'm going to move the type to
indit.cs
okay so now we have a i the item entity
that implements i entity
that is in the i entity.cs file over
here
now what we're going to do is to before
going back to the item repository let's
go to the items repository class
and see how we can generalize this
so to start with
we don't want this class to be
about just items anymore but about a
generic type and the way that we can do
this is to by renaming this interface
into
uh instead of iot depository is going to
be i repository
and it is going to be off a generic type
that we're going to use name t where t
represents the actual entity that's
going to be used in a specific
microservice
so this t will add a constraint here
where t
is has to be
and i entity
the interface that we just defined so
whatever we use for t it has to be a
class that implements the identity
interface
so now that we have that generalization
we can say that all of our methods
actually use this
this t type so for instance instead of
having item here we're going to name it
as t
and the same the same way we're going to
do for the item that's going to return
in general lacing
the item does return in get async
and
also the item
the entity that's received in updated
sync
okay so with that there's no longer a
mention of the item type anywhere in
this interface
so with that done we can now go back to
our items repository and also generalize
it to represent a more generic
repository
so instead of being an items repository
this is now going to be
a [ __ ] repository
that is going to be off some type so
again we're going to use a type t to
represent the actual
entity that's going to be managed by
this repository and also our repository
class now needs to implement the i
repository
of the interface
again
where t
is an i entity
okay
so let's also rename the constructor
to be [ __ ] repository
and let's start changing this so that it
actually to start removing everything
related to item from this class so one
of the things that we have to get rid of
is this constant
that is the collection name items uh
since this is not going to be just about
items anymore let's remove it and what
i'm going to do is just copy collection
name
just the name of the var for the
constant and remove it
and now we are going to receive that
collection name as a parameter in the
constructor so we're going to receive
string collection name
so that's a collection name that's going
to be used when we try to retrieve a
collection
from mongodb from here on
okay and so now we need to start moving
forward and
start analyzing things so let me just
get a copy of t
and so anywhere where we find item we
want to replace it with t
so this is a db collection of t filter
builder of t
builders of t dot filter
and we get a collection of a t
a i t entity
when we do get a lacing we have to do t
again
and again when we do the filtering so
get is of t d over here
it's all generic
also create async should be t
update async should be also t
filter definition of t
and notice that since our actual since
our interface has the id property it
doesn't really care
that it doesn't know what's a real item
as long as that
the real entity sorry as long as that
entity implements a identity it is able
we know that there's going to be an id
property a quick id property that we can
filter by
and finally let's
change our remove async to also deal
with just with t
all right so just to confirm let's make
sure we don't have item anywhere in this
file anymore yep there's no more item
here
so
let's also rename the file by the way
so this should be
mango
repository and this other file here
should be
a repository
and with that done
it is time to start fixing all the
references to our repositories so let's
start by going to our controllers class
items controller
and let's fix things right so this is no
longer an iates repository it's just
and i repository
of type item
and that is what we are going to be
receiving in the itunes controller in
the constructor here
okay
next thing that we need to do is to fix
the way that we are registering the
repository in startup so let's open up
startup
and let's see how we are registering the
repository over here so this is what
we're doing today at singleton i attend
repository item repository
so we will switch to a more
a more concrete way of defining this
singleton because now we need to specify
a parameter as an input to the
repository so remember in manga
repository
now we are receiving a collection name
so we cannot just just expect to all
parameters to be injected automatically
by the service container for us so we
need to be more explicit
so let's update the repository
registration
to start with we are no longer using the
item repository interface
we are using a repository
of type item
and let's see if we're missing something
so let's
add the service entities namespace
so it's another repository of item
we will notice is define an actual class
as a second parameter here
and then we have to specify this service
provider
service provider just like we did in the
other at singleton
call let's open braces here
and now before we can create the
instance of the mango repository first
we need an instance of the imongo
database
because remember we actually registered
an imongo database in the previous
singleton call so how can we get an
instance of such a registered service so
that's where you can use the get service
method of the service provider so just
like this so bar database
equals service provider
that get service
i [ __ ] database
okay so anytime that you need to get an
instance of
a service already registered in the
service container like we did with
imongo database uh you just you just
need to call get service on service
provider
and this will work as long as that
service has been registered before the
call that you're going to make here
and then having that
imogo database instance we can now
return
our new [ __ ] repository
of type item
and then we need to provide two
parameters first one the database the
one that we just got and then the
collection name that so far is being
just items
okay so that should do it let's make
sure everything is building successfully
so i'll do ctrl shift b
and indeed everything is building just
fine
so at this point we have generalized our
repository class so that it can be used
with any type of entity
however
it feels like we're writing too much
code on startup to register the mongodb
related classes because look at this we
have to do register serializers
we have to do the singleton registration
for the [ __ ] client for the [ __ ]
database and then the other singleton
for the repository
so in the next lesson we will introduce
a couple of hand extension methods that
will simplify things quite a bit for
this and for future microservices
so let's take a quick look at everything
that we have to do in order to use our
mango repository so far so here i am in
a startup class
and
the first thing that we have to do is
register the the bson serializers in
order to change the way that we store
codes and date times
then we have to get the mongodb settings
the the movie settings section for an
app settings the json in order to
construct our [ __ ] client and then we
can create our imongo database that we
registered as another singleton
and then finally when we have that we
are able to retrieve that imongo
database and then construct that [ __ ]
repository for the items collection
so let's see how can we simplify all
these lines
to make the life of future microservices
much easier
what i'm going to do is create a new
extensions class inside the repositories
directory so i'm just going to right
click here i'm going to create
extensions
that's yes
not to be confused with the other
extensions that we have over here this
is a new class
let's give it a namespace
like dialog service repositories
so let's name this class public static
class
extensions
and let's declare a function here so
it's going to be public static
i service collection
because we're going to be extending a
service collection here
and let's name it admongo
and it's going to receive we're going to
extend the i service
uh collection object
okay so it receives a service collection
and it will return a live service
collection let's see if we're missing a
space so let's add the defense injection
space there
and here let's go ahead and grab a few
lines from startup
so let's grab these lines
over here
and let's go ahead and add missing nice
bases so i'll do visual serialization
i'll do serialization serializers and
then i'm going to device vision
okay
and then we will need service settings
but we will not receive them here
we will get them
over here
as bar service settings but one thing
that you can notice is that we don't
have an instance of configuration here
just like we had in starbucks where it
was uh when it was a property that we
received as part of the constructor
so we can do is use a service provider
to explicitly request a an instance of
office services has a varying register
so configuration is registered already
by asp.net infrastructure so we should
be able to request it at this point what
i'm going to do is just say bar
configuration
is service provider dot
get service
and the type of service is going to be
just i configuration
okay which
needs the extensions configuration space
so now we can flip this configuration
into just configuration with
with a small cap c
and then we are also missing another
namespace here which is the service
settings namespace
okay so we get the configuration we
retrieve service settings mongodb
settings we construct the [ __ ] client
let's add the missing space here too
and that allows us to return the imongo
database
finally we're going to return the
services collection just to enable the
fluent use of this extension method
so that will register the imongo
database instance and now let's add
another method to register the
repository itself
so i'll open up another menu here
let's call it public static
my service collections go to return
add [ __ ] repository
it's going to be the name
and then
we'll specify a constraint of t for the
actual entity type that's going to be
used
and then
it's going to extend a service
collection
the name is going to be services
and then remember we have specify a
collection name in order to create a
repository so let's receive
collection name
as a parameter
we also need to specify a constraint for
that
for that t parameter so
t
the the the t type that's going to be
used has to be a type that implements i
entity
okay so we may need another namespace
let's first expand this
save it
let's send this to the other line
and let's
add the service entities namespace
okay so this will be useful to register
uh repository with any type of entity
but that entity has to implement i in
the indit interface so now what we can
do is go back to startup and grab these
these few lines
for the i brother registration we'll
copy that here
and then uh to make it generic we're no
longer going to be using item here but
just d
and then this also registers as
and we no longer hardcode the collection
name we're going to be using the
collection name parameter
and finally to keep it fluent we return
services once again
so with that we should be able we should
be ready to start using these extension
methods so let's go back to startup
okay so we're going to go ahead and
remove this serializer registration
let's skip several settings for now in
case we need it later but we definitely
don't need any of this stuff
so now what we can do is just say
services
add [ __ ] that registers
are a [ __ ] client and
a imog database and then since this is
fluent we can say
at mongol repository
we specify a type in our case type is
item
and then we provide the name of the
collection which is still items
so with that done let's just make sure
things are keep working properly so i'm
going to hit f5 to start a web server
and i'm going to go into postman
and i'll do again our simple get all the
items request i'll hit send
and yeah it keeps working just fine
but as you can see the coding startup is
way way simplified
in the next lesson we will see how to
move all of these common classes into a
new shared library that can be used by
all of our microservices
it's time to move the common code with
refactor from catalog microservice to a
new shared class library that can be
used by both catalog and any future
microservice
so to start with i have opened a new
visual studio called instance
i have opened my terminal and i am in
the project directory so here we're
going to create a new directory let's
call it
play that common
and i'm going to open that directory in
visual studio code
all right
now as usual i'm going to create a new
sources directory
src
and here's where i'm going to open a new
terminal
to create a class library not a web api
project but just a class library as we
need
what we can do is use dot cli
by doing dot net new
glass sleep
and then we will give the name of play
dot
command
so let's just erase the files that i can
see that we can see on the left
and then the first thing that i'd like
to do is to generate the files that
visual code needs to build our project
but before we can do that we have to
make sure that the omnisharp server is
running the omnicharge server is the the
component of the c-sharp extension for
visual code that takes care of a bunch
of productivity improvements in visual
studio code like the generation of these
files so what i'll do is just to kick
off the object server i'll just click on
class1.cs
and as you can see on the bottom here
omnisar servers is starting already
and with that i can now go to view
command plate
that then generate assets for build and
debug
so that will go ahead and generate our
vs code folder with the dash.json file
inside
and now that we have it i'll click on it
and i'll go to this section to
make
the the build action the default action
uh for building our project so i'll just
add our group folder just like we did
with the catalog microservice i'll
select build easy fall true and save
okay so with that i'll go ahead and
close this
and i'll delete this class one file we
don't need it
and now it's time to add a few nougat
packages that our shared libraries our
shared classes are going to need so
first i'm going to switch to
play that common and here i'm going to
start adding a bunch of packages so i'll
do
net add package
mongodb.driver
okay so that's for mongodb now we need a
couple of packages for the configuration
related classes so donate a package
microsoft
extensions
configuration
okay we'll do that one and
configuration.binder
lastly we have to add the extensions
that
dependency
injection and nugget package which is
going to be used for everything related
to the service container that we're
using for the penis injection in this
library
with that done let's go ahead and start
creating a folder to bring in our files
so first of all that i'm going to create
a right click and play that comma new
folder folder is going to be settings
and here's where we're going to place
the settings files that we have in
catalog so i'm going to go back to
catalog folder the catalog directory
or here
and i will open settings and i'm going
to copy these two files mongodb settings
settings settings
copy
and back in common i'm going to paste
those files here
and i'm going to close the terminal for
now
and now that we have them here let's fix
the the name space so that it matches
our current uh our current project so
this is going to be
play dot
com dot settings
so vote for [ __ ] tv settings and for
service settings
okay with those files done let's go back
to catalog and let's bring in
our i entity interface i'll copy that
i'm going to place it just at the root
of play that common
i entity
and let's also bring our a repository
interface
repository copy into play.com at the
root
okay so these two should have also the
name spaces fix it so they're just going
to be played that
common
so play that common that one and play
that comment on this one
let's also get rid of any needed
namespaces like this one here
get rid of that one
and we're good
now i'm going to add a new folder for
our mongodb related classes so i'm going
to create a new folder here
and play that command called
mongodb
and in this folder we're going to add
let's go back to catalog
we're going to add the extensions file
and the [ __ ] repository file
copy those ones
back in common
mongodb
paste
so for these ones the namespace is going
to be play that
common that mongodb
and on this one again
play that common that mongodb
i'll also remove any needed namespaces
from here
and from here
and in the case of extensions we also
need to tell it the new namespace for
the settings files so i'll go to service
settings ctrl dot
and i'll use play that command.settings
okay so now we have all of these common
classes in our new common common project
and that should be good
to start building a new package but
since we are here let's actually take
advantage of the opportunity to
expand a little bit our mongol
repository class with a couple of new
functions
that our future microservices are going
to be using for querying entities based
on a filter
so
let's go ahead and go to our i
repository interface so let's start here
and what we're going to do is add a
couple of new functions similar to
our overloads to get all async and gate
async but they are going to be able to
receive an expression
as a filter to filter which entities are
going to be returned
so let's start by get lsync i'm just
going to copy this function
i'll add a new one here and the way that
we're going to specify the filter is
going to be an expression
a link expression
so it's going to be an expression let's
add a missing space link expressions
and the signature we're going to use is
the one that mongodb is expecting from
us so it's going to be a func
of type t
so whichever type is the empty
and bull
filter
okay so again so this is the way to
specify a filter so that eventually when
we want to retrieve uh entities based on
some features let's say
give me
all the items that are owned by a
specific user in the case of inventory
and we will be able to use such a filter
here so you can pass a query expression
here
and then mongodb will be able to to
handle that filter and return the
correct items for us
the same way that we did that let's do
go ahead and do get async another
overload that is also going to receive
expression so in this case
you don't need to specify just an id to
get one item or one one entity but you
can specify a filter to retrieve any
entity that matches that filter
yeah and when we get to our new
microservice our emitter microservice
will see how both of these functions can
be used
so now that we have that in the in the
interface let's now go to [ __ ]
repository and actually implement these
new methods
so i'll go ahead and click on a
repository
ctrl dot implement interface
so that brings in our new
methods at the bottom i'm just going to
relocate them next to their other
overloads just to keep them
close to each other so put that there
i'll grab get async
and i'll put it next to
our other get async overload
there
and really this is very straightforward
so what i'll do is i'll copy the the
last line of our other uh sorry other
get all async
method
i've got here this line
and i'll copy it to our new get a
license overload and really the only
thing that we have to do is pass the
filter there
because
let's see if you go to find
you're going to see that it it can
expect it can receive a filter
definition
but then in another overload it can
actually receive an expression of the
type that we have defined so that's if
that's the overload that we're going to
be using from mongodb to be able to
filter so i'm just going to pass the
filter here
and i'm going to make this method also
async
that will be enough to retrieve all the
items based on the filter
and for the other overload they get
async
again i'll copy the code from the other
overload over here and here the filter
is already
there so it's ready to receive the
filter
but let's make it async
and that that will do it so we can
receive one one entity based on
certified filter
and like i said these methods are going
to be very handy as we move to the
future microservices
so with that done let's go ahead and
build everything make sure everything is
built in correctly so i'll do ctrl shift
p
okay so everything builds just fine and
what i'll do now is i'll switch to my
powershell terminal so that we can
create this nugget package and how do
you create a nuget package very
straightforward you just use dotnet cli
with the netback operation so we will do
and then you have specified the output
directory with dash o
and then given my current file structure
what i would like to do is to place the
package in a packages directory under
the d projects
folder
so what i'll do is
dash o
slash
i'll go up three directories and then
i'll specify
packages
slash
and that should be enough hit enter
and that's it the nuget package has been
created under the packages and we can
confirm that by going to
here
we have a packages directory now and if
i go to
packages
the package is right here so this
package contains everything
compiled out of our play.com
library
so now it's time to go back to catalog
and start using this new nougat package
so i'll switch to catalog
here we are
and before we can get a reference to
that to our play.com nugget package from
catalog there are two things that we
have to do
the first one is to specify a nougat a
package source for recurring nougat
installation
so remember that nuget packages can live
in multiple locations they could live
somewhere in your internet they could
live somewhere in the cloud in a public
location like doggy.org or in a private
feed library
private feed sorry
or or they could live in your local
machine as it is our case
but nougat doesn't know about that so
you have to tell your nugget
installation which are the possible
package sources where it can find the
nugget packages so we're going to tell
it right now that our nugget packages
are in our d a pack the project package
location so to do that i'll open our
terminal right here
what i'll do is i'll use again.cli
with the dot net nougat command but then
do get add search and here's i have to
specify the location of my packages so
in my case that's going to be the
projects
packages
and then i'll give it a name
n uh just to have like two for easier of
reference i'll name it play economy
okay
so it's been added successfully and just
make sure that you update this this
location depending on where you send
your packages in the in the previous
step
the next thing i'd like to do and i'll
collapse this a bit is to go to our
plate catalog service cs prog and what
i'm doing is i'd like to remove this
mongodb driver reference because now
everything mongodb is actually
referenced and brought in via the nougat
package so we will not need to have an
explicit reference to mongodb driver
here i'll just remove that
and now save this project
and now we can go ahead and add our
play.com reference so to do that let me
switch to
src let's go to play that catalog
service
and then we can do
dot net
add package
play that common
enter
and the reference has been added as you
can see right here
so with that it is time to start
cleaning up things
so i'll go ahead and close my terminal
and i'll close this and a bunch of
things that we can remove now are the
identity interface
you can remove
our entire repositories directory can be
removed
and our settings directory can also be
removed
okay so now it's time to fix our
our imports so let's go to item cs and
make sure it can find that identity now
leaves under play.com
from nuget package
in our controller also the irrepository
interface now is coming from play.common
and we'll remove this old namespace
and finally in startup
let's get rid of these all namespaces
exactly clean up the entire thing i
remove all new desired usings
and service settings is now going to be
coming from play.com on that settings
also our addmongo extension method is
also coming now from play.com.mongodb
and that's what it is so we are now
completely using our nuget package i'll
make sure everything is built in via
control shift p
yep it's building just fine and now
let's test if the
if the service is running properly so
i'll do f5 to run our service
and i'll go to postman
and i'll just go ahead and do a simple
query for all the items in the database
via our items operation in the res api
i'll hit send
and here we are we are retrieving items
from the database so everything is
working properly
so it works just as before but now
as you can see our uh and i'll just stop
this
our code base is much simpler so we
don't have the i i entered this
interface here we don't have the
repositories folder we don't have the
settings folder anymore
and yeah our startup looks very clean
and so this is going to help us a lot
for the construction of our future
microservices
in the next lesson we will learn about
docker compose and how it can help us
simplify the way we configure and start
our infrastructure services
in this lesson we will learn about
docker compose and how it can help us
simplify the way we run our
infrastructure services
we already started using docker to run
our mongodb database and we are doing
this via simple docker run command
however starting with the next model we
will need to start bringing in many
other infrastructure services to support
our microservices
for instance in the next model we will
use ravidmq as our meshes broker
and in future models we will choose sec
prometheus and grafana to enable a
series of observability related
components
so if we keep just using docker run to
execute our infrastructure services we
will have to perform too many steps to
setup them and we will need to remember
too many arguments for each of them
like the right environment variables
ports and volumes
also some of our containers might need
to talk to each other
like grafana and prometheus
and some of them might not be able to
work at all without another container be
up and running first
which again is the case of grafana which
won't be able to do much without
prometheus being available first
that's where docker compose come into
play
compose is a tool for defining and
running multi-container docker
applications
we will now be able to define all of our
infrastructure services in a single file
called the door compose jaml file
this will include the definition of the
container to use in each case
environment variables ports and even
dependencies between them
then we will execute a single docker
compose up command
and all the containers will start in the
right order with the correct
configurations
also
compose provides a default network that
all containers are joined to
in case they need to talk to each other
so with docker compose we are able to
document the way to configure all of our
infrastructure services in a single file
and we get to start all of them with
just one line
as opposed to multiple commands
also they all join a default network
in the next lesson we will create our
docker compose file and move our current
mongodb configuration over there
before we start using docker compose
let's first create a new directory where
we can place the compose jaml file and
any future infrastructure related files
so here i am in a new visual studio code
instance i have opened my terminal and i
am switch it into the project directory
so this directory i'm going to create a
new folder i'm going to call it
play.infra
and now i'm going to open in the visual
studio code
and the first thing that i like to do
here
is to take advantage of the
another extension for visual code which
is the docker extension
which we can find if we go to extensions
this type docker
this one here
because this one is going to provide us
some good recommendations as we start
working in our docker compose file so
i'm going to install this extension
click install
and that will show up a new icon on the
left side docker
so let's close this and let's go back to
our explorer
now we can do is just go back here and
let's create a new file
let's call it
docker compose.java
and before writing any code here what
i'd like to do is to bring in that
previous docker run command line that
we've been using
just to keep it as a reference as we
start writing this docker compose file
okay you remember this this line that i
just pasted this is what we've been
using so far to kick off our [ __ ]
or [ __ ] container
so the first thing that you want to do
in this docker compose file is to define
a version for it the version determines
what features you're going to have
available in docker compose because
different versions of the token compose
engine support different versions so you
have to define what version is this file
for
so i'll say version
it's going to be 3.8 is the last one the
latest one available as i'm recording
this lesson
and the next section is what we call
services the services will determine
each of these services is really one of
our
docker containers
so i'll define a services section
and under services you want to define
our first service which is in our case
is going to be mongodb so i'll just name
it one go
and as i start as i start writing this
uh notice the indentation that i'm
setting between each of these
elements indentation is important
because it defines which elements go
inside other elements
uh but to make this more uh
more easier to see for you what i'll do
is i'll enable another setting because
to the code so we can see the white
spaces
that are happening across across the
place so i'll go to file
preferences
settings
and i'll look for render
white space
yeah so it's this one here so i'll
switch from selection
into all
then i'll close this
and now we can see the white space right
there
yeah so as you work on this file just
make sure that you're leaving the same
amount of white spaces or indentation
with different elements that we're going
to write
i will also collapse this left side the
navigation pane since we don't need it
for now so we can have more space
so inside the [ __ ] element we're going
to open yet another element
we have to define the properties for
this for this service so first thing
we're going to define is the image
and as you remember from the command
line on the top the image is [ __ ] so
i'll grab that
then we have to give a name to this to
this container so the container is going
to start up so i'll say container name
and the name that we've been giving over
here is [ __ ] so let's use the same name
it's going to be
[ __ ]
the next thing is the ports so
for sports is actually an array of ports
so the rate you can define by placing a
dash first
and then you specify the port mapping so
i'll grab that port mapping from here
as you remember port is 27017
external port on the left side internal
port on the right side
and the next thing we have to define is
a section for our volumes because
remember that we need to map uh the
slash data slash db directory inside the
db container into a location outside of
the host where the files are actually
going to be written that's what we call
a volume so to define volumes i'm going
to go all the way
here at the same level as our services
section over there
here we're going to declare a section
called volumes
and under volumes i'm going to define
our mongodb data section which i'm
actually going to copy
over here one go to data
column and that's really all you have to
do to define a one volume uh in your in
your machine
and now we have to associate that volume
to our [ __ ] service over there so i'm
going to open yet another section here
called volumes under ports
and under volumes you have to define an
array of all the volumes that you want
for this service so the race starts with
dash and then you define that that
modeling mapping so i'm going to copy
this again
there
so that defines
that yeah so slash data slash db is
mapped into mongodb data remember that
we have to do this because otherwise
our database files will be lost if we
restart the container so from here on
any time that the mongodb container
tries to write to slash data slash db
those files are actually going to be
written into the mongodb data volume
that's outside of the of the container
and into a host machine
okay so now i'll save this file
and it's time to start running this a
container via docker compose
so i'll open my terminal ctrl j
and the first thing i'd like to do here
is make sure that i am not running
mongodb container already
so let's see
wps
docker ps
and
yeah so we are indeed running it already
we don't want to have it running there
because that could cause conflicts so
i'll just go ahead and stop it
docker stop monko
okay and now uh it has been stopped
so
with that done we can go ahead and start
our docker a container video via docker
compose and we can do
docker compose
up
hit enter
and then that starts running the
container and what you're seeing now is
just the output of the mongodb container
being generated directly into the
terminal
so now that we have the docker compose a
docker composer running our dock our
mongodb docker container uh let's see
how is our catalog api working with this
a new new way of running the container
so i'm going to go back to uh to our
catalog microservice
and i'm just going to hit f5 to get
things started
okay with the host up and running let's
go ahead and open postman and let's go
ahead and try to get our old items in
the database so here i am in my get
operation for the rest api
so i'll hit send
and interestingly i'm not getting any
items which is interesting because the
as per our previous lessons we did have
at least one item um already stored in
the database
so what's going on
let's see uh let's go back quickly to
visual studio code
catalog
and let's let's explore our database at
this point in time so i'll collapse this
a little bit
and let's go to the mongodb extension
and here's a localhost 27017
i'll connect to it
and the interesting piece here and i'll
collapse these other pieces is that we
don't have a catalog database anymore
and this is happening because as we are
started
as we moved into docker compose
a new volume has been created for our
database files so technically this is a
brand new database
which has no items yet right so there's
actually nothing in there so there has
not been any need to create the database
yet so that's why you don't see any
database here so just keep that in mind
as you switch from a raw docker
execution into torque compose a new
volume will be created
so let's actually come up with something
for our catalog database so i'll go back
to postman
and i'll go to my post tab
body
okay and so let's again define something
here
we'll go again to our potion example so
it's a potion
and
it stores a small amount
of hp
and the price is going to be just 5.
so go ahead and send
this and the item has been created
if we go back to our get items api once
again hit send
the item is there and if you go back to
visual studio code to catalog and we've
refreshed this
you can see that now we have our catalog
database with our items collection and
the one document already created in
there
and one last tip that i want to give you
as you start working with docker compose
is how to prevent let me actually open
docker compose how to prevent all this
uh output to be shown here so in case i
don't want to see all this output from
the database all the time uh you can see
things in a much cleaner way by doing
the following so i'll go back here to my
terminal i'll just hit ctrl c to stop
docker compose
and what you can do is
you can do docker compose app but you
can append the dash d
a parameter to run in detach mode so if
i do enter now
the only that you're going to see is
that it's starting [ __ ] and then it
says done so the container is running in
the background but you don't have to be
looking at all the output all the time
so you're running in a detached mode
and still if you go back to
postman and you query you can see that
the container is actually running
so we have reached the end of this model
with a few improvements to our developer
workflow
and with a reusable library that will
speed up the construction of our future
microservices
in the next module we will introduce our
second microservice and we will learn
about the multiple challenges of having
microservices talk to each other
in this model you will learn about the
different microservice communication
styles and then you will learn about a
few techniques to properly implement
synchronous inter-service communication
between the existing catalog service and
a new inventory service
by the end of this model you will have a
solid understanding of the following
the different microservice communication
styles
how to implement synchronous
communication between two services via
rest and the http protocol
what kind of partial failures could
impact your mega services and why you
should design for them
how to set timeouts to fail fast when
doing inter-service communication
what is and how to implement the retries
with exponential back-off technique
and when to use and how to implement the
circuit breaker pattern
in this lesson we will create our
inventory microservice which owns the
player's inventory of purchase items
just like we did with the catalog
service we will define a rest api for
inventory with a couple of operations
which are
both items which will be used to add an
item to the player's inventory back
and
get items by user id which should
retrieve all the items for the specified
player or user
talking about users you may have noticed
that we have not properly introduced the
concept of players or in general users
into our system
this is fine the management of the
actual users database will be the
responsibility of the identity service
which will be we will create in a future
model along with all the microservices
security
infrastructure for now we will choose
random guides to identify the users that
own the inventory items
let's get started
let's create our inventory microservice
i have started by opening
a new piece of studio called instance
i have opened my terminal and i have
switched to the project directory so
i'll create a brand new directory for
this new microservice
so let's call it play that
inventory
and then let's switch to that directory
in the terminal
and then what i'll do is i'll use this
command line to ask the current instance
of visual studio code to open this new
folder so i'll just do code
that for the current directory and then
i'll do dash r to reuse the green window
so i'll hit enter
that will be the equivalent to or we use
the file open folder and menu but it's
much faster
now i'll create as usual our source
directory
and in that one i'll right click i'll
say open integrated terminal to open a
new terminal in that location
and then i'll go ahead and use dot net
cli to create the new project
so.net new web api dash n play dot
inventory dot service is going to be the
name
okay so that generates a bunch of files
on the left side and i'll i'll get the
omnishar server started by clicking on
any of rc chart files so i'll click
there that kicks in on the chart server
and that prompts us to
add the the
test.json and logistics.json files so
that this will code can build and debug
our project so i'll say yes
that adds our files on the left side
over here
and then i'll go right away to our
task.json file
to add our
group section where we can say that this
is the
section that by default builds the
project
save that
okay so now also close our terminal for
now and then i'll go to launch.json and
i will remove this section just like we
did with catalog so that anytime we
start the server it doesn't open up web
browser by default i'll just remove that
and what i'll do next is i'll go to
uh under properties i'll go to launch
settings.json because we want to specify
which is going to be the ports that
we're going to use for inventory so
remember we are already using the
default ports for catalog 5001 500 and
5000 so we have to use new ports for
inventory they cannot be the same port
so i'll use i'll go for 5005
and 5004
for our
https and http ports for inventory you
could use any other port really here as
long as they are not being used by any
other application in your your computer
next i'll go ahead and i'll delete what
we don't need from these projects i'll
delete weather forecast controller
and i'll delete the weather forecast
class over here
so now i'll get started by creating our
details so the dtos that are going to be
used by our controller class and their
arrest api
so just like we did before i already
click in play inventory service i'll say
new file i'll create dtos.cs
here i'll declare our namespace
the namespace is going to be
play.inventory.service.dps
and so we're going to define two dtos at
this point
the first one is going to be the dto
used
to
grant items to a user and the other one
is going to be the dto used to return
the series of items that a user already
has in their inventory
so let's start by defining public record
grant items video
and to grant the knight into a user we
obviously obviously need to specify the
id of the user so it's going to be a
good user id
let's add the system in space there
we also have to specify which is the
item the catalog item that's going to be
assigned so we will define that as
catalog item id
and lastly we have to specify how much
of the item is going to be assigned to
the user so that's going to be
the quantity
let's notify the other the other dto as
public record this is going to be
inventory
item dto like i said this is the dto
used to return items
the items that are assigned to a user
and the user's inventory so for this
we're going to be returning the
catalog item id
the quantity
and also let's define the
the acquired date
so this is the date when the item was a
was put into the user's inventory
so now that we have our details it is
time to start defining the entities that
we're going to be using to store
inventory items into the database
however before we can do that uh we have
to bring in the
our play.com nugget package so that we
can start using the the bunch of classes
and types that we have defined there
including our i items
our intt interface
so to do that i'll go ahead and do ctrl
j to open my terminal
and i'll go to
late that
inventory service
and then i'll just do
net
add
package
play that common
okay
so if you go now to play men3 service
we'll see that we have the nuget package
added here
now we can go ahead and right click in
play inventory service new folder
entities
and let's go ahead and define a new file
it's going to be
inventory item dot cs
let's define our namespace
it's going to be
play.inventory service
entities
let's define the class
public class
inventory item
and let's make this class right away
implement our i
i entity interface
let's make it use play.com into a
namespace
and
as we're implementing that interface
let's do ctrl dot implement interface so
we have to define a good
so probably good id
we'll make it define just a get
we will use a get and set
just like that
okay so each metal item will have an id
then it should have it should know to
which user it belongs to
so let's do
probe good
it's going to be user id
next let's define
which catalog item this inventory item
corresponds to a reference to the
catalog item
so it's going to be prop
good
catalog item id
next we'll define the
quantity it's going to be the quantity
how much of this item we have
let me also close this terminal now
and lastly
let's define
the time of set
is going to be the acquired date
the day when the item was assigned to
the user in the inventory
save that
and just like we did with catalog let's
define an extension method so that we
can transform
one of these inventory items into the
inventory item dto
so i go ahead to the root play inventory
service i'll add a new file i'll call it
extensions
let's add an a space
play that inventory that service
and let's add
public static
class extensions
and let's define our method here so
public
static is going to return an inventory
item video
let's call it sdto and let's import a
missing namespace
and it is going to be extending
inventory item
into the item
let's import that it's going to be the
item
and here it is just about creating a
brand new item dto out of this item so
we will say return new
inventory item dto with item
dot catalog item id
item dot
quantity
and item that
acquire date
so that's all we have to do to transform
the item entity into an identity
now we can go ahead and create our
controller so let's go to the
controllers folder right click new file
we'll name it items controller
just like we did in catalog
let's define the namespace for it
play inventory service
controllers
it's going to be
public class
items controller
and remember each of our itunes
controllers should be
a mark with the api
controller attribute
it should derive from
controller base
and it should define the base route that
is going to be a map2 so route
this route just like with catalog is
also going to be items
just because it also manages items
so route items
so now we're going to need a one class
level variable here which is going to be
the repository that we're going to be
using to store and retrieve items so
let's define private
read-only
it's going to be a repository
of type
inventory item
and let's just name it items repository
so let's import play common here
and let's import play inventory service
entities
let's also collapse this navigation pane
for now since we are not going to be
using it for a bit
and now we have to do dependence
injection to actually receive this items
repository into the controller so let's
define a constructor
okay so this constructor is going to
receive again our i
our repository so just copy that here
item repository
and let's assign it to our local
instance
hide the repository
so now it's time to define our two
operations
here we need an operation to get all the
items in the inventory and one operation
to put an item or to create an item into
the inventory so let's start with the
get operation
let's define that as public async
task
of action result
and this is going to be of an
innumerable
of inventory
iron detail
and then we'll name it just get async
get async and the parameter is going to
be the user id so we want to get all the
items in a user's inventory so we're
going to receive
good user id
okay let's see let's add any missing
spaces 3d tasks
systems collection generic
and service ctos
and for the guide using system
let's also define the verb that is
associated to this api which is going to
be http get
and so the way that this api is going to
where this operation is going to work is
we just need to go ahead and get
all the items based on the user so but
before we can do that let's do a quick
check let's make sure that this user id
is not empty so if it is a good empty we
are going to return
a
bad request
request
a simple validation in there
and so to get the items we're going to
do this so we'll say so the items
is going to be and we're going to open
up braces here
we're going to do a sink call to items
repository
get all the
sync and here's where we can start using
our
expression our filter based on an
expression
so in this case what we want to say is
that we want to get
any item
where item.user id equals the user id
that we got as a parameter over here
okay so that's that's how we can filter
items based on a user in this case
and then when we have that we can do a
select
and let's see if we're missing another
namespace system link
where we're going to specify that we
want to take each of these items that we
found in the database and transform them
as
into a dto with our extension method
and finally we'll go ahead and just say
return
return the items
let's also transform this let's just
wrap this into the ok
into the k action result
and that's all we have to do so that
will return all the items in the user's
inventory
the next method is the one that we're
going to use to assign one item to the
inventory
this is going to be a post operation
so let's see let's define it as
publication task
we will just do action
result we're not returning really
anything out of this method
i'm going to impose async
and it's going to be receiving
our grand ideas dto
at istio
let's mark this with the
http post verb
here we're going to do is we will try to
find
the
if we have that inventory item already
assigned in inventory because it could
already have it so in which case we just
need to increase the quantity or in the
other case when we don't have it
we just have to
create it for the first time in
inventory
so let's try to find it so we'll do
so it's going to be inventory item
equals
await
items repository
get a sync
and again here's where we can use the
expression filter
where we're going to say that the item
that we're going to
try to find has to be one where the item
that user id
has to match the grand item cto user id
and also
the item that catalog item id has to
match
grant identity to your catalog item id
let me see if i can put this in the next
line
so that will find the item if it is
there so
but if the inventory item
happens to be new it is this is the
first time that we assign this item to
the user
so in that case we will go ahead and say
inventory item equals new
inventory item
and we will set its catalog item id
is grant items dto.cattleguardian id
the user id is
grab itemcto.userid
the quantity
is that quantity
and for acquired date we will just set
our current date time offset so it's
going to be
daytimeoffset.utc.now
and finally we will call
our method in items repository to create
an item so create a sync
inventory item
okay let's add this missing
using semicolon there
and then let's go for the other branch
so else we did find the item so we just
need to increase the quantity so for
that we will do
inventory item.quantity
plus equals
itemcto.quantity
and then we will do weight
itemrepository.updatesync
with the inventory item
and finally we will just return
we'll just return okay
and that's pretty much for the a
controller operation so we have two
two operations to retrieve the items in
inventory and to put an item into the
inventory
so with that done it is time to start
doing the basic uh configuration of a
startup
so i'll go back to our
explorer here
and first let's go to websites.json here
we have to define
uh the settings for our
in order to define the service name and
the mongodb a mongodb connection
so to save time what i'll do is i'll go
back to catalog actually and i'll open
my app sizing json file over there and
i'll just copy these two sections
from the app statistic json
i'll go back to inventory and i'll paste
that right here
really the main thing the only thing
that we have to change here is that this
is not the catalog service anymore this
is the
inventory service remember that this is
what's going to define the name of the
database that's going to be created in
in mongodb
save that
and now i'm going to want to go to
startup
i'll actually clean up a bit disney
spaces so i'll do control dot here
remove necessary usings
and now i'll go to the start of
configure services
and i'll add the services for mongodb
and the repository so i'll do services
that
add [ __ ]
and that may need another import pay
common mongodb
and then i'll add
a [ __ ] repository
of type
inventory item
let's add a using there
and here we have to specify the name of
the collection here so the name that
we're going to give it is
inventory
inventory items
save that
and so with that we have registered
everything related to mongodb
and
we actually are ready to
start trying out this microservice so
i'll go ahead and hit f5
okay
and then what i like to do is actually
import the
the specification cover api into postman
to make our lives a bit easier what i'll
do is i'll copy
a copied
url of our service localhost 5005
and then i'll go to our browser just for
this time paste that there and then
let's go to slugger
so this defines as you can see this is
the soccer ui page for our
rest api then i'll click in the
swagger.json link here and i'll copy
that
copy that and then i'll just close this
browser
now i'll go to postman
and here what i'll do is i'll just click
on import
link
i'll paste that
click continue
and i'll just say import
so now if we go to collections we have
now not just a catalog service section
but also a collection but also a plain
inventory service collection with our
two items related operations
so what i'd like to do is to go ahead
and post and try out our post to assign
an item to a user
but of course before that we have to
define the base url for our for this
collection
so let's go to dot
let's go to edit
variables
and in this case our base url is as
remember let's go to
inventory base url is
localhost 5005.
put that here
i'll put it for current value and for
initial value
update that
okay so it knows
the base url
now being imposed we go to body and
here's the three things that we need
user id catalog item and quantity
now for user id um like i said in the
introduction we don't uh we don't have
actual users so far so we just generate
a random one and one handy way that we
can do that in postman is by using the
coolid function that's built into
postman so what you can do is just this
so open two sets of curly braces and
then you're going to do just good so
that will on the fly generator quit for
us
and for the catalog item id we want to
know the id of one of our items in the
catalog so to do that let's actually
query our catalog items but before doing
that let's go back to catalog and just
hit f5 to actually start the web server
so that we can query the catalog
and then i'll go back to postman
into our play catalog service collection
i'll expand this i'll go to get items
and i'll just hit send
and here is the one item that we have
the catalog the potion so i'll copy this
id
and i'll go back to our post operation
paste it there
and let's say that we want to assign
just one
one of these potion into the user's
inventory
so now go ahead and hit send
and we got 200 okay meaning it was a
success
and so to verify that this actually
worked let's actually try out our get
all items in inventory
operation so i'll click on this new
operation
and in this case the first thing that
we're going to need is uh to specify the
which is the user id right so which user
was that item assigned to
which we if you go back to post it was
an automatic automatically generated
users we actually don't know yet but we
can figure that out via our console so
i'll click on the console down here
and you open the post operation
and we expand the body the request body
you see the user id is right here so
this
the console records everything that's
going on behind the scenes so it's
pretty handy in this case so i'll just
copy the user id and i'll close this
then i'll go back to our get items from
the inventory service and i'll paste
that right here
so with that i'll go ahead and hit send
and here it is
so this user has a one of the catalog
item of this id and with this acquired
date where the date was assigned
and so let's say that we wanted to
increase the quantity of that item for
this user and we want to actually test
this this other codepath so let's go
back to post
body and let's say that we want to add
uh perhaps four more uh potions to these
users inventory so i'll just do that
uh we want to change now we don't want
to generate get another good so replace
user id
with the id that we we just copied
for our user so then i'll go ahead and
hit send
200 okay and then if we get items for
this user in inventory i'll hit send
and now the quantity is five
so now the user has five items in his
inventory
okay
so at this point our inventory service
can store and report the items that each
user has in his inventory back
however notice that this dto that we
have returned
by the get operation only provides the
ids of the items in the user inventory
so since we don't have any names of
descriptions it is a bit hard to tell
which items are in the user inventory
which are the actually so what does 4e
9c
means really
so
in the next lesson we will learn about
microservice communication styles and
how our inventory service can use them
to retrieve more details about each of
these items from the catalog service
in this lesson we will learn about the
different microservice communication
styles and how to implement the
synchronous communication style vrs and
the http protocol
there are basically two ways you can
communicate with microservices
the synchronous style where the client
sends a request and waits for a response
from the service
and the asynchronous style where the
client sends a request to the service
but the response if there's any response
will not be sent immediately
so far we have been using the
synchronous communication style when
interacting with our services via
swagger ui and postman
and in this lesson we will explore how
to use it for inter-service
communication
we will learn about the asynchronous
communication style in a future lesson
when using the synchronous communication
style the client sends a request and
waits for a response from the service
which means that the client cannot
proceed without a response
you may make this more evident with any
of our services if you put a breakpoint
in one of our service controller actions
like get async in the catalog items
controller start a debug session in bs
code and then try sending a get request
to it be a postman
you will notice that postman waits
indefinitely for our service to respond
it can continue until the service
responds
many times this type of communication
uses a blocking threat meaning that the
client is unable to receive any other
inputs or perform any other task until
the response arrives but it could also
use an unblocking thread where the
client just offers a callback method to
the service so the service can call the
client back when the response is
available
in this case the client thread does not
block even when it still waits for
response
there are two approaches currently to
use the synchronous configuration style
rest with the http protocol
which is a traditional approach and the
one that we have been using so far
in res the business objects are modeled
as resources
and http verbs are used to manipulate
them
also you usually use xml or json to
represent the resources
most clients support rest
the other approach is grpc
which is a binary message-based protocol
in which clients and servers exchange
messages in the protocol buffers format
grpc is becoming increasingly popular
because it supports http 2
and is more efficient addressed
however not all clients support http 2
which is why in a microservices
architecture grpc is used mostly
internally between the api gateway and
the services or between the services
in the next lesson we will be
implementing synchronous communication
between catalog and inventory
microservices using rest and http
at this point when the client requests
the items inventory back for a user
the inventory service creates its
database and retrieves an array that has
basic info about each item including the
catalog item id and the quantity
however having a list of item ids does
not tell much to our client in terms of
what actual items the user has on
inventory
ideally we would like to get at least
the name of each item and hopefully also
a subscription
however inventory doesn't know such
details about the items since the
information is owned by the catalog
service
one way to address this is to have the
inventory service send a get request to
the catalog service to retrieve the
details of all the items
inventory can then combine this
additional info with the details it has
in its own database to send back the
decided more detailed payload to the
client
let's go ahead and implement this
approach
our inventory microservice needs to
receive data from the catalog
microservice
but before we can do that it first needs
to define the dto that represents the
retrieved catalog items
now it turns to be that we already have
such a dto that represents catalog items
and if we go to our catalog
project our catalog microservice and if
we go to dtos.cs we're going to see that
such d2 is right here so this is the dto
item dto
that represents
cattle guidance when you query for them
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
dto
copy this and then i'll go to inventory
here we are in inventory and i'll open
dto.cs and i'm just going to paste that
as initial
dto for uh for the inventory
and the case of inventory we're going to
rename this into
catalog item detail
just do not confuse it with inventory
attended to you
and uh for example inventory again uh we
don't need that many properties when
we're querying for catalog items and you
don't have to retrieve everything or at
least digitalize everything into
inventory the only thing that we're
going to need in this case is the id of
the item the name and the description
we don't need price and created date
for our purposes so remove those save
this
and now that we have this dto we can
actually build a client that is going to
be able to query for this item from
catalog so i'm going to right click in
play inventory service i'll create a new
folder
let's call it clients
and in this one i'm going to create a
new file that i'm going to name
catalog client that's cs
let's give it a namespace
display inventory service
clients
public class
catalog client
so in order for our catalog client to be
able to talk to any external
http endpoint it needs to use the
net http client class so we're going to
define that as a class level variable
here
private read-only http client
http client
and i'll import the
system.http in space
and now we're going to do dependency
injection of this client into our class
so public catalog client
http client
and we'll take that reference
now that we have that client available
we're going to define the function
that's going to retrieve actually
retrieve the items from catalog so this
is going to be an async function so
let's define it as asynctask
and what we're going to return is a
collection of catalog item dto
since the the consumer is not expected
to modify this collection in any way
we're just going to return a read-only
collection
of type catalog item dto
and we'll name it get
catalog
items async
let's import missing spaces
for
tasks and forbid on the collection
and for catalog item video
to retrieve the items
we can do that really easily with one
line so we'll do
items
equals weight
http client
get from json let's change this
get from json async
we need to import another space system
http json
and we'll um
will deserialize as i
read only collection of type catalog
item video
and then here is where you put the route
that you want to access in the invoked
address api in our case in the cases of
catalog the
route would be under items
and with that we can go ahead and return
return the items
that's all you have to do to invoke
another a recipe i in another service
with that done it is time to update our
inventory identity to have this
additional information that we're going
to collect from catalog so let's go back
to dtos
and inventory item dto we're going to
add
a name
and a description
but as we do that and as we can see
extension is complaining and it's
because we need to provide that
additional additional uh members to the
construction of inventory in dtu as we
transform the inventory item entities
so what we'll do is we're going to
receive additional parameters into this
method which are going to be
the name
and the description
[Music]
and we'll fit those two into inventory
item dto constructor
there
with that done we are ready to go to our
controller to actually take advantage of
this new
this new information so i'll go to items
controller
and the first thing that i'll do is i'll
get a reference while defining a
classless variable for our catalog
client so i'll define
private read-only
catalog client
capital client
okay let's import the missing space
and let's receive that
as a penis injection into items
controller
i receive the catalog client
and we'll get the reference
and now that we have that let's change a
little bit how we do the our get async
method
so we'll get rid of these lines for
now and the first thing that we're going
to do is to actually
retrieve the catalog items so how do we
get the catalog items
very easily now we can do
catalog items
equals
weight
cattle client that get catalytic items
async
that's all it is
okay so that gives us all the catalog
items in the catalogs microservice now
we want to get the list of all the
inventory items that we have currently
in the inventory microservice
so we'll do that via
inventory item entities
it's going to be
await item repository get all these sync
where the item item that user id
equals the user id that we got as a
parameter
okay so now we have all the catalog
items and then we have all the entities
the inventory item entities for the
current user now we need to combine
these two pieces of information to
produce the dto that we want to return
so to do that we'll do this so
inventory item dtos
equals
inventory item entities
select so we're going to do a projection
here
for each inventory item
[Music]
we will do this
let me close that
first we will look into the collection
of catalog items and we will find the
catalog item that corresponds to the
current inventory item
so
catalog item equals catalog items
that's single there should be one and
only one catalog item where
the catalog
item
catalog item
that id
should match exactly the inventory item
that
catalog item id
and once we have that we can
do the
conversion of the inventory item into a
dto so we will do
enter the item
return inventory item as dto
and then we have to provide the catalog
item
that name and the catalog item
that description
and finally now that we have the
inventory identities we will return
those as opposed to these old items
collection so inventory item details
so our catalasing method is ready to
retrieve
an improved set of items with name and
description
and now it is time to do the proper
registration in a startup
to let our
application know about this new
catalog client that we're going to be
using
let's go to startup
and what i'll do is i'll open a little
section just under our [ __ ]
registration
so i'll do
services
dot
add
http client
and alt line is going to be catalog
client
let's import missing a space
and then i'll receive a specifier
parameter here is going to be the client
okay let's open that expression there
and here really the only thing that we
have to specify for now is the the base
address of this automaker because
otherwise how how would it know
so we're going to say that the client
base address
equals
a uri
let's import a missing space
and then if you remember the uri where
our catalog microservice leaks so far is
a localhost 5001 so that's what you have
specified here https
localhost
5001.
okay
so this is a handy way to register our
catalog client so that it can be used
by dependency injection in other classes
like in the controller right so you say
http client catalog client and then you
specify the base address and then when
that client is instantiated it will
automatically receive an instance of the
http client that you're going to be
using to query four items
okay so with that done let's go ahead
and hit f5 let's see this in action
let's not forget to also do an f5 in our
catalogue service so i'll go ahead and
start also here's catalog i'll start it
f5
and with the two service up and running
we can go ahead and go to postman
here in postman i am already
in the in the tab for the operation that
can retrieve all the inventory items for
specified user id so this is user data
we've used in the previous lesson uh so
let's see what information we can get
now that we created the api so we'll go
ahead and hit send
and as you can see we are able to
retrieve the catalog item but this time
we not just have the id of the item we
also have the name
and the description of the catalog
okay so this seems to be working pretty
well
however
think about what will happen
if the catalog service started having
issues at least temporarily but what
happens if it's completely down
in the next lesson we will learn about
the problems that we might find when
having a service communicate with
another service
in this lesson we will learn about
partial failures in microservices and
how to deal with them using timeouts and
the exponential back-off technique
even after placing our best efforts to
ensure we have a healthy system it is a
matter of fact that in distributed
systems partial failures will happen
this could be due to multiple reasons
including network outages
hardware failures
dependency failures and even routine
things like having a deployment in
progress
regardless of the cause of the partial
failure
when calling a dependent service it
could certainly cause our microservice
to fail
which will end up in a bad experience
for our clients
so whenever a service makes a
synchronous request to another service
there is an ever present risk of partial
failures and so you must assign your
service to be resilient to them
one of the first things to consider when
making requests to dependent service is
setting appropriate timeouts
a service client should be designed not
to block infinitely and use timeouts
think about the experience of our client
when the catalog service takes a long
time to come back to our inventory
service
if it ever comes back
now the inventory service is also taking
forever to respond to the client leaving
our users with a bad experience
and not only that at least one of the
threads of inventory is now busy not
being able to serve any other requests
which reduces the amount of available
resources in the service
instead of this you can set a timeout of
say no more than one second so that if
catalog service takes more than that to
respond
the request immediately fails
and the inventory service can in turn
return the appropriate request to the
client even if it's a failure
this enables a more responsive
experience and also ensures that
resources are never tied up indefinitely
like we mentioned it is not uncommon for
transit failures to occur in a
distributed environment
therefore you usually want to give the
dependent service one more chance to
come back with a successful reply
however you don't want to keep
retraining at a constant rate since that
could overwhelm the dependency
a good strategy that you can use for
retries is the one called retries with
exponential back off
this strategy performs call retries a
certain amount of times with a longer
wait between each retry
and here's how it works
as usual the client will make a request
to our service and this one in turn will
make a request to its dependent service
if this second request fails instead of
failing right away our service will wait
some time
and then it will try again
if the request fails again we will now
wait a longer amount of time before
trying the request
if it keeps failing we will wait a yet
longer amount of time before one more
try
and eventually if we have tried enough
times
with no successful response we will let
the call fail
as you see this strategy lets the
failing dependency have an increasing
amount of time to
recover it also avoids overwhelming the
dependency
let's see how to implement timeouts and
retries with exponential back off in our
inventory microservice
let's see our inventory and catalog
microservices in action once again
so here i am in catalog
and i'll just hit f5 to start a web
server
and then i'll go to inventory and i'll
do the same thing hit f5
and now i'll go to postman and i'll try
to get
all the inventory items for this user id
so i'll just go ahead and hit send
and here's what we expected to get right
so the list of inventory items with them
and description
now to simulate the effects of partial
failures let's first add a few temporal
modifications to our get out items
operations in catalog microservice
so i'll go to our catalog visual studio
code instance and i'll stop it for now
close terminal
and i'll go to items controller
and what i'll do is i'll modify or get
async method the one that retrieves all
the items so that it introduces a few
temporal failures uh for our inventory
client
so before doing that i'm going to add a
little uh
a little variable to track how many
requests we have received from the from
the client at this point
so i'll just add
private static in i'm making it static
so that it doesn't reset after every
request
let's just call it request counter
start with zero
and now in get a scene i'm going to open
space here let's go down
and i'll do the following first thing
that i'll do is i'll just
increase the counter
and then let's add a lock line just
after this
console.the right line
[Music]
i will just say
string interpolation
request
request
discounter
starting
so that's that's why it tells us that
it's starting a new request
then what we're going to do is for the
first two requests we will actually
increase i mean we'll add a delay to
simulate the timeout scenarios
so if request counter
less than or equals to two
we're going to say i'm going to copy
this line here console.writeline
we will say
delaying
and i'm going to say wait
that's that delay this is how you can
introduce a delay in the current request
in an asynchronous way
time span
that frame seconds will say 10 seconds
so the first request will be delayed 10
seconds
then i'll copy this block
here
down here and we will say that if the
request counter is less than or equals
to four what we're going to do is just
return
an internal server error right so three
to to simulate that kind of error
so request request counter we will say
500
internal server error
and we will return
status code
500
now at this point we are introducing
this capability of uh returning either
one result here or another type of
result here and in order to do that
uh remember that we have to switch from
just returning the innumerable into
returning an actual i actually result so
i'll say
action
result
of a numerable of identity and i'll
close this
so that gives us ability to return more
than one type of a result
and also we'll have to modify our final
return clause here so that it returns
something that can be mapped to
afghanistan like the okay
result
and lastly what we're going to add here
just over here
let me copy this console right line this
is going to be the happy path where we
finally return something and we're going
to say resquez request counter we will
just say 200
okay
okay so for a quick review we have a
static request counter so every time a
request comes in it increases the
counter uh the first two requests are
going to have a 10 second delay the next
two requests are going to end up in a
500 error and then if we get get past
that we'll get at 200 okay
and so at this point i'll go back to
our
inventory
this is our inventory i've used to call
instance i'll just stop it
close
and what i'll do is i'll first go ahead
and collapse our navigation pane for now
i'll open my terminal
over here
i'll open a new partial terminal what
i'd like to do is actually have two
terminals in this window so we can see
the interactions between microservices
so i'll use the split terminal icon here
to open a second terminal and in this
one i'll actually switch back to play
that the catalog directory
okay
play the catalog service
and here i'll do dot net run
so that we can see the outputs that are
coming out of catalog
and then on the left side i'll start up
our inventory microservice same way i'll
do
that run
okay
so with that done let me go back to
postman
and i'll try the query once again so
i'll hit send
and back in bs code
you can see that now this first request
is getting delayed
and now our inventory client is
experienced experiencing this
significant timeout
if we try it again for the point of
views postman so look at this it just
keeps waiting waiting and waiting we're
giving a really bad experience to to our
clients right
okay so what can we do about this so the
first thing as we mentioned is to
introduce a proper timeout to avoid this
kind of situation
so let's go back to visual code
and what i'll do now is i'll stop both
web servers so i'll go to my inventory
turbine and i'll do ctrl c
stop server catalog control c stop
server
and
what i'd like to do now is to add
our
a reference to the poly nougat package
so so this is the package that you can
use in your.net applications to properly
handle transient error failures in a
very easy way
so being in play inventory service i'll
do
net add package
microsoft.next
enter
okay and then perhaps i'll put this back
into place and then i'll just do ctrl j
to hide all terminals for a moment
then i'll go to our explorer and i'll go
to startup.cs and i'll collapse this
once again we don't need it
and let's go into configure services
and um yeah so let's find the section
where we are adding the http client
right here
and here what we're going to do is we're
going to append yet another call to
another method here that's going to be
that's called add policyhandler
and uh here's where we can define a
policy so paulie has this concept of
policies that different policies that
can be used to handle a different
transient errors
when you're invoking an external api so
we're going to use policy
and then let's import any missing space
using poly
so we will say policy dot
timeout async
and then we specify a type here and that
type is going to be http
response message
and let's add the system.net namespace
because this is the type of response i
will get when you invoke the external
external client so
and uh in this parameter we'll specify
uh how many seconds we want to wait
maximum
after calling an external api and before
just failing
so i'll say one second in our case and
i'll close this
so just by doing this you're saying that
anytime we invoke anything under
localhost 5001 we're going to wait at
much one second before giving up
so let's see now how this works i'll
bring in back my terminals via ctrl j
and then i'll do
dot net run in both cases
okay perhaps i'll move this a little bit
to the right
and then let's go to postman
and try the request once again
as you can see it now took just a little
bit more than one second to complete the
request so instead of waiting for all
those 10 seconds wasting resources let's
try again
yep and once again it just took just a
bit more than one second
if we go back to postman
we can also see we tried the two
requests on the right side but then they
usually took more time to respond but
regardless we were already we had
already failed on the on the left side
on the inventory side
so that would at least help us fail fast
to avoid the long delay and avoid
consuming inventory resources
unnecessarily
however we note that transient errors
are not uncommon in distributed systems
so we would like to not just fail right
away but instead try a few times hoping
for the catalog service recovery
in the next lesson we will implement the
retries with exponential back-off
technique
to improve our chances of succeeding in
the presence of transient errors
in the last lesson we introduced a
one-second time-out policy to inventory
microservice
let's now use the retries with
exponential back-off technique to let
inventory retry the calls to catalogue a
few times before giving up
so here i am once again in the play the
inventory microservice and here's a line
where we last in last lesson we added
our timeout policy
what we want to do here is add yet
another policy to specify what to do in
the presence of transient errors and how
to retry
so now i'm going to be adding that
policy handler right here just between
the add http client call and the add
policy handler call
and just pay attention of the location
of this because we want to make sure
that we can combine the timeouts with
the transient error hunting so that any
time that we retry we actually
wait just one second like specified in
this policy
we wait one second uh between tries if
you don't do things in the order that
are going to be shown here
that combination is not going to work
properly
so at this location i'm going to say
add transient http error policy
and let's actually go into the
definition of this method for one second
so go to definition uh so so just so
that you can see what this this method
is handling so this method is taking
care of network failures
it's also taking care of 500 500 errors
several errors and a 408 status quo so
request time out
so this method we're going to use is
very handy so because it can handle all
these situations by itself automatically
i close this
and again notice the location where i
added this
so now what i'll do is i'll say builder
and then we'll say builder dot
weight and retry async
and here we're going to open parentheses
and we need to specify a series of
parameters for this policy and the first
parameter is going to be the retry count
so this is how many times we want to
retry in the presence of transient error
failures so for our case let's say we're
going to go for five retries
the next parameter is the sleep duration
provider so this is just a function that
determines how much time to wait between
each retry so for this we're going to
say
we try attempt
and then we'll use a time span class
to specify a duration in seconds
but here is where the exponential
back-off part comes into place we are
not going to just specify a one specific
amount of seconds we are going to say
but that pow so that we can say uh let's
go for two and then we'll raise that
into retry attempt
so this means that every time we're
going to wait we're going to be waiting
an increasing amount of time that
depends on the retry attempt
so for like the first time it's going to
take two raised t raise it into one the
first which i attempt so two at one is
going to be two so two seconds so next
time it's going to be two a raise a two
so it's going to be four seconds the
next time eight seconds it will keep
going that way in an exponential way so
that every time we just wait a little
bit more so that's that's a potential
back-off
piece of of this technique
and then next we're going to specify yet
another parameter uh that you don't
really need it but we're going to use it
just for the purposes of demonstrating
what happens between the different uh
the different calls so you can totally
skip this if you want to if you want to
don't want to see what's going on behind
the scenes so i'm going to say on retry
and then we specify three parameters
it's going to be outcome
a
time span
and we try
attempt
so i'll open this
and then here we can specify
um what we want to do
each time that retry happens what we
want to do is just present the lock a
lock message in the console and we can
do when you we can use i logger for this
now uh uh to do that at this point we
need to actually get an instance of the
ilogger a lower class but uh we don't
have a easy way to do that right now so
what we're going to do is to as an
instance of the service provider we're
going to create a service provider and
from that one we're going to get that
service this is not ideal and that's
actually going to present a warning
message in the console
but we're doing this just for
demonstration purposes so totally avoid
this this technique in production code
so let's see we'll say service provider
equals services
dot build service provider
and then we will say
service provider that gets service we
want an i logger
of catalog client
okay let's see if we're missing a
namespace
extension's logging
okay so if you're able to get that that
that service instance so we'll use this
equal
question mark there we'll say
that log warning
and here's where we're going to specify
that
message and the message is going to be
and we'll do a string interpolation here
we'll say
lane for
so many seconds
and those seconds are going to come from
time span
the total seconds
and then
then making retry
and that's going to be retry
attempt
okay
close that
save
and one more thing that we have to do
here is make sure that we combine both
of these policies so that they can work
together and to do that what we have to
do is go back to this builder
declaration here so where and then we
have to say builder dot or
and then we specify the exception that
will be coming out of the timeout
of the timeout async call over here so
in that case that exception is going to
be
timeout
rejected
exception and then let's see if you're
missing any space using polytimeout
okay so that's how you can say that if
the actual and then let's
add missing parenthesis
if
we fail because of a timeout produced by
the timeout policy then it will fire a
timeout section let's go ahead and also
retry okay so that's the right way to
combine both policies
okay so now let's just save this
and i'll open my terminals
and left side is inventory i'll do dot
net run
right side is catalog dot net run
let's expand this a bit
and notice the warning that i was
mentioning before and this happens like
i said because of the way that we are
doing a the service provider
construction here there's a radio
service provided
built in into the spinal cord of time we
are creating a second one that's not
ideal and but like i said it's used for
demonstration purposes feel free to
remove this section in your production
code
so now that we have both services up and
running let's go back to postman
and let's go ahead and do a send to see
what happens so it starts and go back
going back here
you can see
that uh first time we tried and then we
waited two seconds then we waited four
seconds then we waited eight seconds
we're trying to wait eight seconds on
the right side you can see that the
multiple requests are coming in now
they're firing internal server drivers
and now we are in what's probably the
last the last weight uh for 16 seconds
and so the client in postman as you can
see it just keeps waiting
uh it's not it doesn't fail right away
but we are trying to get a chance to
actually succeed and yeah eventually
that happened
the client succeeded and we no longer
see an error if we see back into postman
we can see that yeah indeed eventually
we go to 200 okay 200 okay for the last
request
and it is looking great
now the one issue with this is that if
you have multiple instances of your in
this case our inventory service uh
calling a catalog
and they are all waiting exactly four
seconds exactly eight seconds 16 seconds
between the tries that can actually
cause a kind of burst of of calls into
catalog service at the very same time
right because they are waiting for
exactly the same time between retries so
to avoid overwhelming our catalog
service what we can do is introduce a
little bit of randomness so that it is
not exactly four seconds or exactly
eight seconds and stuff like that
so how can we do that i'll do ctrl c in
both of my terminals to stop those
processes and do ctrl j to close the
terminals
and what we're going to do is add what
we call
a jitter so this is going to be
the way to add that randomness here so
i'll go up
and just over here i'll introduce
a
random
error
it's going to be
new random
and then let's go back to the section
where we're defining the retry attempt
over here
and we're going to do is just go to next
line and we will say
plus
time span
that
from milliseconds
and we will say uh
yearly dot next and so we want to add is
some number of milliseconds to those
seconds so we'll say any number from 0
to
1000 should be fine
so this time we should see that it's not
just a specific amount of seconds but
those seconds plus some milliseconds
that are going to be generated at random
so i'll save that
open terminals again ctrl j
dot net run
and dotnet run
and let's go back to postman and try
this again so i'll hit send
let's go back here and as you can see
now we are not waiting just two seconds
but 2.5 to 3 seconds and the next time
we're waiting for that
3-8 seconds and so on and so on yeah so
with that the different instances will
be invoking back to a client at
different slightly different times
which lets a catalog not get overwhelmed
and so this is much better and would
certainly help us handle temporal
glitches uh when reaching out to the
catalog service
however
imagine that a widespread network outage
is preventing us from reaching catalog
or perhaps is preventing catalog from
reaching its defenses so such outage
would likely last let's say a half an
hour and if we have all of an inventory
service threats retrying that much time
we may end up exhausting its resources
in the next lesson we will learn more
about resource exhaustion and how to
deal with it via the circuit breaker
technique
in this lesson we will learn about
resource exhaustion in microservices and
how to deal with it using the circuit
breaker pattern
having a retry policy in place is good
but you also must be mindful about the
limited resources available to your
service
imagine once again a situation where
there is an ongoing issue with your
service dependency
this might not be just a transient issue
but instead
some prolonged downtime caused perhaps
by a broad network
now the client calls our service and
this one in turn invokes the already
failing dependency
which will hopelessly start waiting for
a reply
while this is happening more clients
keep sending requests to our service and
this results in more requests being sent
to the failing service
one thing you have to realize is that
each of these requests are making use of
your service threads
of which there is only a limited amount
once enough threads are in use
there are no more resources available
and you can reach what we call resource
exhaustion
when this happens your entire service
becomes unavailable
for any future requests potentially
causing a lot of trouble in the system
one approach we can use to properly
handle this issue is implementing the
circuit breaker pattern
a circuit breaker prevents service from
performing an operation that's likely to
fail
here's how it
works once again we are in a situation
where our dependent service is already
in a bad state
unable to provide successful replies
our client then makes a request to our
service
however this time instead of invoking
the failing dependency directly there is
an intermediary that we will call the
circuit breaker
the circuit breaker will now start
monitoring the results of each of the
requests that go through it
that go through it to the external
dependency
and when it detects that the rate of
failure goes beyond the configured
threshold it will immediately stop
letting any more requests go out
and will fail them right away
this is what we call opening the circuit
after this request will just keep
failing immediately during the
configured wait time
which would hopefully give the dependent
service enough time to go back to a
healthy state
eventually the circuit breaker will let
some requests go out to verify if they
succeed
and if that is the case
it will close the circuit again
letting all 40 requests reach the
dependent surface
that's how the circuit breaker prevents
our service from reaching resource
exhaustion
while at the same time avoids
overwhelming dependent services until
they get a chance to recover
let's go ahead and implement the circuit
breaker pattern in an inventory
microservice
to implement the circuit breaker pattern
all that we have to do is add a new
transient http record policy just like
we did for the weight and retry policy
so here we are again in the inventory
microservice in the startup class
configure services method and i'm going
to scroll down a little bit here
and remember we have already added
policy for weight and retries and we
have a policy for timeouts
so what i'll do now is i'll open yet
another section here
to add our our next
http record policy so i'll do a
transient http load policy remember we
want to do this just before the timeout
and not after so that this policy can
also wrap the benefits of the timeout
policy
so open parenthesis here
and what i'll do is i'll just copy this
little section here so that we are
we are properly combining this policy
with the time with deceptions that could
come out of the timeout policy
but then what i'll do is i'll invoke the
circuit breaker async method here
and i'll open parentheses
and here we have to suffice the
parameters for circuit breaker
so the first parameter that we have to
define here is how many
tries we're going to allow or how many
requests we're going to allow through
the circuit breaker before the circuit
has to open right so in our case let's
say that's going to be three so three
failed requests are going to are going
to go through the circuit breaker before
the secret breaker actually notices that
yeah there's a problem and we have to
open the circuit
next comes the duration of the or time
span of the other break so this is how
much time we will keep the circuit open
so let's say this is going to be
time
span from seconds let's say 15.
and that's really most of what you have
to do you don't have to do more than
that to enable the secret breaker uh but
just like we did with our tries let's
add a couple of functions here
to get an insight of what's going on
behind the scenes
so what i'll do is i'll say
on break so this is a functional that
will be used when
when the secret opens
so i'll say outcome
and time span
okay
so in this case we want to add a log
message and stating that the secret the
secret breaker is opening
so this is going to be really very
similar to what we did for
uh
for our weight and we try so i'm
actually going to copy these three lines
from here
i'll copy them over here for our own
break function
and i'll just change the message
the following way
so i'll delete this and i'll say
opening the circuit
for
and this is going to be
time span that
total seconds
seconds
okay so that's what's going to happen
when the secret breaker opens
and then next we're going to add another
one
for the on reset
on reset function
that's not going to receive any
parameters
and in this one we're going to do
something very similar so i'll copy
again that that line those lines
paste them there
and in this case we're just going to say
closing the
circuit
okay
so that's really all you have to do to
enable secret breaker so
again
we are waiting we will allow three
requests to go into secret breaker and
if those three are failing the rate the
circuit is going to open
then it's going to wait 15 seconds uh
before allowing any new request to
actually totally try to to reach the
other end uh during those 15 seconds
things are going to just fail right away
and then we have functions to
lock what's happening when the secret
opens and when the circuit closes
and now i'll go ahead and i'll open my
terminal so i will save this file i'll
open the two terminals using the like in
previous lessons i have two terminals
inventory service on left side catalog
service on the right side i'll do.net to
run in both sides
okay notice we keep getting these
warnings about the build service
provider issue that we talked before but
like i said that's this is just for
demonstration purposes
so now i'll get back into postman
and we'll try out that inventory api to
get all the items in the user's
inventory see what happens so i'll just
go ahead and hit send
and notice the left side that we tried
we failed so we waited for 2.02 seconds
then we tried failed waited for 4.64
seconds and then at that point the
circuit actually opens for 15 seconds so
we're waiting at 71 seconds for the next
try but the moment that we try this
again
things fail right away as you can see on
the left side and you see if we see
what's happening in postman yeah we're
getting that error the circuit is now
open is not allowing any further calls
and if we try once again uh it may take
one or two seconds but it will fail
because the sequence is open and if we
just keep trying and keep trying uh
we're getting an immediate result so
this is the effect of having the circuit
open so any new requests are coming here
from any client or service are going to
fail right away
however eventually the circuit
lets us go through one word request and
if it notices that it's successful it
opens the circuit like it happened right
here we go back to postman
we can see that it allowed one more
request just to see if things are
healthy once again and it got a 200
result
and then it said yeah closing the
circuit and it allowed things to keep
working once again
so that's how the secret work breaker
works and that's how it can help us
prevent
overwhelming other services or having to
waste resources and cause resource
exhaustion in our microservice
at this point we are doing a fairly good
job at handling parts of failures
between our inventory and catalog
services
however could there be a better way to
have inventory get all the information
he needs from catalog without having to
rely on catalog to be available most of
the time
in the next module we will learn about
the asynchronous communication style and
how it can help us enable a much more
resilient communication between our
services
in this model you will learn about the
asynchronous inter-service communication
style the challenges it can help solve
how to implement it via habit and queue
and mass transit and how to enable
eventual data consistency between our
two microservices
by the end of this model you will have a
solid understanding of the following
the basics of and when to use
asynchronous communication between
microservices
how to enable microservices autonomy and
the impact to the sla
how to use a message broker for
asynchronous data propagation
how to stand up a ravine queue message
broker via docker compose
how to publish messages to ravit mq via
the mass transit framework
how to consume messages from gravitmq
using mass transit
and how to implement eventual
consistency of data propagated across
microservices
in this lesson we will learn about the
asynchronous communication style and how
it can help us enable much more
resilient communication between our
services
imagine a scenario where after receiving
a request from a client our microservice
needs to reach out to two other
microservices
also each of these services need to get
in touch with other services which in
turn might need to further reach to more
services
there may also be services that depend
on the services that our service depends
on
we originally fine tune our service so
that it never takes more than 300
milliseconds to respond to our client
requests
however when we started making
synchronous calls to one of our
dependent microservices we had to add to
our time the 200 milliseconds that that
service can take to respond
that was still okay in the beginning but
unfortunately when that dependency
eventually started calling another
dependency
and that one yet to another one
our oral
average latency bumped to
1450 milliseconds
which is bad
on top of that if one of our deeper
indirect dependencies starts failing
even if temporarily it can cause all of
the services that depend on it to also
start failing
and the effect keeps cascading until
potentially most of our system becomes
unavailable
one important concept that you should
keep in mind as you embrace
microservices is the service level
agreement or sla
the sla is basically a commitment
between you as a service provider and
the client
for instance as part of our sla we could
have defined that our service can be
expected to be up and running
99.9 of the time
so when our clients choose to use our
service they should expect it to be down
approximately 44 minutes during the
month
which the owners of the client will have
to decide if it's susceptible
however when using synchronous
communication calculating such numbers
for our service sla gets more
complicated
our deepest dependency is also
advertising at 99.9
uptime in their sla
and let's say that all of the services
initially advertised at the same value
however in our scenario when dependency
4 fails
it impacts the sla of dependency 3
which now sets its sla down to 99.8
this in turn impacts the sla of
dependency 1
and ultimately
impacts our own sla
now with an sla of 99 at six percent of
time our clients would be subject to
about
175 minutes of downtime across demand
which
is way below of what we wanted to
provide initially
so the synchronous communication style
suffers from an increase of latency due
to the chain of calls
it can significantly amplify the impact
of partial failures and can potentially
reduce the sla of our service
now let's look at the asynchronous
communication style
here the client does not have to wait
for a response in a timely manner
and in fact depending on how the
communication has been set up there
might not be any response at all
to enable such communication there is
usually an intermediary called the
message broker
which is pretty dumb in nature
meaning that it has no business logic on
it
and it is also highly available
with the message broken in place the
service client sends messages to the
broker and the broker forwards the
messages to receivers as soon as
possible
the messages can be received by two
types of receivers
a single receiver in which case we think
of the message as a command via which
the client requests an action on the
receiving service for instance when a
purchase operation starts our trading
service will send a command to our
inventory service asking it to grant
items to the user's inventory
and another command to an identity
service asking it to david kill from the
user
we could also have multiple receivers
where there are multiple services that
subscribe to the events published by the
client service
this would be the case if for instance
our catalog service would like to
publish any updates with catalog of
items so that other services can be
informed about the changes
one of the key benefits of using
asynchronous communication is that it
enforces a microservices autonomy
let's see how it's enabled
in a single receiver scenario we would
have again our client talking to our
service
but our service will not talk to its
dependent service
it will instead send an asynchronous
message to a broker
and he will immediately acknowledge to
decline the successful reception of the
request
the dependent service will consume this
message from the message broker as soon
as possible and will eventually provide
a reply via the same broker
at that point the client can request a
status of its initial request to our
service
or our service can notify the client of
the response
all of the services in our system would
follow the same message-based approach
including cases where a reply is not
required from the call service
the great thing about this kind of
layout is that when one of the dependent
services fell
it would not cause any impact on the
other services
since all of them have been decoupled
from each other and only talked to the
message broker
so the same sla that one of the services
presents
can be honored across the entire system
assuming that the message broker offers
high availability
so with asynchronous communication
partial failures are no longer
propagated
each service has its own independent sla
and best of all
the autonomy of all microservices is
enforced given the lack of coupling
between them
one of the nice things that asynchronous
communication provides is the ability to
asynchronously propagate data across
services
in the synchronous communication
scenario when the client requests the
user the user's inventory
and since the inventory service only has
the data that's relevant to it
inventory has to first talk to the
catalog service in order to retrieve
additional details
about each item
how comes asynchronous communication
health here
well thanks to the presence of the
message broker
what we can do now is have the catalog
service publish an event each time a
catalog item is created or updated or
deleted
such event doesn't have to have all the
details of each item but only the ones
of interest to client services
we can then have our inventory service
listen to these events and create its
own collection of catalog items
in its own database
as long as we have a highly available
message broker the list of catalog items
in the inventory database should be
eventually consistent with regards to
what's in the catalog service
now when the client requests the user's
inventory
inventory has no need to go out into any
dependent service to request item
details it has everything it needs in
its own database and it can immediately
provide a reply to the client with no
additional latency
so
thanks to asynchronous communication we
can enable eventual consistency across
our system the autonomy of our services
is preserved
and the previous inter-service latency
is reduced or completely removed
in the next lesson we will start
implementing asynchronous communication
between our two microservices
we will introduce revit nq as our
message broker of choice given that it
supports the amqp protocol it is
lightweight
easy to run locally and is very popular
in the open source community
revit queue introduces a concept of
exchanges which you can compare to a
mailbox
when a service like catalog needs to
publish a message it will send it to an
exchange in gravity mq
and with the appropriate bindings in
place
the exchange will distribute the message
to any of the configured queues
from there habit and queue will take
care of delivering the message to any
subscribe services like inventory
we could use revit queue directly in our
code but we would first need to create
the exchanges and queues and configure
the bindings to ensure messages are
properly routed also our code will be
tied to ravitmq and if we ever wanted to
move to another message broker we would
need to rewrite a good part of our
services code
for this and a few other reasons we will
instead use mass transit on top of
raviten
queue mass transit is a popular open
source distributed application framework
for net
mass transit can take care of doing most
of the heritage mq configuration for us
and is able to integrate with multiple
other message brokers while allowing our
services to stick with a higher layer of
broker agnostic apis
as part of this mass transit introduces
the concept of a publisher
and a consumer
which is what our service code will
focus on
let's start coding
just like we need to define dtos to
establish contracts between a rest api
and our api consumers we also need to
define the contracts that define the
messages to exchange between services
that use asynchronous communication
however this time we will define the
contracts in a separate project mainly
because we will later package and share
the contracts with other services so
they can easily use them
so let's start by defining the contracts
that our catalog service will use to
send events asynchronously anytime an
item is created updated or deleted
so here we are once again in our catalog
microservice project and what i'll do is
i'll open my terminal via ctrl j
and then i'll switch to the
search directory and i'll go ahead and
create a new class library so i'll do
dot net new
classlip
and the name we're going to give it is
play that catalog that contracts
okay so now we have a new contract
project over here and before we forget
let's make sure we get a reference from
the catalog project into the contract
project
so what i'll do is i'll go into
play that catalog that service and then
i'll do dot net add reference
and it's going to go into play that
catalog that
contracts
lay that catalog.contract.cspro
so i'll make sure that we can use this
contract from the a catalog service
now let's go to our let's collapse this
and let's go to our contracts project
and let's actually collapse this
terminal
and let's delete this class one we're
not going to need it and let's actually
bring in a brand new file into the
contracts project
we will call it just
contracts.cs
let's give it a namespace
i'm going to replay that
catalog that
contracts
and here we're going to declare three
records that are going to represent
these contracts four items are getting
created updated and deleted so let's
start with the created case so public
record
catalog
item created
so
here we need to specify not everything
about the catalog item but really the
stuff that our consumers are interested
in so in this case what our consumer
needs in this case inventory needs to
know is the item id the name and the
description so let's specify that so
good item id
let's import the missing namespace
the name and the description
and then we need to specify the the
event for when items are getting updated
so i'll just copy the one for created
since these are very similar uh i'll say
update
okay it's really the same information
we're going to emit any time and writing
has been updated
and then lastly
let's define catalog
item deleted
and in this case the only thing that we
need to communicate is the id of the
item so in this case it's just going to
be
good item id
so with that we have defined all the
controls that we need
and in the next lesson we will update
the catalog service to start using these
contracts and a few new nuget packages
to start publishing messages to a
service broker
it's time to update our catalog
microservice so that it starts
publishing messages anytime an item is
created updated or delete it
so i'll start by opening a terminal so
that we can bring in a couple of uh
nuget packages that we're going to need
so here i am in the play that catalog
directory i'll switch to src and to
play that catalog that service not the
contract but the service one
and here i'll add the net add package
masstransit.asp.net core
okay so this one brings in a bunch of
functions that we're going to use
in order to interact with the mass
transit libraries
and the next package is going to be mass
transit that
habit
mq so this one introduces a couple of
additional api so that we can explicitly
use the a rabid nq service bus
okay so with those added let me close
this terminal
and i'll go to play catalog service and
into our items controller
and perhaps i'll close the navigation
pane for now
and here we're going to do a few things
first let's get rid of this temporal
code that we added in previous lessons
to simulate temporal failures so we
don't need really any any of these
anymore
remove that
remove that and also remove this request
counter that we had added
now the first thing that we're going to
need here in order to be able to publish
messages is what we call a polish
endpoint so this is the this is the
class that allows us to really
communicate that we want to send
messages to some location
so i'm going to declare
a variable of type i publish endpoint
let's call it just publish endpoint
and for this we're going to need to
import
the mass transit namespace
and then we're going to receive this
variable as via dependence injection
into the constructor
and then we will grab that instance into
our pollution point variable
now we can go to each of our
controller actions operations where we
want to push a message and start sending
those messages so i'm scrolling down
into our post async method
and what we're going to do is that just
after creating the item in our database
we're going to publish a message
announcing that the message has been
that the item has been created so i'll
do
await
foolish endpoint
dot publish
and here we're going to use our new set
of contracts and we will start with our
catalog item created
contract and let's see control dot we
need to import the play catalog contract
namespace
and here we have to provide of course
the item.id
item.name and item.description
and that's really all you have to do to
publish a message
and i'll copy this line
because now it's time to go to our put
async method and do something very
similar so just after updating the item
into the database over here
let's add and paste that line but in
this case the
method is going to be catalog item
updated
and we will choose the existing item
variable that we have here
we'll use the the id the name and the
description
i'll copy this once again
and let's go to our delete async method
and again just after removing the item
we will go ahead and publish a message
saying that we have a catalog catalog
item
deleted
which is going to be
just the
id that we received from the
from the parameter
so yeah so that's all you have to do and
so now any
any consumer of these messages that is
listening to to to the queue to the
right queue it will be notified that an
item has been created updated or deleted
now what we have to do is to
do the proper registration in startup uh
to configure and to register the classes
that we need for mass transit from wmq
so i'll open my explorer here
and i'll go first to upsetting.json
here just like we did with mongodb we
need to add a little section for our
rabbit enqueue settings
so i'll open a section here let's name
it
rabbit mq settings
open a section here
and here the only thing that we're going
to declare at this point is
the host so which which where is this uh
this gravity mq server living and in our
case since this old local machine is
just going to be
localhost
you could specify more details like
username password and a bunch of other
settings but for now for local purposes
we will just accept the defaults and we
will go with localhost
save that
now just like we did with the other
settings libraries settings classes we
need to introduce a class that
represents a habit and q settings so
that we can use that in startup so i'll
create a new settings directory here now
and of course we will move this later
into our shared command command library
but for now let's just do it here and we
will do that refactoring later on i'll
add a new file into the settings
directory
let's call it
rabbit nq
settings that's cs
let's add a namespace
that
catalog
let's service
that settings
and then let's declare our class
public class
habit mq settings
and as we know the only thing that we
need here is the host so i'll declare
our
string
host
and as with any other settings class we
will do use this as
as
init as opposed to set because and
nobody should be setting these
these properties after they have been uh
deserialized from the configuration file
i'll save that
and now it's time to go to startup to
register with the services that we're
going to need so i'll go to startup
and again i'll collapse this navigation
pane
so here in startup i'll locate our
configure services method
right here
and then we will add the mass transit a
classes just before the controllers
let's do it here
we're going to say
services that
add mass transit
and we will receive a variable here that
we're going to be using to configure
things
i'll open a section here
close this let's see if we're missing
something
yeah so we need to import the mass
transient space
and then we will use this x variable
here
which is that we call the configurator
uh to specify the type of transport that
we want to use in our case that transfer
is going to be rabbit and q so we have
to say x dot
using rapid mq
and then we need to receive we need to
specify a function to configure the
habit and queue so in this function
we're going to declare two parameters
which is going to be the context
and the configurator
and then let's give it a let's give this
function a body
stat
say
and the first thing we're going to do
here is to
get an instance of those rabbit mq
settings so that we can figure out
what's the host that we're going to use
so we will just say
have it
mq
settings
it's going to be
configuration get section
and then the section that it should have
the name of
covet mq
settings
have it into settings class
and let's see if we're missing something
yeah we need to import the play catalog
service settings namespace
and when we have that we can say okay so
now get it as a
habit enqueue
settings type
okay so we have the settings and now
what we can do is use the configurator
to set the host
where our gravity mq instance lives and
that's going to be in
gravitysettings.host
and now we'll add one more line this is
not necessary but i think it's very
handy and this line is going to help us
define or modify a little bit how the
cues are created in the rabbit and queue
so i'll do configurator dot configure
endpoints
and here we're going to receive the
context
and
afford mater and what we're going to use
is the
kebab
case
endpoint name formatter
see if we're missing something yeah we
need mass transit that definition
and in this formatter we're going to
define
um
we're going to define first uh the
prefix that we're going to be using for
our cues and that's going to be
service settings
dot
service name
and then we will not need to include the
full name space of our classes in those
queues so we'll say we'll just say false
here
and lastly we'll add one more line just
after this one
to start they must transit
the hosted service
so we will say services that
add
holds service
and this is the service that actually
starts the rapid mq bus so that messages
can be published to the different
exchanges and queues in rapid queue
i'll save that
and for one last change i'll go to our
i'll go to our explorer
and i'll go to app settings at
development.json and this is something
that i like to do more for demonstration
purposes than for anything else but this
is a changing the default
login level
from information to debug
so i found that this is going to be very
handy for us to understand what's going
on behind the scenes when messages start
flowing between services so we'll do
that
over
here
and at this point the catalomic service
is ready to publish messages to have it
and queue
but we don't have a rabbitmq instance
available just yet
in the next lesson we will expand our
docker compose file to also stand up a
rabbitmq docker container that our
catalog service can communicate with
it's time to stand up our rapidmq
message broker
and of course we'll use docker for that
so here i am in visual studio code and
what i'll do is i'll open our play.inf
directory play that infra and then i'll
do code.r
and here i'll just go ahead and close
this close that and i'll open our docker
compose java file and perhaps i'll
collapse this
so the first thing that i'll do is i'll
go ahead and remove this comment that we
had at the top
and now we can go ahead and start
declaring our gravity mq service so just
like we did with [ __ ]
we'll come here
and we will declare a service for
driving queue
let's name it having queue
and then as usual the first thing that
we want to declare here is the image
that we're going to use
that image is going in this case is
going to be the standard rabbitmq image
that includes also a portal to manage a
derivative infrastructure so that would
be driving queue management
then we will mention the container name
the name that we're going to give to
this container and it's just going to be
rabbitmq
then we'll go for the ports section
we're going to open uh two ports
one port for our services to communicate
without having queue and then another
port for us to be able to navigate to
the cabinet and queue portal so the
first port is going to be
five six
seven two
maps to the same one internally
and the other port is going to be
fifteen
six seven two
which maps to the same port internally
too so the first one is going to be used
by the services to publish messages to
or to consume messages from hybrid and
queue and the second one is going to be
used to be able to go to the portal to
the writing q portal
then we're going to go to the volume
section and we're going to declare a
volume also for having queue
which is important because we don't want
to be missing those messages if the
gravity and queue container goes down
so i'll just declare gravity mq data
and now we have to uh we have to map
that volume into some location in our
rabbit mq
image or container
so i'll declare volumes
i will copy have it in queue data
and then location the location that you
want to map inside rabbit enqueue
is going to be var
leave
grab it mq
and one more thing that we have to
suffice here which is pretty important
is the hostname
so hostname and we will give it the
value of rabbit enqueue
so this one here is pretty important
because this is associated to how having
mq stores data internally and if you
don't specify it then it gets a random
value and then each time we restart the
container gravity and q would store data
in a different place which is not going
to help us really a lot so keep in mind
you always want to specify here it
doesn't matter what value is here but
you have to specify some value
okay so with that done i'll do ctrl s to
save this file
and then i'll open the terminal
and it's time to start this container
via docker
compose
up dash d
hit enter
and this is the first time that i'm
pulling in the
hovering q image so you have to download
it to my machine
like i said next time it will be faster
so yeah now we have
we have raving queue up and running over
here
and with that we can start trying this
out so i'll go back to our catalog
project
and here we're going to start the
catalog the catalog web server uh but
we'll do it via dotnet run so that we
can take a closer look at what's
happening behind the scenes so i have
opened the terminal ctrl j then i'll do
src and then i'll do
data catalog that service
and then let's just do dot net run here
i'm going to collapse this also
and so a couple of things to notice here
is that
uh so yeah mass transit is doing its job
it's starting the starting the bus
and then it has connected to
it has connected to gravity and q in
port 5672
is using the protocol aem qp so here's
where you can see the actual address of
rabbit enqueue in the docker container
uh like i said this is the one port to
connect uh today to the queues
and so things are looking ready on this
side so now we'll go to postman
and what i'll do is i'll go ahead and i
will create an item in our catalog so
i'll go to our catalog
api and i'll open the post one
and here i'll create some new item
let's say this time we're going to
create an antidote
so antidote
curse poison
and then price going to b7
and i'll hit send
so that then got created in the database
but now let's see what else happened so
if we see now here
yeah the item got created but also
an exchange was created uh in gravity
and queue so mass transit created this
exchanging gravity queue for us that's
one of the nice things about mass
transit so we don't have to create it
manually and it got the name play
catalog contracts and then the name
would be catholic item create
so an exchange will be created for each
of the messages that we publish
from from catalog
and you can see that after created
exchange it also sent the message to
that
to that exchange the message was sent
over there
and so if you want to see
how this looks like in gravity and queue
actually we can go ahead and check out
the java and q portal so let's open that
portal now
here we are in the browser let's go to
localhost
15672
is the
easy place
and here we're going to use just the
default username and password for having
queue so that's going to be guest and
it's exactly the same password just
guest
login
and in this ui you can see a couple of a
bunch of things but really the one thing
that i wanted to show you now is the uh
the exchanges
and as you can see there is a exchange
created here cattle guiding created
and issued i find out meaning that
anybody listening to this exchange will
be able to
get the messages
and then cattle guide and create it i'll
go in there
and then
there's not much to see here because the
exchange just takes messages from one
place to the other it's not going to
store the messages and then as you can
see the exchange right here in binding
section it is not connected to any it
doesn't have any bindings just yet and
that's because we don't have a consumer
of these messages yet which is going to
be inventory and but it's not there yet
so the queue has not been created and so
there's no destination for these
messages just yet
and so at this point we are able to
publish messages from our catalog
service
anytime our items database is updated
so in the next lesson we will generalize
some of the code that we have added here
into our common library in preparation
for having inventory start consuming the
polished messages
let's move the code that configures mass
transit and rabbitmq into our common
library so that things get easier and
cleaner for catalog and any future mic
services
so here i am back in our catalog project
and i'll start by
going to our settings folder
and i will copy our raven queue settings
file copy that
and then i'll switch to
our common project our common library
i'll open our settings folder and i'll
paste the copied class
and i'll grab the name space from some
other of our
settings classes i'll just fix that
namespace here
save
and now before adding the mass transit
classes let's bring in the nougat
packages that we're going to need over
here so i'll do ctrl j
let's go into sirs
play that common
and let's add the same packages that we
already added into catalog so
dot net add package
mass transit that is b net core
and then let's do
mass transit that
have it mq
all right
so with that done let's go ahead and
create a new folder
let's call it
mass transit
and perhaps let's close this terminal
for now
and just like we did with mongodb
let's add an extensions file here
but we're going to add our handy
extension method so let's first declare
namespace
click that command that means transit
and now let's create our class
it should be a static class
and now we'll bring in our extension
method so this is going to be
public static iservice collection
add mass transit
with rabbit mq so that way we can do all
the registration for mass transit and
everything queue in one location let's
add the missing space
and
let's expand
let's extend i service collection
services
and here is where we're going to bring
that code from the catalog service i'm
going back to catalog
into the startup class
scrolling down
i'll copy these lines
copy that
into common
and i'll paste them over here
and now let's start fixing all these
missing name spaces so admins transit we
need to import using mass transit
and then uh for gravity mq settings
we'll need to import play that
command.settings
give that case endpoint name for matter
we'll need my strategy.definition
okay and just before we also will need
an actual instance of the configuration
class and an instance of our service
settings class now these are very
similar to what we did in mongodb so
let's see if we can get something from
there so mongodb extensions
let's see let's yeah let's grab these
two lines
let's close this
and into this spot
there
and let me collapse this navigation pane
now
so here we also need an entry an import
for eye configuration let's grab that
extensions configuration
and you can notice that there's no
service provider variable available here
however we do have a service provider
and that is this context class that
that's that's over here this ibus
registration context exactly a service
provider so we'll use that
as the class that can give us an
instance of i configuration
we can also fix this other configuration
member here
and let's also rename this x variable
here to something more meaningful let's
name it
configure
and since we are here one more thing
that we can do
is to perform the consumer's
registration the consumers are the
classes that are in charge of consuming
messages from the rabbit and queue
message queues
we have not created these classes just
yet for catalog because catalog is not
consuming but just publishing messages
but we will create these classes
inventory so since inventory will be
using this method we might as well just
add that registration over here
so i'll open a couple of lines here and
what i'll do is i'll just say
configure
dot add consumers
and there's a few ways to register
consumers and the way we're going to do
it is that we're going to specify
the assembly that should have all the
consumers already defined and that's
going to be the uh the entry assembly
for whichever microservice is invoking
this this class so to get that we're
going to say
assembly and we need another import here
using system reflection
that get entry assembly
and that that should do it
okay so any consumer classes that are in
that assembly will be registered by this
method
and finally let's go ahead and
return our services instance
to complete this method
okay so with that let's make sure
everything is built in so i'll do ctrl
shift b
and yeah everything builds just fine and
now let's go ahead and package it all
these new changes into a new version of
our nougat package so let's go back into
our powershell terminal and perhaps our
clean this
and listen we did before we're going to
do dot net pack
but this time we're going to specify a
version last time we didn't do it and
that generated version 100 for package
this time we need to increase the
version so that our consumers can
actually notice that there's something
new available in the in the package so
to specify version what you can do is
use the d
p sorry
parameter and then you specify
package version
and then you specify the version so i'll
say 1
0 1
and then just before we'll specify an
output directory it's going to be the
same location as before
packages
enter
and we got a new nuget package created
right there
so now let's go back to our catalog
project and start taking advantage of
this package
and first thing i'll do is i'll delete
our settings directly once again we
don't need it
get rid of it
then i'll go to our project file and
since we're bringing in this nuget
package that has all the master assets
stuff we should not need these two
references so i'm going to get rid of
them
save
and now what i'll do is i'll just go to
our play.com dependency and i'm going to
bump the version number here this is one
zero zero bumping it to one zero one
i'll hit save
this pop-up dialog shows up asking us to
resolve the updated dependencies so i'll
do a click on restore
and that's going to bring in the updated
package into catalog
so i'll close this and i'll close that
and now it's time to update our startup
class to take advantage of the new
package
and first let's get rid of this unneeded
import at the top
and now what we can do is just since
it's fluent let's expand on top of our
admonk repository so let's just do
add
mass transit
with rabbit enqueue
we may be missing a namespace
we need to import play.com on that mass
transit
and then that becomes a one line that we
have to run to execute all this stuff
that we were doing before so i'll get
rid of all these lines
save
and that should be good enough i'll do a
ctrl shift v to make sure that things
are compiling
yep it's looking good so let's go back
let's open a new terminal here
and let's verify that things keep
working properly so i'll do i'll go to
src
it's not into contracts we want to go
into
service and then i'll do dot net run
yup so yeah we are connected we have
connected to the rabbit and queue
so it's time to do something about
messaging so let's go back to postman
and last time we had created this
antidote
item and so instead of creating a new
one why not let's try the an update
operation so i put so i'm going to just
copy this
and then
let's go into put
and then in the body we're going to just
paste paste this
so it's the same antidote curse poison
but let's say that the price is now 9
and then let's bring the id
hopefully the same id that we used
before
so copy this id
into the url
for the put operation
and then i'll hit send
so we go 204 so it was a success
and now let's go back to vs code
and yeah just like before the exchange
was declared
and the message was sent to the exchange
as you can see
but this time we should have a new
exchange so let's go back to riveting
queue briefly
and here let's go now to exchanges
and as you can see there's a new
exchange here cattle guiding updated so
things are working properly
and one last thing that we have to do
here is to actually publish the catalog
contracts as a nugget package so that
inventory can use it in the next lesson
so let's go ahead and go back to catalog
and here i am i'm going to do ctrl c in
my terminal so that the whole stops and
then i'll switch to
our play dead catalog that contrast
directory
and here i'll do what we did before so
dot net
back
and then output directory
packages
that should go ahead and produce our
contracts package hit enter
and there it is so now we have a
contacts package that inventory service
will be able to
use to consume the messages
in the next lesson we will update our
inventory service so that it can consume
the messages published by catalog
the whole point of moving inventory to
using asynchronous communication is to
have its own database of catalog items
that it can use without ever having to
get in touch with the catalog service
api
therefore let's start by defining the
entity that represents catalog items in
the inventory microservice
so here i am back in our inflatable
inventory microservice
and i'll open our entities directory now
this new entity that we're going to
create has some similarities with
inventory items so i'm actually going to
start by getting a copy of inventory
item
so i'll just copy this and i'll paste it
right there and let's rename this into
catalog
item
catalog item and we rename this as
catalog item which also implements
identity
but in this case it's not going to have
most of these properties but it's only
going to reduce the id
now remember the categorizing has a
bunch of properties in the catalog
service but here we will only introduce
the properties that make sense for
inventory
so in this case this is going to be
we'll start with the
with the name
and then we will also need
description
okay so keep in mind that as you are
bringing in these entities from other
microservices you don't have to have
everything that
these entities have in the other service
it's only a the version
that the new market service needs in
this case us id name and description
with that done let's go ahead and start
bringing in the nuget packages that we
need for this
so i'll go to
play.inventory.service.csprock
and then i'll open my terminal
so let's go to src
enter the service play inventory service
and let's get a reference to our new a
catalog contracts nuget package so
dotnet add package
play that catalog that contracts
remember this has all the contracts that
we can use to consume messages from
catalog okay with that done let me close
this and now you can see that we have
applicator contracts here
but we also need to bump the version of
play.com because remember we added some
new uh
so some new classes in there so album
from version one zero zero to version
one zero one i'll save that
let's go ahead and restore the new
the new nugget package
now we can close this
close this these files
now it is time to define the consumers
and like i said before the consumers are
the classes in charge of consuming the
messages that have been published by any
other microservice
so to define the consumers let's go
ahead and
create a new folder let's call it
consumers
and we have to create one consumer for
each of the different operations that
happen in catalog so that's for creation
update and delete of
of catalog items so i'll go ahead and
create a new file let's name this one
catalog item
created
consumer
copy the
name let's give it a name space
service
consumers
okay so this is our catalog item created
consumer
and the first thing that you have to do
about this consumer's class is to make
sure that they are actually consumers
and to do that you have to implement the
iconsumer
high consumer interface which is part of
mass transit and i'll do control dot so
using mass transit and here you also
have to specify what is the type of
message that this consumer is going to
handle and that type of message is
actually coming from them the contracts
that we're bringing in from catalog so
in this in this case it's going to be
catalog item created
let's see if we're missing something
using play.contracts
so then let's go ahead and implement
this interface so i'll do ctrl dot here
implement interface and as you can see
we just have to implement one method
that which is the consume method so
which is where we're going to actually
uh perform the action of of consuming
the message
and so what we want to do when we
consume the message is actually a
storage in our local catalog items
database
so to do that let's first introduce a
repository that we can use for for that
so i'll declare
read-only i repository
of type catalog item okay so this is the
new entity we just introduced it
for catalog guidance in inventory
all right
see if you're missing something play
that common for i repository
and play that inventory service entities
and now we need to inject this
repository in the constructor of this
class so let's define a constructor
so
public catalog item created
consumer
and so here's where the repository comes
in
okay
so let's say this data repository equal
repository
let's now go ahead and implement the
consume method for this class
so i'll get rid of this and let's first
get a copy of the of the message so the
message
that we're receiving
is available in the context variable
as the message property so let's grab
that copy there
and then what we want to do as we
consume this message is probably first
make sure that we have not consumed this
already right uh we we may have a very
consuming message of the creation of an
item uh
with the idea that we're going to get in
this message uh and if we did we already
would have that into the database so
let's make sure that we don't have it
and if we do have it let's just return
there's nothing else to do but if we
don't have it we'll go ahead and create
it
so let's see
item is a weight
repository
not get async
and that's going to be in message dot
item id
let's also make sure that this method is
async
and then
if item
is not new
then we will go ahead and return
okay because in this case it happens to
be that we already created this item in
our local database so why would we
create it again
if not we will say new catalog item
and then we'll say all these
message.item id
name is message that name
and description
is message the description
finally we'll go ahead and
do repository dot create async
of this item
okay so that's all you have to do to
consume a message that represents a new
item that has been created in the
catalog like i said we just verified if
the item is already here because it
could happen in the cases where
for some reason the publisher publishes
the same message twice
and so we don't want to be having errors
here because we already have the item in
our catalog guidance database so if we
don't have it we'll go ahead and define
it and create it into our local database
let's go ahead and do something similar
for our a update so when a catalog item
has been updated so i'll get a copy of
our of the consumer
and let's just rename it into
catalog item
updated consumer
okay
so i'll do this
and then the the message is catalog item
updated
so let's fix a couple of things
constructor
there
okay so we are consuming now catalog
item updated
and here the logic is going to be a
little bit different so
for an update it could be that we
already have this inventory item in our
local database so in which case we'll
need to go ahead and just update the
properties or it could be that this is
the first time that we receive this
message for this item in which case
we'll go ahead and create it
so now in the case that uh so first just
before we can go ahead and get the item
but if the item is new so we'll change
this if item equals no then we will go
ahead and define these lines that we had
over here
there
so editing is new we don't have it in
the database so let's go ahead and
create it
otherwise
let's just update the the properties
that make sense in this case it's going
to be item.name equals message.name
and item.description equals
message.description
and in this case let's go ahead and call
weight repository
that update async
item
okay so quick recap we for an update
operation we go ahead find the item if
we cannot find it we will go ahead and
create it into the database and if we
find it we update nameless description
and update it into the database
now let's go ahead and implement our
third consumer which is going to be four
deleted items so again i'll get a copy
of
this last consumer
paste here and then rename it into
catalog item
deleted consumer copy this name
so i'll update the name of the class the
constructor and then let's make sure we
also update the message that we're
handling here this is catalog item
deleted
here and there and in this case things
are even easier
and so we will go ahead we'll try to
find the item and if we cannot find it
uh it means that for some reason it does
not exist in our local database so
there's really not much more to do in
our case so we will go ahead and just
return
we don't have it just go ahead and
return and if we have the item
then we can go ahead and say
weight repository remove async
message.item id
okay so with that we have our three
consumers defined
and now it's time to perform the proper
registration in startup
and before we can do that let me go to
app settings.json and we need to declare
those rabbitmq settings so that we know
how to communicate to have it in queue
so i'll actually go back to catalog
our catalog service over here and i'll
just grab those
three lines for hybrid mq settings for
an upsizing adjacent
and then back to inventory we will add
that over here
same thing we're talking to localhost
for arriving in queue
now let's go to startup
okay um perhaps i'll collapse this for a
moment
so let's do a few things here so as you
see we still have this logic to
use the catalog client to talk to the
catalog service uh we will not be using
this anymore
but let's keep this logic around in case
you want to reference it later but what
we're going to do is we're just going to
refactor it into another method so we
don't have to have all this stuff
hanging around here so i just selected
all this logic
to use the you know the retries and the
configuration of the client i'll do ctrl
dot and i'll say extract method
so we'll name this method at catalog
client
and i'll take this method and just send
it
to the end of the file
so that we don't have to see it
frequently
and now a couple of things that we have
to do here for
for uh our new a catalog items
repository and mass transit so
first we need to introduce a new
repository here for the catalog items so
i'll say
add [ __ ] repository
catalog of catalog item and then we need
to give a new name for this new
collection of items in this case it's
going to be
catalog items
okay so keep in mind that both of these
are going to live in the same database
the same inventory database but it's two
collections one collection for inventory
items and one collection for catalog
items
and then we also need to add the mass
transit registration so i'll say add
as transit
with habit mq
let's add a missing space
and that's pretty much it on startup
then let's go back to our explorer one
more thing that i'll do is just like we
did in catalog let's flip the default
log level so that we can see also
what's going on regarding
all these message exchanges
so i'll change this to debug
and with that our inventory service is
ready to start consuming messages but
one more thing that i'd like to do is to
actually
clean up our databases and i like to do
this because
at this point we we do have some data
both in inventory and catalog site but
that that data has never been
synchronized at all so it will be better
to use a start clean in a situation
where both sides are actually
synchronized from the start so i'll go
back to mongodb
the mongodb extension i'll expand this
and as you can see we do have the
catalog and inventory databases so to
clean them up i'll just right click and
say drop database
i'll drop catalog
and then i'll drop
inventory
you may choose to not delete them but
that could cause issues as as you start
moving forward so it's better to use
starkling in this case
at this point i'll start our micro
services so i'll do ctrl j to open the
terminal
i'll go to my terminal and perhaps i'll
do
clean
and just so that we can see things
better what i'll do is i'll
see i'll collapse this and i'll bring in
yet another terminal with the split
terminal put on here so that we can see
services in both sides
so perhaps what i'll do is i'll switch
to
a catalog on the left side
so i'll go to play that catalog
and then
play catalog service and on the right
side i'll stay in inventory so i'll do
play inventory service
okay so let's clean both sides
and now we can start both services i'll
do dotnet run both sides
and now notice in the right side that a
few new things are happening and perhaps
i'll move this around a little bit
and yeah it may be a bit hard to see but
exchanges has been declared for the
for the consumers that we declare here
you can see we have exchanges for a
cutter guiding created updated and
deleted
and if we scroll down a little bit let's
see
these exchanges are now connected to the
queues so you can see that this this
exchange is now connected to our new
inventory catalog item updated queue
same for created and deleted
and
the consumers are reporting that they
are okay so they're ready to start
consuming messages okay so let's move
this
over here
so now let's see this in action so let's
go to
postman
and what i'll do is i'll start by
creating a brand new item
so i'll go to our post item api in play
catalog service body
and let's define our classic potion
example again
we'll say potion
sources small amount of hp
and the price is going to be 5.
i'll go ahead and hit send
the item has been created
and then let's go back to our terminals
and see what happened
so as you can see on the left side
the change was declared cut the guiding
created and the message was sent right
so cattle guiding created was sent
and then the right side we can see that
now we actually received the message
and that was handled by the cattle guide
and created consumer
so if things went uh
correctly we should now have a copy of
the catalog item in our local a catalog
guidance collection in inventory site
inventory database
let's go to [ __ ] mongodb
let's see what we have so i'll expand
this
so we have the catalog database with
this item created here and then we'll
expand inventory
and then you can see that we do have now
our catalog items collection
with that
item created over here
so the item has been replicated from
catalog into inventory
we can now take a look also
the activity that happened in driving
queue so let me go to the driving queue
portal over here
and let's take a look at exchanges so
see that we now have the three exchanges
uh for category created deleted and
updated
from the catalog side
and then also the
the changes from the inventory side
created outdated and then if we go to
queues you can see that now we have the
three queues for the three types of
events
and
if you go to cattle guide and create it
we could see here any activity that goes
across this queue now the item has been
already consumed so there's nothing not
much to see here but let's see what
happens in a case where let's say that
our catalog service is is not running
right so
actually our inventory service is not
running so our catalog service pulls
some message but inventory is not
running now that the queue is up and
running
things are going to work in a speed of a
different way so let's go back to
inventory
and i'm going to stop the terminal on
the right side i'm just going to do ctrl
c
inventory stops now
and let's go back to postman and create
yet another item so i'll create an
antidote
which cures poison
and price is going to be seven
so i'll go ahead and pause this
and then if we go back to rabbit and q
let's see gather guy and create it
you can see that now there is a one item
in the queue as reflected by this
as you can see it's one item
which is waiting to be
consumed by somebody
so here is where the nice thing about
asynchronous communication starts
happening so there's no need for
cataract to be up and running all the
time uh inventory can nicely just keep
polishing these updates uh to their
to to their items and then whenever
inventory comes back it should be able
to consume the the message
and in fact let's go back to our
terminals
over here
you can see that the category was
created on the left side and now let's
go ahead and start a terminal on the
right side
let me collapse this once again
okay so on the right side i'm going to
do.net run again
and then you can see that right away
inventory is able to consume the new
message
so the databases should be in sync again
we can see that there's no more messages
here waiting the message was consumed
and our databases should be once again
sync let me refresh this
so yeah we have two documents here and
we have two documents over there
so things are in sync
so our inventories microservice now have
a nice way to stay in sync with any
updates to the items managed by the
catalog service
in the next lesson we will update
inventory so that it starts taking
advantage of this new capability anytime
it needs to present data that is
partially coming from catalog
now that our inventory microservice has
its own copy of the catalog items it no
longer needs to query the catalog
microservice to gather additional
information about the items of inventory
so let's update our inventory controller
to take advantage of its new catalog
items collection
so here we are back in our inventory
project and i'll go ahead and open our
controllers folder and i'll go to items
controller
let's collapse the navigation pane to
get more space
and let me scroll down a little bit
and the first thing that we will do is
to get rid of our catalog client
because we will no longer need to invoke
catalog client i mean the catalog
service anymore instead of that we're
going to declare another variable here
is going to be just another i repository
but in this case it's going to be off
catalog item
so this is going to be our
catalog items
repository and since we're introducing
this new repository let's also rename
the previous one so that it better
resembles its purpose so this is going
to be our
inventory items repository
let's also rename this
the variables in constructor so this
items repository becomes inventory as a
repository
and then the it's time to inject also
our new catalog items repository as
opposed to the catalog client
here we will capture that
so with that let's go down into our get
async method
and here's what we're going to do
the first thing is that we definitely
don't need to cut to call catalog client
anymore so we're going to get rid of
this
we still need to get the list of all the
inventory item entities
uh represent the items in the user's
inventory so this this stays
but after that what we want to get is a
from our local catalog items collection
we want to get all the corresponding a
catalog items that i mean the ones that
could respond to the inventory items on
inventory the today's inventory so to
get that let's first get all the list of
all the catalog item ids
that that are involved in the inventory
items collection that we have here so to
do that let's do this so
item ids
equals
inventory item entities select
let's do a little projection here
where item
item dot catalog item id this gives us
the list of all the the catalog items
that we have an inventory the ids
specifically
and with that we can go ahead and
get the actual catalog items so let's do
catalog item entities
is weight catalog items repository
get all they sync
where item
and what we're going to say is that we
want to get all the items that are in
the item ids collection so i'm going to
say
item ids
contains
item dot id
so now here we have all the catalog
items that match the
the items that we have an inventory for
this current for the current user
having that we can go ahead and
update this little function here so they
take advantages of this new items
collection and i'll say catalog item
entities is going to go here so now we
can go ahead and say okay so as we go
through all the inventory items
first we're going to look at the catalog
item entities and we're going to find
the catalog item whose id matches the
id of the catalog item id of the
inventory that we're looking at so
that's a catalog item
and then we'll keep moving forward as
usual and we say okay so now that we've
found the inventory item and now that we
have the catalog item let's go ahead and
turn it into dto adding the catalog item
name and the catalog item description
okay
so i don't think we need to make more
changes to pause async
so we should be ready to start using
this so i'll save this
i'll go back to catalog
i'll just going to hit f5 to start the
service
and i'll go back to inventory and i'll
do the same f5 to start the service
and now let's go ahead and go back to
postman and let's grant one item to a uh
to our user
so the first thing that we'll do is
actually get the list of current items
in our catalog to know what to grant so
i'll just open our get operation in the
catalog service and i'll hit send
here we are
we have currently a portion and an
antidote so let's say we want to do the
potion
so i'll copy the id of the potion
and now let's go to the
to the inventory collection let's expand
this and i'll go to our post operation
where we can assign
a assigned one item
to a user so i go to body
i'll paste the catalog item id that we
just copied over here so this is the
item to assign and then just like before
we need a user id
so and just as we did before let's use
the postman function go it to generate a
random user id
and finally let's get some quantity
let's say we're going to assign one
portion to this user
okay and so with that i'll go ahead and
pause that sent
and it's done and if it worked now our
user should have one potion right so
i'll go ahead and first we need to
figure out what's the idea of the user
that was generated and we can do that
from the console so i'll click on the
console
and i'll go down to our post operation
request body and it's right here this is
a user id that was generated i'll copy
that
close console and then we can go
to our get operation
to get all the users in the
sorry all the items in the user's
inventory and so we'll get
the items for this user
i'll hit send
and as you can see now we can see that
this user a has a potion has one potion
but more instruments interestingly it is
able to show the name and the
description of the potion from the local
catalog items collection so it no longer
needed to go ahead and and talk to the
catalomic service to retrieve decision
information so things are much more
resilient and rely and faster now
because we don't need to go out and ask
for this additional info
now what would happen if we go ahead and
update the description of this catalog
item in the catalog microservice how
would that look like here
let's try that out so first i'll go to
back to our get items
results and i'll copy a few details
about the potion i'll just copy that and
then i'll go to the catalog collection
and i'll go to the put operation
here's where we can make updates to our
item so i'll just come here
paste that
fix
indentation and let's say that instead
of having this description
it just says restores some hp
that's going to be the new description
also the id of this item is this one
here so let me grab it
go back to put i'll paste that here
and so let's go ahead and update this
item in the catalog microservice so i'll
go ahead and do that
and then i'll go back to our query for
the inventory items of the user and
let's see what happens with the
description of this of this item so i'll
hit send
and as you can see the description is
already updated and this is because as
soon as we updated the item in the in
catalog my service
a message was published into habit mq
and then our inventory service grabbed
that update into its local database and
is ready to present the updated
description
as we query for items
so this is great but now what would
happen if our catalog microservices is
having issues actually what happens if
it's completely down right so it has a
major problem
what would happen with it with inventory
maker service can it still keep working
just fine
let's see i'll go back to catalog
here's catalog i'm just going to stop
the service so service is completely
down
and in fact if we go back to
a postman and we try to get items again
let's see what happens
connection refused because the service
is completely down but then let's try to
get all the items on the user's
inventory
so i'll hit send
and still works
even more i can try granting yet another
item to the user's inventory
so just to test this out i'm going to
start catalog once again
hit a 5
back to postman let's go ahead and get
the list of items and now i'm going to
grind and grant the antidote to that
same user
let's do antidote
into the post operation
body so let's grab the antidote
let's make sure we use the same user id
it's right here
maybe it's ready
and then again like i said catalog is
having problems i'll just stop it it's
completely down it's not working
yet i'm going to go ahead and grab that
item to the user
i hit send
200 okay so it looks like it was
successful and then let's get all the
items inventory now so i'll hit send
again
over here and as you can see we can
query for the for all the items and all
the items are showing name and
description regardless of the fact that
the catalog microservice is completely
down
so this is the power of asynchronous
communication and this is how you enable
very resilient communication between
microservices
both services are now really autonomous
because they don't rely on each other to
be available at any given time
one more thing to consider is a case
where one of our consumers is not able
to consume the message properly perhaps
due to some issue when trying to talk to
its local database
so for instance let's go to
our inventory
inventory service over here
and i'm going to stop this for now and
close terminal
and i'll go here
into our consumers let's say cattle
guide and create consumer and
what would happen
if this line here is having trouble
right so when we when we go into the
consumer uh this this all this logic
happens because we're consuming the
message but if we fail if an exception
is thrown in this in this case and the
message is going to be sent into some
error queue and if you would not be able
to consume it anymore so at that point
you missed an update from the from the
catalog mic service
so is there a good way to handle this so
there's to be that yeah there's a
there's a way to do that so if you go
back to our
to our common library so here we are
back in common library
and we're i'm going to go to the mass
transit extension that we created before
and scroll down a bit
and what we can do is to enable analysis
we can do is enable message retries
for the consumption of the messages so
you can go here and say
configurator
that use message
message retry
and then here we're going to define our
retry configurator
okay let's open this section
and then you can say retry configurator
that interval
and then the first item the first
parameter you're going to specify is how
many times you want to retry so anytime
the the consumer is not able to consume
the message how many times you want to
retry that consumption so let's say we
want to say 3
and then you have to define the time
span
or our time between retries let's say
that's going to be
time span
let's import missing space
from seconds
and that's going to be five
five seconds
let's also import another missing space
we need to use using green pipes here
and that's all it is so with that logic
any time a message is is not able to be
consumed by the consumer it will predict
right three times
and with a five seconds delay
in there and there's a bunch of
different ways to configure this
depending on how you want to do your
retries
and with that let's just save extensions
and then if you wanted to consume this
in your microservices as usual you will
go ahead and generate another version of
the nugget package so in this case it
would be
it would just do dot net back
it would be
package version
let's say in this case would be one zero
two and then we send it to the same
location fe4
packages
package generated
and then you would just go back to
catalog
and update its version
over here to play.com102
save
restore dependencies
and then we would go back to
inventory and do the same thing
102
save
and then we'll not exercise this really
in this lesson and restore but that's
how you do it so from here on both
microservices has this capability to
retry the consumption of the messages
so that marks the end of this lesson and
of this model
you now have two independent and
resilient microservices that can
collaborate asynchronously to manage a
catalog of items and to grant and query
for items in a user's inventory pack
you also have a reusable common library
that any of your mute future
microservices can take advantage of and
that you can keep improving according to
your needs
in this model you will connect the
provided front-end project to your
microservices to enable basic end-to-end
scenarios from a modern single page
application
by the end of this model you will have a
solid understanding of the following
how to get and build the front-end
project in your box
how to host the front-end project in a
node.js server
what is the structure of the react-based
front-end
what is course and how to configure it
in your microservices
and how to debug the communication
between the front-end and your
microservices
in this lesson you will install node.js
which is a javascript runtime that will
host the front-end portal and that also
includes npm the package manager that
provides all the dependencies required
by the portal
the only additional tool required to
build and launch the front-end portal is
node.js
which you can get in the nodejs.org
website
let's see how to install node.js and
verify the installation afterwards
before installing node.js just keep in
mind that the pages that you will see
next will likely look a bit different
depending on your operating system and
the versions available at the time that
you're taking this course
but regardless the overall download and
installation process should be mostly
the same
so let's now browse to the node.js
website
and here the first thing that you're
going to see is a right away a few
download buttons for your current
operating system version and
architecture in my case that will be for
windows 10 x64 these are the two
versions the one on the left is the most
stable version available and the one on
the right is the latest version
available which may not be
the most stable one but it has the
latest features
i would recommend going for the most
stable version the lts version since
that's a recommended one for most users
now if the version that you would like
to download is not here you can always
go to the other downloads link over here
and here you can pick
the right version for your operating
system and you also have a few other
download options
now in my case i'm going to go back to
the
first page and i'm going to download
14170 lts so just click there
and i'll go ahead and start installer so
click here
here's installer
so i'll just click next
accept next
next and next
and at least for this course i have not
seen the need to install any additional
tools here so i'll just click next
and install to get installation started
say yes
and so with that node.js is installed in
the box so click finish
and what we want to do now is to verify
that the installation has completed
properly
so what i'll do is i'll just close the
browser now
and i'll open my visual studio code
instance here
and here in business to the code what
i'll do is i'll open my terminal by
pressing ctrl j
and i'll just type a couple of commands
to verify that the tools are installed
properly so i'll just type
node
v to get the version of node.js
which you can see right there
14
17 0
and and now also verify the version of
npm which is the package manager that
comes with node.js so i'll do mpm-v
and i can see the version right there
also
so with this we know that node.js has
been properly installed and we're ready
to move on
in this lesson you will explore the
structure of the front-end code base how
to install its dependencies and how to
build and run the portal
before exploring the front end code base
let me give you a few details about it
the front end is a simple single page
application that demonstrates one way to
interact with all the play economy
microservices
a single page application is a web
application that dynamically rewrites
the current web page with new data from
a server instead of constantly loading
new pages
it is built using react which is a
javascript library for building
interactive user interfaces
i chose react because at the time of
creating the course it was one of the
most popular front-end frameworks and is
easy to learn assuming that you have
worked with javascript before
it uses create react app to simplify how
you do local development how you build
and debug the code in your box
and how you package everything in
preparation for deployment
finally it is hosted in a node.js server
a very popular runtime for javascript
applications
there are a few things that i'd like you
to keep in mind as you work with the
provided front-end portal in these and
the next lessons
this is not a course about front-end
development and certainly not about
react
as a back-end developer myself i only
know enough react to build this simple
portal
however
i'm probably making lots of beginner
mistakes and i'm probably not following
client-side best practices in many
places so please don't use this code as
a template for the production level
application but more as a basic example
of one way you could interact with the
microservices from a modern client
you won't be coding this front end in
this course
there is both not enough time and i'm
not qualified to teach you how to build
a front end step by step instead i'm
providing you the finished portal so you
can use it as is
it should work with no issues and no
changes required
provided that you make a small update to
the microservices as i'll explain in the
next lesson
in this lesson i'll give you a quick
overview of the structure of the
front-end codebase with a focus on the
areas that interact with your
microservices as opposed to the many
components that handle layout rendering
and many other things
finally please check out the links below
if you would like to know more about the
deck used in the front end project
so here i am in a new bezel studio code
instance and i have already opened my
terminal into the projects directory
where i have all my files
and as you can see i have already
downloaded and extracted the front-end
project files into this directory play
that front-end
and what i'm going to do now is just
switch to that directory
and i'm going to open this instance of
code into that directory by doing
code that in dash r to reuse the window
enter
and here you can see the structure of
the project files on the left side
and what i'm going to do is first close
this terminal for a moment i'd like to
point you to the readme.md file so this
is a file that will give you a
description of
what this project is about and a few
other things and in fact what you can do
is just open this uh preview window
with this button
that opens up review on the right side
and close the original one so this gives
you a nice view of
the redmi file
so as you can see this is crafty project
it is creative prerequisites of the
project
and then it tells you how to
build the project how to run it locally
and also
it provides a bunch of other scripts
that are also available
now
what we're going to do is to actually
follow
this couple of first lines in this in
this file to get started with the front
end so as it says what you can do to
install a all the dependencies of this a
front end is a run just npm install
so open my terminal once again
here scroll down a bit and what you want
to type just at the root of this project
is npm install
hit enter
what this is going to do is to bring in
a bunch of node models
that represent all the dependencies
that
this this portal depends on
including react bootstrap and a bunch of
other things this is going to take a
while depending on your internet speed
because there's a lot of stuff that
needs to get downloaded so just give it
a moment
okay so the dependencies have been
installed and as you can see there's now
a node models folder on the left side
if you expand it you're going to find a
bunch of directories have been created
right
so
now that we have that we are ready to
run the portal so to do that if you
scroll down in the readme you can see
that you can just do npm start and
that's what i'm going to do here
npm
start
enter
so this is going to
compile the entire code
base and then it's going to start the
node.js
host
okay so it compiles successfully and as
you can see we get an address here to
browse locally to it
so i'm going to copy this address
localhost 3000
and i'm going to go to my browser i'm
going to paste that there and hit enter
and there it is
the portal is up and running in this box
now in the home page here what we have
is just a few basic things like the
description of the project
and then a couple of links uh both to go
to the catalog section uh to get the
list of the catalog items
and the inventory section so that you
can
inspect which are the items that are in
inventory back of a user
notice that we also have a navigation
bar at the top that takes you either to
the home or to the catalog and inventory
sections
there's also links here to go to the
rabbitmq portal if you wanted to to
explore what's going on with the queues
and there's also links here to explore
the swagger
soccer ui open api documentation for
both catalog and inventory service
and also a few other things
general links to
the different technologies that were
used to create the whole the whole
system
now before we go and dive into the
catalog and inventory sections which are
of course the most important uh parts of
this portal at this point uh let's go
back to pieces to the code for a moment
and let's explore briefly the files that
are available here just so that you get
an idea of how this project is
structured
so what i'm going to do is just close
this terminal for now and close the
readme
and the first file that i'm going to
show you is package.json this one here
describes all dependencies of this
project which are all the node models
that are installed by now and like i
said these include things like react
being used for all the components
interactive and dynamic components use
it across the portal
bootstrap for layout
and a bunch of things for being able to
do routes in the client side
the react scripts uh which are the ones
that we can use to start the portal
and a few other things
and uh and yeah many other dependencies
now let me close this
and then
uh take a look at the public folder here
this one is the one that defines
index.html which is what we call the
the page template so in a single page
application like i think i mentioned
before
there's not really a navigation into
different pages of a portal there's no
reload of pages there's just one page in
this case in the html
where every
all of these
dynamic components are loaded and
refreshed constantly
and in fact uh in this section here in
this div root here is where all the
javascript files uh javascript content
is injected with all the react
components
now this file also references config.js
which happens to be over here and this
is a file
where if you're asking where is the
addresses of all the microservices this
is the file so this is where you're
going to see the address of the catalog
service and the others of the inventory
microservice right there
as well as the address of the having
queue portal and a few other derived
address addresses for the items apis in
catalog and inventory
now the most important directory
actually here is the search directory
because this is the one that contains
all the react components so this is
pretty much
is the heart
of the of the project this is where the
system logic
happens
and in this file if you go to in the gs
this is where this is the
the route where we start rendering a
react components and we are asking it to
start rendering them in the a root div
that we just saw in in the in the html
this one here we saw that there's a root
div and that root div is where index.js
will get rendered as you can see right
here
and so the first react component that we
actually start rendering is this app
component over here which is coming from
app.js
this app component defines our app by
using uh first the layout component
which is in charge of rendering the
basic layout
of the system as you can see
over here if you expand components
layout js this is one that defines the
navigation menu at the top the container
for all the other components in the
middle and then the footer at the bottom
back to app.js
as you can see we have layout and layout
defines that inside of layout we're
going to have a component
for the home
a component for the catalog and a
component for inventory
so then if it goes just go into the
components directory we have our catalog
file and this is the one where you can
start really seeing interesting things
because
this file allows you to communicate to
the catalog microservice
if you go down into the populate items
method over here you can see that here
is where we are actually talking to the
academic service and then we're
getting a response from it and that's
that's the one that we are uh
collecting and setting it into the
client-side state that later on if you
see at the bottom
it's been rendered
as a list
as a table in the into the page
okay and it's the same idea with the
inventory.js which is able to render the
items inventory back of a user
we also have a few form well model files
and form files like guiding model which
is the one that is used to render the
model
a model dialog
so you can go ahead and either create or
update an item in the item form which is
the one that actually shows the form
inside that model
and the same way we have a model for
granting items for a for a user so that
it can go into his inventory back so a
model and a form for that same purpose
and lastly we have the that vs code
folder
which you should be very familiar but
with
at this point where we also have a
launch.json file
where we define a defining
configurations that you can use to start
debugging
either the server side or the client
side of this portal so you can see we
have a configuration for the server we
have named it server
this is going to be the one that can
launch the npm server
or the nodejs server
and one configuration for launching the
client at the location of the client in
the browser
there's also a compound configuration
which i named server and client server
client that can can be used to launch
both the server and the client at the
same time in your local box
okay so i'll just close this so now
let's go ahead and try that catalog
section so i'm going to open the
terminal once again here
so our front end is still running
but what we may not be running right now
is a catalog service so let me go back
to catalog
here's my a catalog code base so i'll
just switch to src
play that catalog service and then i'll
do
dotnet run
so catalog is now up and running
so let's go back to
the portal the browser
and in order to see the list of catering
items what you can do is either click in
catalog in the navigation bar over there
or you can click in this catalog link
right here and i'll click on it
and uh this should display the list of
categorical guidance but as you can see
that is not working right now so we
cannot load the items so there is some
problem happening here
and so
the client side
one way that you can tell what's going
on is by using the
the browser developer tools which
usually you can you can go to by
pressing the f12 key which i'm going to
do now f12
and this opens the developer tools
section now on this one there's a bunch
of tabs but the one that you're
interested in is in the console tab so
click on console and this is going to
show you what's going on so as you can
see there's an error access to fetch at
https alcohol 5001 items which is the
address of the cataloging service
from the origin http localhost 2000
which is the address of this
of the front end
has been blocked by course
the course policy so no access control
origin heater is present in the resident
resource
so what is this course thing about
that is going to be actually the focus
of the next the next lesson
so in the next lesson we will learn
about cross-origin resource sharing also
known as course
and how it can help us enable the
communication between the front end and
our microservices
in this lesson you will learn about
cross-origin resource sharing
also known as course
what problem it solves and how it can
help us enable the communication between
our front-end portal and our mac
services
to understand course let's first
understand what a close origin request
is
let's put our catalog microservice to
the site for a moment and let's imagine
that the node.js web server that is
hosting our frontend is also the server
that hosts the res apis to interact with
the [ __ ] database that owns the catalog
data
in this scenario the browser initially
navigates to the web server url to load
the front end home page
and then when the catalog section is
requested the browser makes a get
request to the catalog rest api
to the same web server url
to which the server will reply with the
json representation of the catalog data
the address from which the browser calls
res api is known as the origin
and is made of the combination of
protocol host and port
which in this case is http localhost it
doesn't
notice how the origin in the browser
matches exactly the origin of the server
that provides rest api
let's now go back to our actual scenario
where our catalog microservice hosted in
asp.net course kestrel web server is the
one providing the res api
now when the catalog section is
requested in the browser
the browser makes a get request to the
rest api at the origin of the catalog
microservice which is https localhost
5001.
since both the protocol and port of the
catalog service are different
than the one in the browser this is
known as a cross-origin request
the microservice will return the catalog
data just as before
but by now the browser knows that this
response comes from a different origin
since it had set the origin header in
the request
therefore it rejects a response data
with a course error
this happens because browsers follow
what is known as the same origin policy
which states that a web application can
only request resources from the same
origin the application was loaded from
browsers and forces to prevent malicious
websites from reading confidential
information from other websites
unfortunately this is also preventing
our front end from reaching the catalog
microservice
so how can we fix this
here's where course comes into place
course allows a server to indicate any
other origins than its own from which a
browser should permit loading of
resources
here's how it works
once again the browser has loaded the
front-end page
now the catalog section is requested and
a get request is sent to the catalog
microservice
and since catalog is hosted in a
different origin the browser appends the
origin header
the difference this time is that the
catalog microservice has been configured
with the access control allow origin
heater
which indicates all the other origins
that are allowed to call the res api
in this case this header has been
configured with the origin where the
front end is hosted http localhost 3000.
once catalog sends the item's data back
to the browser it appends this header to
the response
the browser now compares the value in
the orient header it sent to the value
in the received access control allow
origin heater
since they match the browser now allows
the response data to reach the front end
this works for simple requests like gets
but for post put and other methods
things work a bit differently
when a cross origin request may perform
some sort of write operation on the
resources owned by the server
like is the case when performing a post
put or delete request
the request needs to be first
preflighted
this means that an additional initial
request needs to be sent to the server
to determine if the actual request is
safe to send
going back to our scenario imagine we
now want to create a new item in the
catalog and therefore our front end will
send a post request to the res api
however since this is a post of json
data across origins the browser
automatically sends first a request with
the options method
this time not just adding the origin
header but also two other headers called
access control request headers and
access control request method
access control request method indicates
that when the actual request is sent it
will be a post
and access control request headers tells
the server that the request will come
with a content type heater in this case
the server should have been configured
to respond with corresponding headers to
indicate what it allows
the headers returned by the server are
access control allow origin access
control allow heaters and access control
allow methods
if the values returned in these heaters
match the values in the heaters sent in
the request
the browser accepts the post request and
submits this original request to the
server with the json payload of the new
item to create
the catalog microservice creates the
item and returns expected 201 status
code
as you can see the key to a successful
cross-origin request is in the
appropriate course configuration on the
microservice that exposes the rest api
since only the microservice can declare
the allowed origins
but how do we properly configure cores
in atheism net core
that's the focus of the next lesson
where we will add the missing course
configuration to both the catalog and
inventory microservices
let's now fix the course related errors
we are getting in the browser by
configuring the course middleware in the
request pipeline of our microservices
and let's start with the catalogue
service so i have the catalog codebase
open here in visual studio code
and what i'm going to do is open app
settings the development.json first
here i'm going to declare the ordering
of the frontend so that we can properly
configure it in startup later
i'm using app settings the
development.json and not absence.json
because the origin of the front end is
just a development server at this point
and we will not need a course policy for
that origin in production
so what i'll do is i'll just open
another section here
this is just going to say
allowed origin
and that's going to be the address of
our front end so this http
localhost 3000.
now that we have that let's go into our
startup file and here's where i'm going
to collapse the explorer for a moment
let's scroll down a bit
and what i'm going to do is define first
a constant to represent the name of that
setting that we just created
so this is going to be
private constraint
load origin
setting is going to be
the name that we just created over here
i'm going to copy it aloud origin
right there
and now that we have that we can
actually configure course so to
configure course what you want to do is
go down into the
configure method
which is where you configure the request
processing pipeline
and so like i said this is mostly for
development scenario at this point
because the front end is a development
web server so what i'm going to do is
take advantage of this m.easy
development section which only happens
with the 40 minute scenarios and i'm
going to add another piece over here
so i'm going to say
app.use course
and here we're going to provide the
function
that configures the course configuration
so i'll do
builder
and i'll do this
and then we're going to say builder dot
with origins
and here we're going to specify that
that origin which at this point comes
from the configuration data so it's
going to be
configuration
and here we're going to pick the right
key from the configuration which in this
case is
allowed origin setting
so remember this that this configuration
is the configuration object that has
been declared here
right here the configuration object
which is populated automatically by the
sp net core runtime so that
configuration object contains all the
data at this point of app settings that
json and upsetting the development json
included allowed origin setting
so you can use this to just go ahead and
get the key
that corresponds to the allowed origin
setting that we just declared so
configuration
and then allow origin settings
that allows the origin
but we also have to tell it which
headers and which methods are allowed
from the client side
so to do that what i'm going to do is
just say dot
allow any heater to allow any of the
heaters that the client wants to send
and we will say
allow any method
to allow any of the methods used from
the client side including get post put
and all these other verbs
okay so with that we have allowed the
front end origin and we have set any
here and any method should be allowed
okay so with that we should be able to
properly invoke the methods in the
microservice from the client side so let
me open up
my terminal once again and i'll do
netrun
and then i'll go back to the browser
where as you remember last time we did
have this course error
so now i'll just refresh the page
and as you can see
things are loading properly
and in fact if we inspect briefly
the network section here
and we inspect the items request that we
made right here
you can see that the browser did send
the origin
heater in the request for localhost 3000
and the catalog microservice
responded
with the access control allow origin
heater over there which is why the
browser allowed the response
so that's how you configure cores
and since we did this for the catalog
mic service we should do the same thing
for the inventory mic service
so let me go back
now to our inventory code base which is
open here in this other business to the
code instance and i'm going to do just
pretty much the same thing that we just
did
so here in fact i'm going to copy a few
sections here so from catalog
i'm going to close the terminal for a
moment i'm just going to copy this allow
origin section
into inventory
cloud origin
then back to catalog i'm going to copy
the
allowed origin
setting from
startup back into inventory in startup
at the top i'm going to place
that constant
and then finally
back to catalog
into the configure section i'm going to
copy the use course section here
and back into inventory
i'll collapse this for a moment
in configure i'm going to add this
right there
okay so this enables the same a
configuration for inventory as the one
that we have in catalog
so both microservices are properly
configured now so
in the next lesson we will explore in
more detail all the scenarios enabled in
the front end and how its react
components are interacting with the
microservices
let's now explore in more detail all
these scenarios enabled in the front end
and how its different react components
are interacting with the catalog and
inventory mega services
so i have stopped all the web servers at
this point both for microservices and
for the front end they're all stopped
because i want to restart them in debug
mode that way we can jump from client to
server and see line by nine what's going
on
so here i am in the catalog of my
service code base and i'm just going to
go ahead and hit f5
to start the web server and then i'll go
to the inventory maker service called
this code instance and i'll do the same
thing
f5
okay and now i'll go to our front end
and in this case instead of typing npm
start from the terminal i'll take
advantage of the debug configuration
that we have set here so i'll go to the
run on the box section
on the activity pane there
and as you can see we have a few options
here we can debug either server client
or server client server client is the
one that i'm actually going to pick so
that both
the client and the server are started at
the same time
so i'll click there
and this is going to bring up the
browser right away
however
it may take a while to load while the
server is compiling
the source code and starting the node.js
server
if we head back here you can see that
the server is getting started but it may
take a while to start
okay so as you can see the server has
compiled the source code properly and it
has started a debugging session of them
on the front end in localhost 3000
so now we can go back to the browser
and here we can go ahead and navigate
into the catalog section so i just click
there and then things are loading
properly
but how is this communication from the
client happening to the server side
so to understand that what we can do is
just head back to
play the front end
and what i'll do is i'll open
my explorer on the left side and i'll
collapse the terminal for a moment
and then i'll go into src
components catalog.js
let's collapse that
so here the communication happens in
this populate items method over there
first we call the fetch function where
we talk to the url of the catalog items
api so that total the catalog
microservice and then we get a response
back from it
the response will tell us the status
code if you wanted to inspect that but
this is actually a promise in the in the
javascript land is called the promise
which means that we will have to invoke
the json method to actually get the
items in this other 10
that we can then take and then uh put
into what we call the state the state of
the of this page
and then that state
is going to later be used into the
in the render items table uh the items
are going to be taken from the state
into this method are received as items
and then we will just render them in a
normal
html table
so let me put a few breakpoints back
into populate items
so that we can see things as they go so
i'll place this breakpoints over there
and let's also go to the catalog
microservice
so that we can put a breakpoint on the
server side so i'll collapse this and
i'll go to items controller
collapse that
and then here we can go into the
get async method put a breakpoint there
so now let's go back to the browser and
let's just refresh this page
and sure enough here back into
the front end we have hit the breakpoint
and as you can see here's where we have
the location of the catalog microservice
in the items api
so if i say continue
that's going to talk immediately to the
catalog microservice as you can see now
we are in the catalog service
let me collapse this a bit
and here's where we're going to go ahead
and
talk to our mango to our repository and
to talk to the mongodb database and then
return the items so i'll just say
continue
and now we are go we are back into the
front end where we have received that
response
which we can briefly inspect on the left
side
let me collapse this and that
and that
and as you can see we got a 200 status
code which is great
and then we need to
convert that promise into the actual set
of items so for that i'll just hit
continue
and now we have our list of items over
here in these returned items a variable
where you can see we have collected the
items from the server side with the date
the description the id and the name
as an array
and then if we just hit continue then we
go back to the browser we can see that
the items are right there
now how about creating a brand new item
so let's go ahead and click the add
button here
and this is the form where you can go
ahead and actually create an item
so again how is this form working so
going back to
play the front end
go to the code base you're going to find
the code for that in the in on the form
in item form
here
if we go back up
there's a method called create item so
this is the one that's going to be in
charge of sending the post request to
the catalog mic service to create the
item
now we can do the same exercise by just
placing a breakpoint over here
and then we're going to get a response
over there
same way we can go back to the catalogue
service
and we can place a breakpoint into the
post async method over here
now back to the browser
let's go ahead and create an item so
let's say we're going to create in this
case a shield and let's call it actually
round shield
and this is going to be
a basic shield
now
what happens if i just don't put a price
here so i'll go ahead and hit save
and you can see that this is going to
happen so we have enabled client-side
validation
via react into the client side so here
it is making sure that i have a name and
that i have a price if i don't have a
price then this happens
so sure enough i can put a price and
that should work
but before we do that what happens if i
do something a bit different like
putting
an invalid price like a negative five if
you remember the catalog service has
been configured with validations and it
should not allow a negative price here
we have i have intentionally not enabled
client-side validation for a negative
number here so that it just let it go
but how would that look like in the
uh
over here when the validation actually
comes from the server side to figure
that out i'll actually go back to
front end and put yet another breakpoint
into the catch section over here
so now let's go back to the browser and
try to save that
now we are back into front end so as you
can see we will send the request to the
catalog items
microservice i'll hit continue
and
as you can see we already got a response
here we didn't even need
we didn't even get to reach the
controller on the microservice because
the asp.net core validation
runtime
verified that this is not an allowed
thing like the dto that we sent did not
pass the validations so as you can see
the response here is already telling us
that this is a 400 bad request
because we have sent and uh
an invalid value
and in fact we want to know more about
what happened here what we can do is
just
let me put another breakpoint
over here
and i'll hit continue
and now we can inspect this error data
section here
and it says here yeah one or more
validation errors occur which by the way
is exact same validation that we were
seeing before imposement for this kind
of invalid inputs and if we expand the
error section here
you can see that we have all the errors
that are coming back from the
microservices like the field price must
be between zero and a thousand
so this is one way that if you wanted to
you can show that error with that that
specific error into the client in our
case we are only showing the error data
that title
uh property that's as much information
we want to show to the client at this
point so i'll just say continue then we
reach the catch section which will catch
all the errors here from validations or
for any other kind of communication
errors from the client and the server
and that's going to show an alert
we say continue and then back to the
client this is what we're going to see
good note at the iron one more
validation error secured
so to fix this
let's actually put a correct price let's
say six
then i'll hit save
so back to front end
we'll send the fetch request
and now we hit the catalog microservice
because the validation succeeded so the
controller is actually being hit now
so this will go ahead and as you know it
will execute the logic to create the
item and then publish that item into the
message broker and write in writing
queue so that the other microservices
can get notice of this
so i'll hit continue
then we're back into the front end
and this time if we expand the response
we can see that we got expected 201
and then we hit continue and
back into the browser the item has been
created browse shield basic shield with
price six
okay
so what about editing an existing item
so to edit an item all you have to do is
click on the read button here
and this will allow you to perform the
edit
but before actually going through the
editing scenario let me actually just go
ahead and
remove all these breakpoints since i
think we get the idea now of how
communication is flowing across places
so let me go to the breakpoints and just
remove all of them
over here and also in the catalog
microservice
so i'm going to go ahead and
remove all breakpoints okay
so
now back to the front end the edit
edit logic is happening if we go back
into
uh yeah in item form
so that is happening in the
update update adding method
so here's where again we call the fetch
method
with the
uh
the url of the rest api plus the id of
the current item
so double go ahead do the fetch
operation
and then later we'll get a response over
here so let's see how that that works in
real life
over here i'm going to just bump the
price from 6 to
and then i'll just hit save
and the edit has been performed
notice how
things never reload here like the page
is never really reloading it's just a
react component that's fetching the
updated data and putting it dynamically
into the same page that we're always
working on
then we can also try the delete scenario
and that happens if we go back into
front end
that is happening
directly into the catalog catalog.js
file
there is a section
called delete item that's invoked by
that red delete button see there's going
to be a confirmation then it invokes the
catalog api with the id of the of the
item and then it performs the delete and
also it removes it from the client state
so to see that in action let's go back
to the client
and then i'll actually like to keep this
bronze shield and the other items so
what i'll do is i'll create quickly
another one let's just call it
delete me
deleting description
and then i'll say price for right so
i'll save this item items created and
for the delete operation all you have to
do is click on delete
there's going to be a delete
confirmation box here click ok and the
item is gone
and you can always confirm that these
are actually happening in the server
side by refreshing the browser and you
can see that the items are actually gone
and of course you can also take a look
at the
database now how about granting an item
to a user which a touches basis with the
inventory side so
to do that what you can do is use this
grant booth over here so let's say i'm
going to grant this bronze shield to a
user
so i'll click on grant
and this pops up this model dialog to
grant an item
now in this in this dialogue what i have
done is i have made it so that anytime
you open it it's going to populate some
random code for some random user id
remember we don't have the console of
the users really here so it's just a
random user id so just like we did a
random user in postman now there's this
page is uh presenting a random user id
run good here
and also there's a quantity that you can
increase or decrease as as needed
now this here is
is happening back in in the front end is
happening in the grant item form
js file over here
here is where
uh we can actually do a breakpoint for
this one uh this is where
we will invoke the inventory items api
uh with the data that we have about this
item and then the uh inventory service
is going to take care of granting the
item to the user so if you go back to
them to the browser and we say let's say
we're going to grant two of the potion
actually two of the grand brown to the
brown shield to the user i'll say grant
and then if you go back here in grant
item form
we can see that the inventory items a
url is going to be invoked this time is
5005 slash items
and that is going to use the user id
that we specified in the client side
the catalog item id which is right here
and the quantity
which is two
and just to lose it i'm going to
actually going to grab this user id
i'm going to copy this one
so that we can query for it later
and then uh yeah i'll hit continue
and that would have granted the item to
the user
now there's no visual representation of
that completion uh in in this page but
that's why we have this other page for
inventory so let's go to the inventory
section
over here
and here is where you can
paste that user id and you can get
inventory for the user now all the logic
here is happening if you go back to
to the front end this is happening
actually in dumb
inventory.js page so this is the page
that
is going to allow us to populate items
based on this
in on the enter user id
that's going to go ahead and talk to
inventory api with that user id and that
brings back all the items that are in
the user's inventory pack
which is rendered over here in this
section render items table
to go back to the browser we'll just hit
get inventory and there you go
the current inventory for the user is
presented in this case just bronze
shield
now once again it's also interesting to
see what happens if there's an update if
an update happens to this item right
would the the ui be able to to reflect
the fact that inventory needs to have
updated data from the catalog uh when it
happens would that take too much time
how about that render so let's see so we
have bronze shield it's name bronze
shield basic shield quantity two so
let's go back to the catalog
and we're going to edit the bronze
shield
uh
and we're going to change the name
so instead of having it as bronze shield
we'll just call it
a
basic shield
right
and perhaps we'll also update the price
let's say it's nine
and so so now the bronze shield is named
basic shield so hit save
and i'll go back to inventory and i'll
query again for the items of this user
that we just
use a granted inventory to so hit get
inventory and as you can see
the name has changed to basic shield
that means that as soon as we perform
the update in the catalog microservice
that was immediately
replicated via a synchronous message
into the inventory service and
eventually is now able to present the
updated
name of the shield in this case basic
shield and that happened really fast
so there you go
we have gone through all the
sections in this basic front-end user
interface
so that marks the end of this model
and you have connected a modern single
page application built with react and
hosted in node.js
with your two.net based mic services to
light up a basic end-to-end scenario
and you learned all about cores along
the way
i hope you enjoyed building this system
with me so far
congratulations you made it till the end
i really hope the course met your
expectations and gave you a good sense
of how to get started building
microservices with a.net platform
please consider hitting the like button
if you got value out of this and don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
know right away when i publish new
videos
now microservices development is a huge
topic and this course only covers the
tip of the iceberg if you want to become
a microservices developer and you are
considering this architecture style for
a real world project you will need to
master many other techniques and
patterns essential for distributed
systems development
also as you move your system to a
cloud-based environment you will need to
add many other pieces to your tech stack
to ensure the microservices can be built
and deployed quickly to scale the system
to meet the production demands and to
have the tools to monitor and diagnose
the services when things don't go as
expected
to cover all these topics i created the
buildingmicroserviceswith.net complete
learning pad which expands what you saw
in these basic skirts with dozens of
additional lessons that will teach you
step by step how to add all the building
blocks needed for the complete
microservices-based application and how
to take everything to a production
environment in the cloud
if you are interested please check out
the links below to get all the details
on this premium offering
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]